THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON FUEL
SUPPLY AND PRICE SPIKES WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON.
WE'RE HOLDING THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY IN THE Þ STREET BUILDING.
I'M ASKING ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO ARE NOT HERE RIGHT
NOW TO REPORT TO ROOM 2100 SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE HAVE
ONE BILL ON TODAY'S AGENDA, AND
THAT BILL IS AB TWO ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART. BEFORE WE
HEAR THE BILL, SECRETARY, LET'S
CALL ROLL. ESTABLISH THE QUORUM.
BRADFORD HERE. BRADFORD HERE.
DELHI HERE. DALLY HERE. ASHBY
HERE. ASHBY. HERE. BECKER.
BECKER. HERE. BLAKE. SPHERE.
GONZALEZ. HERE. GONZALEZ. HERE.
LAIRD. HERE. LAIRD. HERE. LEMON.
LEMON. HERE. CIERTO. CIERTO
HERE. SCANNER. HERE. SKINNER.
HERE. STERN. STERN. HERE. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. AND I'M GOING
TO ASK OUR AUTHOR TO COME
FORWARD TO THE TABLE. BUT BEFORE
WE HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR, I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SOME BRIEF
COMMENTS. THIS IS THE SECOND
TIME IN AS MANY YEARS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS CALLED A SPECIAL
SESSION TO ADDRESS GASOLINE
PRICE SPIKES. LAST YEAR WE
PASSED SB ONE TWO, WHICH
AFFORDED THE ADMINISTRATION
SPECIFICALLY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND NEW DIVISION OF
PETROLEUM MARKET OVERSIGHT WITH
MANY NEW POWERS TO ADDRESS
GASOLINE PRICE SPIKES. MY
STANDING COMMITTEE HELD AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON THIS TOPIC
EARLIER THIS YEAR TO CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THE DEVELOPMENTS BY THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS FRONT.
THE GENERAL VIEW IS THERE IS
STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
IMPLEMENTED AS IT RELATES TO
MANY OF THESE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION, THOUGH I KNOW THE
CDC HAS BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY
AND HARD TO ADDRESS THEM.
HOWEVER, I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
ESTABLISHED AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO INFORM THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE POLICIES,
PARTICULARLY AS THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE IS INTENDED TO HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
WORKFORCE. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT ALL
MEMBERS HERE ON THIS DAIS AND IN
BOTH HOUSES SHARE OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT PRICE OF GASOLINE AND THE
IMPACT IT HAS ON ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT HOUSEHOLD BUDGETS CAN BE
HIGHLY IMPACTED BY THE COSTS OF
FUELING UP AT THE PUMP AND THE
RIPPLE EFFECTS GASOLINE PRICES
HAVE ON PRICES OF PRODUCE AND
OTHER GOODS. EVEN AS THE STATE
IS ATTEMPTING TO TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES,
INCLUDING ELECTRIC VEHICLES,
MANY OF OUR RESIDENTS RELY AND
WILL CONTINUE TO RELY ON
GASOLINE FUEL FOR MANY DECADES
TO COME. I BEING ONE OF THEM.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE AND
RELIABLE GASOLINE THAT SET PRICE
SPIKES ARE ONLY ONE ASPECT OF
THE GASOLINE FUEL STORY. WE MUST
ALSO BE MINDFUL OF ALL THE
POLICIES THAT AFFECT THE PRICE
OF GASOLINE, AND ENSURE THAT
THEY DO NOT HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES, NOT JUST ON THE
PRICE OF GASOLINE, BUT BUT ALSO
ON THE SAFETY OF THE WORKFORCE.
OPERATING THESE REFINERIES OF
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE
ADJACENT TO THESE REFINERIES, AS
WELL. THESE ARE THE LENSES THAT
I'M USING WHEN I REVIEW THESE
TRANSPORTATION FUEL POLICY
PROPOSALS, PARTICULARLY GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THERE ARE FOUR
REFINERIES IN MY DISTRICT. THESE
REFINERIES PROVIDE MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS TO MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS
AND ARE IMPORTANT DRIVERS OF THE
ECONOMY, ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
AND REALLY, SINCE THE FOUNDING
OF MANY OF OUR CITIES, LOS
ANGELES COUNTY, INCLUDING CARSON,
EL SEGUNDO AND OTHERS, AGAIN,
THESE CITIES WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
FOUNDED IF IT WASN'T FOR THESE
REFINERIES. I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE PRESENTATION TODAY AND HOPE
THAT WE GET SOME ASSURANCES,
ASSURANCES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT ADDRESSING
MY CONCERNS AS WELL AS MY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO SAFETY FOR WORKERS
AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES. ON THAT
NOTE, SENATOR HART, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M
SORRY, ASSEMBLYMAN. I MIGHT HAVE
DEMOTED HIM. EVERYBODY KNEW WHAT
YOU MEANT. THERE FOR SURE. THANK
YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, TO BEGIN,
I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS. THE GOVERNOR CALLED
THIS SECOND EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION TO ADDRESS ONE GOAL.
REDUCE GASOLINE PRICES FOR
CALIFORNIANS. SINCE THE PASSAGE
OF LAST YEAR'S SB ONE TWO BY
SENATOR SKINNER, THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION AND THE
DIVISION OF PETROLEUM MARKET
OVERSIGHT HAVE HAVE GAINED
CRITICAL INSIGHTS INTO REFINERY
OPERATIONS AND GAS PRICE TRENDS
IN CALIFORNIA. GAS PRICES
SURPASSED $6 PER GALLON LAST
SEPTEMBER, COSTING CONSUMERS AN
EXTRA $2.2 BILLION AT THE PUMP.
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS, IN THE
EARLY FALL, GAS PRICES HAVE
SURGED. AT THE SAME TIME,
REFINERIES WENT DOWN FOR
MAINTENANCE. AB TWO ONE
CLARIFIES AND BUILDS ON LAW FROM
LAST YEAR REQUIRING REFINERIES
TO SUBMIT RESUPPLY PLANS TO THE
CEC IN ADVANCE OF MAINTENANCE OR
TURNAROUND EVENTS. THE BILL
GRANTS THE CEC THE AUTHORITY TO
OPEN A FORMAL RULEMAKING PROCESS
TO DETERMINE WHETHER REQUIRING
MINIMUM INVENTORY LEVELS OF
FUELS WOULD BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. THE PROPOSED CEC
REGULATIONS WILL ONLY BE ADOPTED
IF THEY ARE PROVEN TO REDUCE
OVERALL GASOLINE PRICES,
INCREASE FUEL SUPPLY, AND CURB
MARKET VOLATILITY. LET ME BE
CLEAR. AB 2-1 DOES NOT PROHIBIT
A REFINERY FROM CONDUCTING
IMPORTANT MAINTENANCE. REFINERS
CAN AND SHOULD PERFORM THE
MAINTENANCE THEY NEED TO KEEP
THEIR WORKERS AND FACILITIES
SAFE. AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE MAKE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKERS SAFETY AND
EXISTING LAW ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
MOREOVER, LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
IS IMPERATIVE. THE CEC IS
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT AN ANNUAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE,
REEVALUATING THE NEED FOR
REGULATIONS. THE MINIMUM
INVENTORY REGULATIONS. SUNSET ON
JANUARY 1ST, 2033, WHERE IT WILL
COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THE GOAL IS SIMPLE GUARANTEE
THAT FUEL RESERVES ARE READILY
AVAILABLE FOR CONSUMERS DURING
MAINTENANCE EVENTS AND SUPPLY
CONSTRAINTS. THIS BILL
INCENTIVIZES FUEL REFINERS TO
PLAN PROACTIVELY, SAVING
CALIFORNIA GASOLINE CONSUMERS
BILLIONS AT THE PUMP WHILE
KEEPING PROFITS FOR OIL
COMPANIES. I'M PLEASED TO AUTHOR
THIS BILL, SPONSORED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
BONTA, ALONGSIDE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND SENATOR SKINNER.
GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATORS. I WILL
KEEP THIS VERY SHORT. MY
COLLEAGUE AND JOINT AUTHOR FROM
SANTA BARBARA HAS COVERED THE
MAIN POINTS VERY WELL. THIS BILL
SETS UP A REGULATORY PROCESS TO
AVOID REFINERY GAS SUPPLY
IMBALANCES THAT CAUSES OF PRICE
SPIKES IN OUR STATE. IT DOES
THIS WHILE ASSURING THE PROCESS
PLACES A FIRST TIER PRIORITY ON
MAINTAINING IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF REFINERY WORKERS AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE THOROUGH PUBLIC PROCESS THAT
GOT US HERE. THE ASSEMBLY
CONDUCTED AN HISTORIC AMOUNT OF
TESTIMONY FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
PARTICIPATION BY THE MEMBERS OF
THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PETROLEUM AND GASOLINE SUPPLY
DURING THE. DURING THE THREE
DAYS OF EXTENSIVE HEARINGS. IN
TOTAL, THE COMMITTEE SPENT OVER
14 HOURS ON THIS BILL HEARING
FROM EXPERTS IN THE INDUSTRY,
LABOR, ECONOMICS, ACADEMIA, AND
OUR OWN STATE ENERGY PERSONNEL.
WE CAN RARELY MAKE EVERYONE
HAPPY WITH THE WORK WE DO IN
THIS LEGISLATURE, BUT I DO FEEL
PROUD THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL, EMBODIED IN AB TWO,
RECEIVE THE ATTENTION AND
SCRUTINY IT DESERVES. THE MANY
AMENDMENTS WE'VE TAKEN DURING
THE SECOND EXTRAORDINARY SESSION
MAKE THIS SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER
PRODUCT AND ARE A TESTAMENT TO
THE PROCESS THAT BROUGHT US
BEFORE YOU HERE TODAY. THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS NEGOTIATED
BY THE GOVERNOR, THE SPEAKER,
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM, THAT WE
ALL WILL BE ACCEPTING HERE
TODAY, MAKE IT EVEN MORE
PRODUCTIVE, PROTECTIVE OF OUR
REFINERY WORKERS, NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES AND GAS CONSUMERS.
FOR THAT REASON, SENATORS, I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
NOW WE'LL MOVE TO LEAD WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT. I SEE WE HAVE THE
VICE CHAIR, PLEASE. YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR. AUTHORS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT WORK
THAT'S IN FRONT OF YOU. THROUGH
THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE TWO LAST
YEAR, THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION WAS TASKED WITH
IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITIES TO
SHED LIGHT ON THE CAUSES BEHIND
GASOLINE PRICE SPIKES AND TO
DEVELOP OPTIONS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST THEM. OVER
THE PAST YEAR, WE HAVE GAINED
INVALUABLE INSIGHTS INTO
CALIFORNIA'S PETROLEUM INDUSTRY,
AND WE CAN NOW CLEARLY ESTABLISH
THAT AT THE HEART OF PRICE
SPIKES IS A LACK OF HEALTHY
LEVELS OF LIQUIDITY IN THE
MARKET, ESPECIALLY DURING LATE
SUMMER MONTHS WHEN DEMAND FOR
GASOLINE IS AT ITS HIGHEST. THIS
SITUATION IS FURTHER EXACERBATED
WHEN THE. WHEN CONFRONTED,
CONFRONTED BY LOSS PRODUCTION
DUE TO PLANNED AND UNPLANNED
REFINERY OUTAGES THAT ARE COMMON
DURING THIS PERIOD. THE
RESULTING SUPPLY TIGHTNESS IN
THE MARKET LEADS TO INDUSTRY
SCRAMBLING TO SECURE SUPPLY THAT
DRIVES UP PRICES IN THE SPOT
MARKET AND ULTIMATELY AT THE
PUMP. LIKE ANY FOR PROFIT
COMPANY, REFINERS SEEK TO
MAXIMIZE THEIR PROFITS WITHIN
THE MARKET AND REGULATORY
STRUCTURES THEY OPERATE UNDER,
AND THE CURRENT STRUCTURES DO
NOT INCENTIVIZE THEM TO MAINTAIN
NECESSARY MARKET LIQUIDITY THAT
PROTECTS CONSUMERS FROM PRICE
SPIKES. AT THE HEART OF AB 21 IS
MAXIMIZING PROACTIVE PLANNING
USING EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ENHANCE RESILIENCY IN THE SYSTEM
AND REDUCE REACTIVE BEHAVIOR BY
INDUSTRY DURING SUPPLY TIGHTNESS
THAT ULTIMATELY HURTS CONSUMERS.
ANY REQUIREMENTS ON REFINERS
WOULD BE DEVELOPED THROUGH A
THOROUGH AND A TRANSPARENT
PUBLIC RULEMAKING PROCESS. SP
ONE TWO ALREADY REQUIRES THE CEC
TO CONSULT WITH LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY, AS
WELL AS LABOR AND INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS, IN CONSIDERING
WAYS TO MANAGE NECESSARY
REFINERY TURNAROUNDS AND
MAINTENANCE THAT WOULD PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
EMPLOYEES AND THE PUBLIC. AB 21
MAKES NO CHANGES TO EXISTING
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS AT REFINERIES,
REFINERIES AND REQUIRES ANY
REGULATION ADOPTED TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
EMPLOYEES, LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
THE PUBLIC. ANY MINIMUM
INVENTORY REQUIREMENT WILL BE
DEVELOPED BASED ON EXISTING
STORAGE INFRASTRUCTURE. CDC DATA
SUGGESTS THAT CALIFORNIA
REFINERIES CUMULATIVELY HAVE
SUFFICIENT NET USABLE GASOLINE
STORAGE CAPACITY WITHIN THE
REFINERY GATES TO MEET ABOUT
15.5 DAYS OF TYPICAL CALIFORNIA
DEMAND. ADDING NEW, USABLE
GASOLINE STORAGE AND STORAGE
CAPACITY OUTSIDE OF REFINERY
GATES. THAT NUMBER GOES UP TO
ABOUT 24 DAYS. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT CEC HAS BEEN USING
15 DAYS OF SUPPLY AS A NUMBER
WHERE WE BEGIN TO SEE THE PRICE
SPIKES. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THOSE 15 DAYS, ABOUT 1 TO 2 DAYS
OF THAT IS REFINERY PRODUCTION
AND IMPORTS COMING INTO THE
STATE. SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ROUGHLY 13 DAYS OF REFINERY
STORAGE TYPICALLY. SO UNDER THIS
RULEMAKING PROCESS, WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE MAXIMIZE
EXISTING INVENTORY TO IMPROVE
LIQUIDITY. OUR ANALYSIS SHOWS
THAT THE POTENTIAL COST SAVINGS
TO CONSUMERS IN AVOIDING PRICE
SPIKES FAR OUTWEIGH THE COST TO
REFINERS. FOR INCREASING
INVENTORY TO MAINTAIN LIQUIDITY
IN THE MARKET. TAKING THE 2023
PRICE SPIKE AS AN EXAMPLE. CEC
ANALYSIS ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT
100 MILLION ADDITIONAL GALLONS
OF GASOLINE COULD HAVE
MAINTAINED MARKET LIQUIDITY
ABOVE 15 DAYS OF SUPPLY. IN THAT
SCENARIO, IF REFINERS BUY LOW
AND SELL HIGH, THEY COULD MAKE A
PROFIT ON THIS EXTRA INVENTORY.
IF GAS PRICES WERE TO DROP ABOUT
$0.25 PER GALLON. THE ADDITIONAL
INVENTORY COST WOULD BE ABOUT
$25 MILLION. THE 2023 PRICE
SPIKES ESTIMATED DIRECT COST TO
CONSUMERS, MEANWHILE, WAS AT
LEAST $1 BILLION. THIS DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE INDIRECT ECONOMY
WIDE IMPACTS, AS THE COST OF
GOODS AND SERVICES ALSO INCREASE
WHEN GAS PRICES GO UP. IN
CLOSING, THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WILL PROVIDE THE CEC WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO OPEN A RULEMAKING
TO DO A DEEPER ANALYSIS INTO TWO
CONCEPTS THAT COULD ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A HEALTHY FUEL
SUPPLY AND STABILIZE PRICES FOR
CONSUMERS. PAY AT THE PUMP STOCK
MINIMUMS FOR REFINERS AND
RESUPPLY PLANNING FOR PLANNED
TURNAROUNDS AND MAINTENANCE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AB 21. ANY
REQUIREMENTS ON REFINERIES WOULD
ONLY BE ESTABLISHED IF BENEFITS
ARE FOUND TO SIGNIFICANTLY
OUTWEIGH COSTS. THIS RULEMAKING
WOULD BE A PUBLIC PROCESS, AND
THE CEC IS COMMITTED TO WORKING
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH INTERESTED
PARTIES, INCLUDING INDUSTRY,
LABOR AND COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES, TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS, WORKERS
AND RESIDENTS ARE PROTECTED.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. OUR OTHER
EXPERT WITNESS IS DIRECTOR TIM
MILLER OF THE DIVISION OF
PETROLEUM MARKET OVERSIGHT,
WHO'S BEEN WORKING WITH VICE
CHAIR, GUNDAM FOR THE PAST YEAR
ON THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS TY MILLER, DIRECTOR OF
THE DIVISION OF PETROLEUM MARKET
OVERSIGHT. THANK YOU. TO THE
CHAIR, TO THE AUTHORS OF THE
BILL, TO THE VICE CHAIR. TWO
YEARS AGO, THE SENATE PASSED SB
ONE TWO, WHICH CREATED THE NEW
DIVISION AND GAVE THE CEC
CRITICAL NEW TRANSPARENCY TOOLS
TO SEE INFORMATION THAT BEFORE
WAS OPAQUE. THANKS TO THESE NEW
TOOLS, WE KNOW WHAT CAUSES THESE
UNIQUE PRICE SPIKES IN
CALIFORNIA. THE DATA IS CLEAR.
LOW INVENTORY LEVELS COMBINED
WITH PLANNED AND UNPLANNED
MAINTENANCE LEADS TO PRICE
SPIKES. WE'VE SEEN THAT PATTERN
NOW THREE YEARS IN A ROW VERY
CLEARLY AT THE ASSEMBLY
HEARINGS, DPMO PRESENTED DATA
SHOWING THAT THESE PRICE SPIKES
AREN'T NORMAL. THEY DON'T HAPPEN
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
WE SHARED GRAPHS SHOWING THAT
CALIFORNIA PRICES CAN SPIKE EVEN
AS CRUDE OIL PRICES ARE GOING
DOWN. AND WHEN PRICES ARE GOING
DOWN IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY. IT'S A BASIC STORY OF
SUPPLY AND DEMAND. WHEN SUPPLIES
ARE ALLOWED TO GET LOW, PRICES
SHOOT UP AND SO DO PROFITS. WE
HAVE A HIGHLY CONCENTRATED
REFINING SECTOR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, AND THAT THAT
CONCENTRATED MARKET DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH INCENTIVE TO PREVENT
PRICE SPIKES. I THINK CONSUMERS
ARE RIGHTLY SICK AND TIRED OF
PAYING INFLATED PRICES DURING
PRICE SPIKES, AND AB TWO ONE IS
A TARGETED SOLUTION THAT'S BEEN
ENDORSED BY INDEPENDENT
ECONOMISTS. THREE QUICK POINTS.
PREVENTING PRICE SPIKES LOWERS
PRICES AT THE PUMP. WE PRESENTED
DATA SHOWING THAT IF YOU AVOID A
PRICE SPIKE IN ONE YEAR, COULD
BE AS HIGH AS $2 BILLION IN
SAVINGS. THAT EQUATES TO ABOUT
$0.15 PER GALLON FOR EVERY
CONSUMER. EVERY TIME THEY GO TO
A GAS STATION IN A YEAR. SECOND,
REFINERS HAVE EXISTING EXCESS
STORAGE CAPACITY. THIS IS STATE
AND FEDERAL DATA SHOWING THAT
CALIFORNIA REFINERS ALREADY HAVE
MILLIONS OF BARRELS OF UNUSED
STORAGE CAPACITY. THIRD, THE
BILL PROTECTS WORKER SAFETY AND
STRENGTHENS EXISTING LAW. THE
AMENDED BILL EXPLICITLY REQUIRES
THAT ANY RESUPPLY AND MINIMUM
INVENTORY REGULATION MUST
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
EMPLOYEES, LOCAL COMMUNITIES,
AND THE PUBLIC. THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE IN THIS BILL BUTTRESS
EXISTING LAW, SO ANY FUTURE CSC
RULEMAKING WOULD NEED TO FOLLOW
THOSE LEGAL DIRECTIVES. THERE IS
NO TRADE OFF HERE BETWEEN WORKER
SAFETY, COMMUNITY SAFETY AND
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. THIS LAW
WILL DO BOTH. WE NEED TO SEE
MORE SUPPLY AND MARKET LIQUIDITY
AT CRITICAL TIMES OF YEARS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM PRICE
SPIKES, AND THAT WILL HELP THE
ECONOMY OVERALL WITH STABILITY
AND PREDICTABILITY FOR PLANNING
AND RESERVE ALSO HELPS
RESILIENCY. IF THERE'S A NATURAL
DISASTER OR SOME OTHER KIND OF
INTERNATIONAL EVENT. THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE SOLUTION THAT'S
BEEN DEVELOPED BY, THAT'S BEEN
ADOPTED BY, DEVELOPED COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD. AND WITH THIS
LEGISLATION, YOU CAN CONTINUE
THE CRITICAL WORK OF SBX. ONE
TWO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE. YOU CAN COME TO
THE PODIUM AND STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. DANIEL BROD, ON
BEHALF OF UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT. ALEXA
CHÁVEZ ON BEHALF OF UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND OUR OVER
1800, 180,000 HOME CARE AND
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHRISTINA
SCARINGE WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, REBECCA MARCUS
ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER WATCHDOG
AND THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
POLICY CENTER AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF LAW AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CASSANDRA MÀ WITH
NEMA LÀ PAPPAS AND ASSOCIATES,
ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR A
SAFE AND HEALTHY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HELLO. MATT
LASHER WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M
NORMAN ROGERS WITH US LOCAL 675.
AND ACTUALLY, I HAVE COMMENTS
THAT ARE NEITHER SUPPORT OR SIT
IN THE MIDDLE. AND WE WIENER I
GUESS I AM. THANK YOU. I AM A
TWEENER. WOULD I HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK FURTHER?
WE'VE HAD OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
ON ON THIS MEASURE, SO IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION, WE'LL HAVE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK. BUT BUT WE HAVEN'T A LOT
OF TIME FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE. OKAY.
WE'LL COME BACK AND GIVE IT
ANOTHER TRY. OKAY. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANY? I'M SORRY. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE? YOU CAN COME TO
THE MICROPHONE AT THIS TIME.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE. NOW
WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION. DO WE
HAVE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? YES, IF WE COULD.
YEAH. ALL RIGHT. I DON'T KNOW IF
WE HAVE SEATS FOR EVERYONE, BUT.
OKAY.
WHAT? OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I GAVE THEM THREE MINUTES, BUT
ACCORDING TO OUR TIME, IT WAS
ABOUT EIGHT MINUTES. SO I WILL
AFFORD YOU BOTH FOUR MINUTES
APIECE. WELL, THANK YOU,
SENATORS. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ZACH LEARY WITH THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION HERE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB, X2 DASH ONE.
LAST YEAR, THE FOCUS OF THE
SPECIAL SESSION WAS ON PRICE
GOUGING AND THE DATA THAT'S
COMING INTO THE CEC THAT'S BEING
PUBLICLY REPORTED ON THEIR
WEBSITE IS JUST NOT SHOWING THAT
FACT. IN FACT, THE DATA IS
SHOWING THAT REFINERIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE LOSING MONEY
MONTH TO MONTH. THERE ARE MONTHS
WHERE THEY MAKE MONEY, BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF MONTHS WHERE THEY
ARE LOSING MONEY. AND THE LAST
SPECIAL SESSION, YOU, AS THE
LEGISLATURE, I THINK, HAD THE
WISDOM TO REJECT THE PROPOSAL
FROM THE INCEPTION AND INSTEAD
REQUIRED THAT THE BILL FOCUS ON
COLLECTING DATA FROM THE
INDUSTRY, CRAFTING MULTIPLE
STUDIES FOR LEGISLATIVE REVIEW,
ONE THAT'S IN FRONT OF US TODAY,
THE TRANSPORTATION FUEL IS
ASSESSMENT. YOU ALSO HAD HAD THE
WISDOM TO CREATE THE INDEPENDENT
CONSUMER FUELS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THAT WAS NEVER FILLED. AND SO
NEVER MET, CONVENED OR ADVISED
THE CEC. WE THOUGHT THAT THAT
WAS AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
PROCESS, AND I JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SB ONE TWO HAS BEEN REALLY
DIFFICULT ON COLLABORATION. WE,
AS A TRADE ASSOCIATION HAVE
TRIED TO ENGAGE. WE'VE REQUESTED
RULEMAKINGS FOUR TIMES FOR
CLARITY ON THE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEING TRIED TO BE
COLLECTED. UNFORTUNATELY, ALL
FOUR TIMES THOSE REQUESTS WERE
DENIED. WE HAVE ALSO WRITTEN
OVER 30 COMMENT LETTERS TO THE
DOCKET VERY EXTENSIVE QUESTIONS
ON UNDERSTANDING THE PROCESS AND
ON. UNFORTUNATELY, THOSE HAVE
NOT BEEN RESPONDED TO AND WE
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS CONCERN
THAT IF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
2-1 IS ANYTHING LIKE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB ONE TWO,
THERE SHOULD BE DEFINITE
CONCERNS FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
SO NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT TWO
YEAR PROCESS, MULTI YEAR
COLLECTING DATA, YOU'RE BEING
PRESENTED WITH AN IDEA THAT WAS
ACTUALLY PRESENTED 20 YEARS AGO
BY THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
LOCKYER ON A STORAGE REQUIREMENT
FOR GASOLINE. THE CEC ACTUALLY
DETERMINED 20 YEARS AGO IT WAS A
BAD IDEA. AND SAID TO REJECT IT.
AND WE BELIEVE IT'S EVEN A WORSE
IDEA NOW. WE ACTUALLY ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS IN
THE TRANSPORTATION FUELS
ASSESSMENT THAT STATE THE
PROPOSAL COULD CREATE ARTIFICIAL
SHORTAGES AND RESULT IN EVERYDAY
GAS PRICES TO RAISE. IN THE
ASSEMBLY, WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THE MATH AND THE MATH OF THIS
WORKING OUT. I THINK THERE ARE A
COUPLE VARIABLES I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT I THINK ARE
MISSING AS IT RELATES TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL
VARIABLE. ONE HOW MANY DAYS OF
STORAGE ARE WE TALKING? ARE WE
TALKING ONE DAY OF STORAGE,
WHICH IS ABOUT 35 MILLION
GALLONS OF GASOLINE? OR ARE WE
TALKING 15 DAYS OF STORAGE,
WHICH IS HALF A BILLION GALLONS
OF GASOLINE? AND WHAT ARE THE
CARRYING COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
STORING THAT KIND OF FUEL
VARIABLE? TWO HOW IS THIS NEWLY
INTRODUCED TRADING MECHANISM
GOING TO WORK? WE THINK OF IT AS
LIKE CAP AND TRADE OR LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD. THAT'S TRADING
TRADING CARBON CREDITS. THIS
WOULD BE TRADING ACTUAL PHYSICAL
SPACE IN BARRELS. WE THINK THAT
COULD PUT FOLKS AT A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE OR DISADVANTAGE IN THE
MARKET. AND IF THIS RESULTS IN
REFINERS HAVING TO BE FORCED TO
LEASE PRIVATE STORAGE SPACE,
WELL GUESS WHAT. RENT JUST WENT
UP FOR THAT STORAGE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE A
DEMAND. AND THEN VARIABLE THREE
AND FOUR. WHAT IS THE MARKET
IMPACT GOING TO BE TO
WITHHOLDING FUEL FROM FROM
CONSUMERS. WE THINK THERE'S
GOING TO BE THAT IS SUPPLY AND
DEMAND. AND THEN OUR FOURTH,
FOURTH VARIABLE THAT WE SEE AS A
BIG CONCERN ON THE OPERATIONS
SIDE IS NOW STORAGE REQUIREMENTS
WILL CREATE A PINCH POINT IN THE
SYSTEM AND SLOW DOWN PRODUCTION.
WE REMAIN FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSED
TO THE PROPOSAL. WE BELIEVE,
GIVING THE LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
TO YET ANOTHER STATE AGENCY TO
RAISE EVERYDAY GAS PRICES IS NOT
A GOOD IDEA FOR CONSUMERS. WE
ALREADY HAVE ONE STATE AGENCY
DOING THAT, THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE IN THE PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, JEREMY SMITH, HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA. IN OPPOSITION,
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
ONE. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU,
MISTER CHAIR, YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE TIME YOU HAVE
GIVEN US AND OUR MEMBERS IN MANY
OTHER CONVERSATIONS ON AB TWO
ONE TO HEAR THEIR AND OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL.
SAME GOES TO THE MAJORITY LEADER
AND MISTER HART AS WELL. THANK
YOU. WE ARE HERE ON BEHALF OF
OUR MEMBERS WHO WILL BE WHO YOU
WILL HEAR FROM SHORTLY, THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AB TWO ONE AUTHORIZES THE CEC TO
REQUIRE REFINERIES TO PROVIDE A
SUPPLY PLAN THAT WILL OSTENSIBLY
AVOID PRICE INCREASES TO THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION FUELS
MARKET BEFORE GETTING APPROVAL
TO PERFORM A TURNAROUND OR
MAINTENANCE EVENT FOR THE SAFETY
AND HEALTH AND HEALTH OF OUR
MEMBERS, MANY OF WHOM, AGAIN,
YOU WILL HEAR FROM TODAY, THIS
IS A NONSTARTER. OUR MEMBERS ARE
INSIDE CALIFORNIA'S REFINERIES
AND HAVE WORKED OVER 33,000,000
HOURS OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS,
SAFELY WHILE PROVIDING FOR THEIR
FAMILIES, WHICH OFFERS THEM A
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON HOW
GASOLINE IS PRODUCED AND HOW
THIS MAINTENANCE AFFECTS
CALIFORNIA REFINERIES.
MAINTENANCE MUST BE DONE ON A
SCHEDULE BASED ONLY ON THE
CONDITION OF METALS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE LIFE
CYCLE OF EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
VESSELS, PIPES AND VALVES. THE
SAFETY OF OUR MEMBERS WORKING IN
REFINERIES, THE SAFETY OF OTHER
WORKERS AND REFINERIES AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES MUST NOT
BE JEOPARDIZED. ON MARKET AND
PRICING CONSIDERATIONS, WE AGREE
WITH THE INDUSTRY THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS TO STORE FUEL TO
MITIGATE INCREASED CONSUMER
COSTS THAT A MAINTENANCE OR
TURNAROUND EVENT MAY CAUSE, WILL
LEAD TO THE INABILITY TO DO
MAINTENANCE, LEADING TO
SHUTDOWNS, CLOSURES,
CATASTROPHIC FAILURES, INJURIES
OR DEATH. AND MASSIVE JOB LOSSES
DURING A TURNAROUND. THERE IS A
RUSH MENTALITY BY OUR MEMBERS.
REFINERIES LOSE MONEY FOR EVERY
MINUTE THE REFINERY IS DOWN FOR
MAINTENANCE. HOWEVER, DELAYED
MAINTENANCE OR MAINTENANCE
TURNAROUNDS SCHEDULED FOR
ANYTHING OTHER THAN
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND THE
WEAR AND TEAR OF A REFINERY
ENDANGER OUR MEMBERS SAFETY AND
HEALTH AND COULD LEAD TO
CATASTROPHIC BREAKDOWNS THAT
WILL PUT WORKERS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES AT RISK. THIS BILL
COULD HAVE LOOKED TO INVESTIGATE
SOLUTIONS TO THE GAS PRICING IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT SEIZING
BUREAUCRATIC JURISDICTION OVER
THE SCHEDULING OF REFINERY
TURNAROUNDS. INSTEAD, THE BILL
WILL IMPART UNPRECEDENTED
AUTHORITY TO THE CEC, PUTTING
OUR MEMBERS HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
THEIR HANDS. FURTHERMORE, IT IS
YET ANOTHER ATTEMPT TO RUN
REFINERS OUT OF THE STATE,
TAKING THOUSANDS OF CAREERS FOR
OUR MEMBERS WITH THEM. THE
MINIMUM INVENTORY LEVELS THE
BILL AUTHORIZES THE CEC TO
DEVELOP LIKELY CANNOT BE
COMPLIED WITH WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
TANK TANKS BEING CONSTRUCTED
WITH NO CONSIDERATION FOR SPACE
OR THE REALITY THAT THEY CAN
NEVER BE PERMITTED. COMMUNITIES
LIKE TORRANCE, RICHMOND AND
OTHERS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
WOULD NOT BE ACCEPTING OF
ADDITIONAL TANK STORAGE FOR
GASOLINE AND OTHER REFINED FUELS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES, YET THE
BILL EXPECTS THE INDUSTRY TO
COME UP WITH A WAY TO USE
EXISTING STORAGE THAT IS ALREADY
USED FOR THE PROCESS OF REFINING
THIS HOBSON'S CHOICE FOR OUR
EMPLOYERS ONLY ENDANGERS OUR
MEMBERS CAREERS AND THEIR HEALTH
AND SAFETY. THIS BILL,
UNFORTUNATELY, DOES NOT
DEMONSTRATE AN ABILITY TO LOWER
PRICES WHILE MAINTAINING SAFETY
AND RELIABILITY. WHILE WE HAVE
BEEN INFORMED WHILE THERE ARE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND WE
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE TIME WE
WERE ALLOWED WITH STAFF AND
MEMBERS IN THIS HOUSE AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO TALK THROUGH THOSE
AMENDMENTS, WE MUST REMAIN
OPPOSED TO AB 21. THANK YOU. NOW
WE'LL OPEN UP THE MIC FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN THE ROOM WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. YOU
CAN COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
AND STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. JACK JANIS, ON
BEHALF OF SLOAT HIGGINS. JENSEN
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FUEL AND
CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE, THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION,
THE ARIZONA PETROLEUM MARKETERS
ASSOCIATION, THE NEVADA
PETROLEUM MARKETERS ASSOCIATION,
AS WELL AS THE FOLLOWING
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES JB
DUA, CYPRESS OIL FUEL DELIVERY
SERVICES. ED STAUB AND SONS,
LAKEVIEW PETROLEUM, VALLEY
PACIFIC PETROLEUM SERVICES,
RIVER CITY PETROLEUM, NATIONAL
PETROLEUM, RIBBLE OIL AS WELL AS
THE FOLLOWING ARIZONA BASED
COMPANIES MILLER OIL COMPANY,
DIAMOND TRUCKING, TO BE FUELED,
ARIZONA FUEL DISTRIBUTORS,
VALHALLA FUELS, BENNETT OIL
COMPANY, AMERICAN TRANSPORT
FREIGHT ENTERPRISES, SUPER
PUMPER STORES, CALVERT OIL,
JACKSON ENERGY, SYNERGY
PETROLEUM, CIRCLE K, CANYON DE
CHELLY FUELS, AND J.F. PETRO
GROUP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIRMAN. I AM TIMOTHY JEFFRIES,
AN INTERNATIONAL REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF BOILERMAKERS AND
ON BEHALF OF TOM BARKER,
INTERNATIONAL VICE PRESIDENT
REPRESENTING BOILERMAKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. ALOHA,
MITCHELL BECHTEL, ON BEHALF OF
THE DISTRICT COUNCIL OF
IRONWORKERS IN OPPOSITION.
THANKS, DAN. TOM, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, IN OPPOSITION, THANK.
HI. GOOD AFTERNOON, PAUL MARINO,
IRONWORKERS LOCAL 433, IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON,
TYLER BURT, IRONWORKERS 416 IN
MITCH PONTS, VICE PRESIDENT OF
IRONWORKERS LOCAL 433 AND
PRESIDENT OF THE LA ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES WIENER
OPPOSITION OF THIS. THANK YOU.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. DEAN TALLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION, OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MEMBERS ORACIO
GONZALEZ, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE, OPPOSED. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ANDREW AREN'TWE
WITH CHAU ANTHONY SCHMELTZER AND
LANG HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
KERN COUNTY, FRESNO COUNTY AND
THE WESTERN PROPANE GAS
ASSOCIATION, ALL IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO. MY NAME IS TOM HANSEN,
BUSINESS MANAGER, IBEW LOCAL
302. WE'RE OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
HOW ARE YOU DOING, RENE
PALACIOS, BUSINESS AGENT,
IRONWORKERS LOCAL 433, OPPOSE.
RANDY THOMAS, BUSINESS MANAGER,
BOILERMAKERS LOCAL 549, NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA. WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON,
ANTHONY VISCUSO, LOCAL 16 HEAT
AND FROST INSULATORS BUSINESS
AGENT. AND WE ARE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. LARA
NHîNG FRANCISCO YANEZ, ORGANIZER
FOR LOCAL 378. WE OPPOSE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. RACHEL SHEWMAKE, IBEW
LOCAL 302 AND OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. PAUL FIELDS, VICE
PRESIDENT OF BOILERMAKERS LOCAL
549. WE ARE OPPOSED. Þ. GOOD
AFTERNOON. OSBALDO TROCHE,
BOILERMAKERS LOCAL 549 OPPOSE.
IAN SIMONI, LOCAL 549
BOILERMAKER. OPPOSED. ANYBODY
ELSE? MARTIN RODRIGUEZ, TRI
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
PRESIDENT, IRONWORKERS BUSINESS
AGENT. 433.. THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM.
HEARING. SEEING NONE. I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF OUR WITNESSES, BOTH
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. NOW,
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME? SENATOR GONZALEZ? YEAH.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? ANYBODY?
ANY QUESTIONS? WELL, EVERYBODY
CAN WAIT FOR ME TO ASK
QUESTIONS. WE'RE ASKING FIRST
AND THEN IT IRRITATES EVERYBODY.
SO. THEY CAN OKAY. ALL RIGHT
I'LL DO A FEW. I ONLY GOT ABOUT
THREE. SO. 2 OR 2 WITNESSES.
THIS IS A LOT OF THESE ARE FOR
YOU TO ANSWER. WHICH TWO
WITNESSES. THE TWO WITNESSES IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. AND THEN
THERE'S ALSO SOME FOR THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES, BECAUSE IT
HAS TO DO WITH SOME OF THE
MAINTENANCE REFINERY ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE. I'M CURIOUS AS TO THE
EXPERTS THAT HAVE FIGURED THIS
OUT, THAT THIS IS THE ISSUE.
NUMBER ONE, CHARACTERIZING IT AS
A SIMPLE THING. IT'S NOT SIMPLE.
THERE IS NOTHING SIMPLE ABOUT
DEALING WITH THE OIL INDUSTRY
AND INPUTS, OUTPUTS AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT PARTS OF IT. SO IT'S
PRETTY COMPLEX. AND THE GOAL OF
THIS PROGRAM IS SIMPLY WHAT TO
GET RID OF PRICE SPIKES. YES. TO
ADDRESS THE PRICE SPIKES, TO
REDUCE THEM, MITIGATE THEM AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE OKAY. SO
OCCASIONALLY WE HAVE THESE PRICE
SPIKES THAT GO UP TO 650 A
GALLON. AND I THINK THE BIGGER
PROBLEM FOR CALIFORNIANS IS OUR
GAS NORMALLY COSTS 450 TO $5 A
GALLON. NOW THOSE AREN'T PRICE
SPIKES. THAT'S JUST THE AMOUNT
THAT WE'RE PAYING NOW. SO THAT'S
SOMETHING I THINK WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT. AND I HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYBODY TALKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE NINE REFINERIES LEFT.
RIGHT. AND ONE OF THEM IS PRETTY
SMALL. SO IT'S ALMOST EIGHT
REFINERIES LEFT OUT OF 32 THAT
WE STARTED WITH. SO WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A SUPPLY AND
DEMAND, YOU KNOW, TALK ABOUT
SIMPLIFYING IT, SUPPLY AND
DEMAND. IF WE HAVE CUT OFF ALL
THIS SUPPLY, IF WE'VE REDUCED
THE SUPPLY AND WE'VE REDUCED OUR
USAGE RIGHT AT 30%, BUT WE'VE
TAKEN 60 SOME ODD PERCENT OF OUR
REFINERIES OUT OF OUT OF
COMMISSION, THEY'RE GONE. AND SO
I THINK WE'RE RIGHT AT THAT
LEVEL WHERE, YOU KNOW, HOW MANY
GALLONS OF FUEL DOES CALIFORNIA
USE FOR PER DAY OR, YOU KNOW,
YEAH, PER DAY. I THINK IT IS. WE
USE ABOUT A DOLLAR ABOUT, SORRY,
ABOUT A GALLON PER PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA, ABOUT 37 MILLION A
DAY. OKAY. SO IT'S 37 MILLION
JUST FOR CALIFORNIA. BUT WE GOT
LETTERS FROM THE GOVERNORS OF
NEVADA AND ARIZONA, BOTH OF THEM
EXPRESSING GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS. HOW DID YOU RESPOND TO
THEM? WHAT ARE THEIR CONCERNS
AND HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
ALLEVIATE THEIR CONCERNS?
BECAUSE THEY USE SOME OF OUR
FUEL ALSO. CORRECT? RIGHT,
ABSOLUTELY. SO I THINK, SENATOR,
THANK YOU FOR THOSE QUESTIONS.
JUST KIND OF TACKLING. I MEAN,
IF YOU WOULD LIKE ME TO ANSWER
ALL THE ALL ALL OF THEM IN A
SEQUENCE, I THINK FIRSTLY, IN
TERMS OF OUR INTERCONNECTEDNESS
IN THE WEST, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT. SO WE, NEVADA AND ARIZONA
GET FUEL FROM CALIFORNIA
REFINERIES AND THROUGH OUR
PIPELINE SYSTEM. AND IT IS
IMPORTANT TO OBSERVE THAT EVERY
TIME THERE IS A SPIKE IN
CALIFORNIA, THERE'S ALSO A SPIKE
IN NEVADA. AND ARIZONA. THOSE
THINGS MOVE UP TOGETHER. SO
ANYTHING WE DO HERE TO IMPROVE
THE LIQUIDITY AND BETTER
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCY OF THE
REFINERIES IN CALIFORNIA WILL
ALSO POSITIVELY IMPACT ARIZONA
AND NEVADA. THAT'S OUR LIKE
$1.50 A GALLON LESS THAN WE PAY
I GIVE. YEAH, FRIENDS ALWAYS
SHOW ME PICTURES JUST TO SHOW
OFF. AND I'M LIKE, OKAY, THANKS.
YEAH. BUT DURING THE SPIKES,
THEY ALSO KIND OF JUST TRACK
WITH US AS, AS CLOSELY AS THEY
ARE THE REST OF THE YEAR. SO
THEY HAVE THEY HAVE SIMILAR
SPIKES BUT NOT DID THAT
ALLEVIATE THEIR CONCERNS. DID
THEY THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL
NOW? NO, I THINK WHAT THEY'VE
BEEN REQUESTING FOR AND THE CDC
AND MYSELF ON BEHALF OF CDC SENT
A COUPLE OF LETTERS BOTH TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN NEVADA AS
WELL AS THE SENATE IN ARIZONA,
BASED ON CONVERSATIONS AFTER
THAT, AFTER THOSE LETTERS WERE
SENT, THEY'RE ASKING FOR
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
AND ENSURING THAT THERE IS A
TABLE SETTING THAT WE REGULARLY
TALK AND ENSURE THAT WHATEVER WE
DO TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THEIR
INPUT AND THEY FULLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT'S TRYING TO BE DONE HERE.
SO LET'S GO BACK TO
PROFITABILITY OF OUR OUR
EXISTING REFINERIES, BECAUSE IF
THEY'RE NOT PROFITABLE AND WE
START LOSING MORE SUPPLY, IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT WE DO IN IN
STORAGE CAPACITY, WE'RE GOING TO
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE HIGH PRICES.
HAVE WE DONE ANYTHING IN THAT
ARENA TO TRY TO ADDRESS HOW
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP OUR
REFINERIES ONLINE? BECAUSE IF WE
LOSE MORE, WHAT HAPPENS TO US?
RIGHT. SO THANK YOU, SENATOR. I
WANT TO JUST KIND OF MAKE SURE
THERE'S A COUPLE OF FACTUAL
INFORMATION ON SPECIFICALLY THE
REFINERIES NUMBER OF REFINERIES
GOING DOWN IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
BEEN A NATIONAL TREND. SO THE
CONSOLIDATION. SO JUST TO KIND
OF SHARE NATIONALLY IN 1980, WE
HAD ABOUT 200 REFINERIES AND
THEY HAD LESS THAN 15 2013. AND
THIS IS NOT CALIFORNIA TREND.
IT'S A NATIONAL TREND. AND WHAT
WE OBSERVE IS OVER THE YEARS,
THE EFFICIENCY OF THE REFINERIES
HAVE GONE UP, MEANING IN
CALIFORNIA, FOR EXAMPLE, IN
1984, WE HAD ROUGHLY 60% CRUDE
OIL UTILIZATION. TODAY IT'S AT
85, 87. AND SOMETIMES DURING THE
SUMMER IT EXCEEDS 90%. AND WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS FEWER NUMBER OF
REFINERIES THAT HAVE
CONSOLIDATED SOMETIMES IN
CALIFORNIA, MULTIPLE REFINERY
LOCATIONS HAVE CONSOLIDATED INTO
A SINGLE ONE. SO OVERALL, WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT 40, IN 1984 GOING
DOWN TO NINE IN TERMS OF JUST
CAVA PRODUCTION, WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE CAPACITY BEING
REDUCED AT THE SAME LEVEL. SO IN
1980, WE HAD THE CRUDE OIL
PROCESSING CAPACITY ABOUT 2.7,
IN A MILLION BARRELS A DAY.
TODAY WE HAVE CLOSE TO 1.7. SO
IT HASN'T REDUCED PROPORTIONALLY
IN THE SAME WAY. IT'S JUST THAT
THEY'VE CONSOLIDATED AND THEY
RUN MORE EFFECTIVELY. RIGHT. SO
CURRENTLY WE PRODUCE HOW MUCH A
DAY WITH OUR WITH OUR NINE
REFINERIES. HOW MUCH. SO WE
PRODUCE ABOUT 800,000 BARRELS A
DAY. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT LIKE
4243 MILLION GALLONS. OKAY. SO
IF WE HAVE IF WE USE 37, ARIZONA
USES 33 MORE, THAT'S 40. AND
THEN NEVADA USES 42. SO WE'RE
LIKE RIGHT THERE. RIGHT. SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
JUST WITH ANY MARKET, IF YOU
LOOK AT JUNE JULY, THE OVERALL
DEMAND FOR THE REFINED FUEL BOTH
IN CALIFORNIA PLUS WHAT GOES OUT
IS LOWER THAN THE OVERALL PEAK
CAPACITY. WE HAVE RIGHT NOW,
REFINING CAPACITY. SO MOST OF
THEM IN A STORE. SO IN JUNE,
JULY, IF YOU LOOK AT THE LAST
THREE, FOUR YEARS HISTORY, EVEN
LIKE IN LOOKING AT POST COVID,
THE REFINERY INVENTORIES GO TO A
MAXIMUM BY THE END OF JUNE. AND
THEY DRAW DOWN DRAW DOWN DURING
PEAK MONTHS. SO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS, FOR EXAMPLE,
JUST TO KIND OF LOOK AT THIS
YEAR IN JULY, JUST WITHIN
CALIFORNIA REFINERY GATES, WE
HAD ABOUT 12 MILLION BARRELS,
AND THEY COME DOWN OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS BY TWO 3
MILLION BARRELS. WITHIN THAT,
WHAT WE'RE TALKING HERE IS
ABOUT, AS YOU DRAW DOWN,
REPLENISH THEM SO THAT THERE IS
LIQUIDITY. AND THE REPLENISHMENT
COULD HAPPEN IN A MULTITUDE OF
WAYS. AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
THE RULE MAKING PROCESS HAS TO
LOOK INTO. SO YOU DON'T HAVE YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY NEED TO
REPLENISH, WHERE THEY NEED TO
REPLENISH WHICH, WHICH IT'S ALL
GOING TO BE UP TO THEM TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THEY DO IT. NØ. SO I
WOULD JUST OFFER I THINK PART OF
IT IS LIKE TODAY, FOR EXAMPLE,
THIS YEAR AND IN THE ASSEMBLY
HEARINGS, WE GOT THIS QUESTION A
LOT AND WE OFFERED THIS. THERE
ARE REFINERS THAT PLAN
EXCELLENTLY WELL TODAY. THEY
PLANNED REALLY WELL. I MEAN, I
COULD YOU KNOW, BECAUSE OF
CONFIDENTIALITY, I CANNOT SAY
NAMES, BUT THERE ARE REFINERIES
WHO PLAN VERY CAREFULLY TO
RESUPPLY FOR BOTH PLANNED AND
UNPLANNED OUTAGES. THEY DO THAT.
NOT EVERYBODY DOES. IT BECAUSE
THERE IS NO INCENTIVE. SO THIS
LAW WOULD ALLOWS THE CÁC TO WORK
WITH EACH ONE OF THEM TO FIGURE
OUT HOW CAN WE MAXIMIZE OUR
PRE-PLANNING TO REDUCE REACTIVE
BEHAVIOR AT THE PUMP AND IN SPOT
MARKET IN REAL TIME? AND IF I
COULD ADD ON THE QUESTION OF
VISIBILITY INTO REFINERY
PROFITABILITY IN CALIFORNIA, I
THINK THAT THE CHARACTERIZATION
FROM THE INDUSTRY IS COULDN'T BE
MORE WRONG. I THINK LOOKING AT
2022 AND 2023, WE SAW RECORD
PROFITS FOR INDUSTRY. AND THESE
COMPANIES ARE VERY LARGE AND NO
LIKE PROFIT IS GOOD. THIS IS A
MARKET THAT WE NEED TO FUNCTION
BUT IT NEEDS TO BE A COMPETITIVE
PROFIT. SO WHEN YOU SEE WHAT
ECONOMISTS CALL EXCESS PROFITS,
YOU KNOW THAT THERE MAY NOT BE
COMPETITION. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WE PRESENTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY HEARING IS THAT FOR
COMPANIES CONTROL 90% OF THE
REFINING CAPACITY IN CALIFORNIA,
THAT'S A NATIONAL TREND. YOU
KNOW, CONSOLIDATION HAPPENS IN
OTHER REGIONS, TOO. BUT
CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUELY
CONSOLIDATED. AND SO THESE
PROFITS, THEY DON'T REPORT THE
REFINERIES OFTEN DON'T REPORT
JUST FOR CALIFORNIA. THEY REPORT
FOR THE WEST VERSUS THE GULF
VERSUS THE EAST. CALIFORNIA AND
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES IS THE
MOST PROFITABLE GASOLINE MARKET
IN THE UNITED STATES, AND ONE OF
THE MOST PROFITABLE IN THE WORLD
CURRENTLY. WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE
THE DATA FOR THAT, RIGHT? SO
WHAT DOES THE DATA INDICATE FOR
THIS LAST YEAR THAT YOU'VE BEEN
ABLE TO OBTAIN THE DATA? HAVE
THEY BEEN PROFITABLE EVERY
MONTH. SO I'LL LET I'LL LET I'LL
LET THE VICE CHAIR SPEAK TO THIS
AS WELL. DIVISION OF PETROLEUM
MARKET OVERSIGHT IS AN
INDEPENDENT DIVISION OF CEC. SO
WE DON'T PUBLISH THAT DATA. BUT
WE'VE GIVEN INPUT. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE SEE,
UNFORTUNATELY, IS THAT AS MUCH
AS WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AN OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT AND FRANK
DISCUSSION BETWEEN INDUSTRY AND
THE PUBLIC, FOR SOME REASON THE
INDUSTRY NUMBERS THAT THEY'RE
SUPPLYING TO THE CEC DO NOT
TRACK WHAT THEY REPORT TO THE
SEC IN TERMS OF THEIR
PROFITABILITY. THE NUMBERS
APPEAR INCREDIBLY DIFFERENT AND
NOT CONSISTENT WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY. SO THE NUMBER THAT
DPMO HAS BEEN USING PUBLICLY AND
WHAT WE'RE USING TO EVALUATE
PROFITABILITY IS CALLED A GROSS
REFINING MARGIN. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE COST OF CRUDE AND THEN
WHAT YOU SELL THESE PRODUCTS FOR
AND THAT TYPE OF GROSS REFINING
MARGIN CALLED A CRACK SPREAD IS
WHAT'S USED IN THE INDUSTRY. SO
THE CRACK SPREAD AGAIN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, HIGHER THAN ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE COUNTRY, GENERALLY,
THERE CAN BE PERIODS WHERE LEAN
PERIODS WHERE PRICES ARE LOW.
AND ON THE ONE HAND, THAT'S A
GOOD MEASURE OF COMPETITION.
THAT'S GOOD FOR CONSUMERS. BUT
UNDERSTAND THAT INDUSTRY NEEDS
TO MAKE A FAIR PROFIT. BUT THESE
KIND OF EXCESS PROFITS, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE.
WHEN YOU PUT IT VERY WELL, 450
OR $5 A GALLON. CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS ARE USED TO THAT. THEY
CAN SEE WHERE EVEN IF OUR TAXES
ARE HIGHER, THAT'S AN INVESTMENT
IN INFRASTRUCTURE OR OUR OUR
BLEND IS CLEANER. THAT'S AN
INVESTMENT IN CLEAN AIR. WHEN IT
GOES BETWEEN $4.50 AND $6.50, I
THINK PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW, WHERE
DOES THAT MONEY GO? AND BEFORE
THE SENATE OVERSIGHT HEARING IN
APRIL OF THIS YEAR, WE SHOWED
THAT MONEY GOES TO THE INDUSTRY.
WHEN THOSE PRICES SPIKE, THE
TAXES AND FEES STAY THE SAME.
AND THOSE ARE PROFIT SPIKES FOR
INDUSTRY. AND I THINK PEOPLE
WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHY THAT'S
HAPPENING AND AGREE THIS IS NOT
A SIMPLE SORT OF APPROACH
OVERALL, BUT THE SUPPLY AND
DEMAND FUNDAMENTALS HERE ARE
SIMPLE. WE LOOK AND WE'VE LOOKED
AT THE LAST FEW YEARS WHEN THE
INVENTORIES GET LOW, THAT
CREATES THIS STRESS ON THE SPOT
MARKET PRICES SPIKE, PROFITS
SPIKE. BUT INDUSTRY COSTS DON'T
GO UP. ALL RIGHT. THIS QUESTION
IS FOR THE INDUSTRY EXPERTS
HERE. THE PROCESS OF REFINING
FUELS IT. DOES IT GO THROUGH THE
REFINERY AND THEN GO DIRECTLY
INTO TRUCKS THAT TAKE THEM TO.
OR WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE STORAGE
TANKS THAT ARE EXISTING NOW?
DON'T THEY PLAY A PRETTY LARGE
ROLE IN THAT? YEAH. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION. IN THE ASSEMBLY, WE
HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE SUPPLY CHAIN GETTING CRUDE
CRUDE OIL FROM EITHER THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY OR COMING OVER
VIA MARINE VESSEL. SO WHEN IT
GETS TO THE REFINERY, OBVIOUSLY
MAKING MULTIPLE PRODUCTS
GASOLINE, DIESEL, JET FUEL FROM
A BARREL OF OIL, YOU'RE NOT JUST
PRODUCING ALL GASOLINE, YOU'RE
PRODUCING DIESEL AND JET ALONG
WITH IT ALONG WITH OTHER
PRODUCTS. AND THEN WE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT TANKAGE IN IN THE
ASSEMBLY INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS.
AND THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A BARN STORING HAY AND THE
TANKAGE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
OUR TANKS ARE WORKING TANKS.
YOU'RE CONSTANTLY BLENDING
COMPONENTS THAT MAKE GASOLINE.
SO YOUR TANKS, YOU'RE LOOKING AT
A 40 TO 60% CAPACITY GENERALLY.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES. SO WHEN IT COMES
TO JUST SAYING FILL YOUR TANKS
MORE, WELL THAT THAT'S WHERE IT
COMES THAT PINCH POINT I WAS
TALKING ABOUT IS IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TAKE COMPONENTS INTO
YOUR TANKS, WE ACTUALLY THINK
YOU WOULD POTENTIALLY HAVE TO
SLOW DOWN THE REFINING PROCESS
TO ACCOMMODATE. FOR NOW, HAVING
YOUR TANKS MORE FULL, AND THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY AFFECT THE
MARKET AND RELIABILITY ISSUES.
SO WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
TANKAGE. YOU MAY HAVE A LARGER
CAPACITY, BUT YOU'RE WORKING
CAPACITY IS PRETTY MUCH AT MAX
RIGHT NOW. OKAY. I WANT TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MAINTENANCE.
WHO REGULATES WHEN IT GETS
MAINTAINED, WHEN THESE WHEN
THESE PLANTS HAVE TO GO OFFLINE
TO GET MAINTAINED. WHO REGULATES
THAT. THE SENATOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. YEAH.
AND IS THAT A FLEXIBLE THING? I
MEAN, BECAUSE I LIKEN IT TO LIKE
YOU HAVE AN AIRPLANE, RIGHT? AND
EVERY SO MANY HOURS YOU GOT TO
TAKE YOUR PLANE DOWN AND REBUILD
THE ENGINE NO MATTER WHAT, EVEN
IF IT'S WORKING RIGHT, YOU GOT
TO TAKE IT DOWN IN THE FIRE
SERVICE. SO WE HAVE OUR
HELICOPTER. WHEN THEY HIT THAT
THAT WHEN THEY HIT THE HOURS,
THEY'RE DOWN AND THEY'RE DOWN
FOR MONTHS WHILE WE'RE REDO
THEM. IF THERE'S BRUSH FIRES
EVERYWHERE, THAT IS NOT A
CONSIDERATION. WE JUST CAN'T USE
THEM. SO THAT'S ONE OF MY
CONCERNS HERE IS THAT, YOU KNOW,
AS IF WE'RE ENTERING INTO A AN
AREA WHERE WE HAVE HIGH DEMAND
AND YET WE HAVE A SUPPLY ISSUE,
OR WE ONLY HAVE A FEW DAYS OF
SUPPLY ISSUE AND THEN THEN WE'LL
HIT ANOTHER PINCH POINT. IN
OTHER WORDS, WE'RE JUST MOVING
THE PINCH POINT AROUND
EVENTUALLY. A SUPPLY ISSUE IS A
SUPPLY ISSUE AND THE MARKET WILL
REACT TO A SUPPLY ISSUE. AND
WHEN THAT MARKET REACTS, THAT'S
WHEN WE WIND UP HAVING TO PAY
MORE FOR OUR FUEL. SO WHO WOULD
MAKE THAT DECISION. AND HOW
COULD THEY DIVORCE THEIR
DECISION ABOUT WHEN SOMETHING
COMES DOWN FROM SAFETY TO
POLITICAL CONVENIENCE. RIGHT.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR, I
THINK I WOULD JUST YOU KNOW,
FIRST OF ALL, JUST OFFER
SOMETHING FOR THIS CONVERSATION
AT THIS TABLE. I DO NOT WANT TO
PUSH BACK ON MY INDUSTRY
COLLEAGUE HERE FROM WHISPER AND
NOTE THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
WHAT THEY SAY TO US PRIVATELY
AND PUBLICLY. AND I'M NOT GOING
TO COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE I
WANT TO HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP. REGARDLESS OF THAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT. I
JUST ASK. SO I WANT TO KNOW THAT
QUESTION. GET TO THAT POINT OF
BASICALLY IN TERMS OF HAVING
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS. SO THE
QUESTION I WOULD ASK FIRST IS DO
THE EXISTING SYSTEM, THE STATUS
QUO OF MAINTENANCE PROTOCOLS
WORK OR NOT? IF THEY DO WORK, IF
EXISTING PROTOCOLS CURRENTLY
WORK, WE WILL NOT TOUCH THEM. SO
IF THE QUESTION IS EXISTING
PROTOCOLS AND BEST PRACTICES DO
NOT WORK, THAT'S A DIFFERENT
QUESTION. SO WHAT I WOULD WANT
TO OFFER TO THE COMMITTEE,
REGARDLESS OF THE CONVERSATION,
IS WHATEVER IS IN BEST
PRACTICES, WHETHER IT'S CAL-OSHA
DER LABOR STANDARDS, THOSE WILL
BE INPUTS INTO THE RULEMAKING
PROCESS AND WE WILL NOT TOUCH
THEM. THAT WOULD BE THE
CONSTRAINTS UNDER WHICH WE WILL
WORK THAT THOSE CONSTRAINTS WILL
NOT BE CHALLENGED AS A PART OF
THE RULEMAKING PROCESS. RIGHT.
AND WHEN AND FOR THE INDUSTRY,
WHEN HOW LONG DO THESE PROCESSES
USUALLY TAKE TO GET IN THERE AND
REFURBISH OR REESTABLISH A SAFE
REFINERY? WHEN YOU DO
MAINTENANCE, BECAUSE THERE'S THE
GENERAL MAINTENANCE AND THEN
THERE'S THE BIG OVERHAUL? YEAH.
I MEAN, I. I THINK THAT. OUR
MEMBERS GO IN ON A CONTRACTUAL
BASIS AND THEY ARE HIRED BY THE
REFINERIES TO COME IN AT
PREDETERMINED INTERVALS TO DO
THE CONSTRUCTION WORK. HOW LONG
DOES THAT USUALLY TAKE? I THINK
WE'RE LOOKING AT 1 TO 15 DAYS OF
FUEL SUPPLY. I THINK IT DEPENDS
ON THE ON THE EFFORT REQUIRED TO
DO THE TURNAROUND AND THE
MAINTENANCE EVENT. I KNEW THAT
TURNAROUNDS TAKE 4050 DAYS. I'VE
BEEN TOLD THOSE ARE THE BIG
ONES. THOSE ARE THE ONES WHERE
EVERYTHING'S SHUT DOWN AND IT
KIND OF TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
AIRPLANE. YEAH, KIND OF REDOING
EVERYTHING IN A WAY, NOT REDOING
EVERYTHING, BUT LOOKING AT IT,
LOOKING IT ALL OVER. BUT, YOU
KNOW, I'VE BEEN TOLD BY FOLKS
WHO WORK IN THE INDUSTRY 45 TO
50 DAYS. I KNOW WE HAVE SOME
FOLKS HERE IN THE ROOM THAT I
REPRESENT FROM THE BOILERMAKERS,
FROM THE IRONWORKERS. IF THEY
WANTED TO COME BACK TO THE MIC
AND JUST GIVE A MORE SPECIFIC
IDEA FOR YOU. BUT IT'S IN THAT
IT'S IN THAT VICINITY. OKAY. I
THINK ONE THING I WANTED TO ADD,
SENATOR, ABOUT MAKING THE
DECISION. SO IF THERE IS A
RESERVE THAT'S BIGGER THAN TODAY
AND THE CEC HAS TO GO THROUGH A
RULEMAKING AND DETERMINE HOW
MUCH IT IS PER REFINER, AND FOR
THE SYSTEM OVERALL, BUT WITH
MORE IN THE TANKS, YOU HAVE A
LOT MORE OPERATIONAL
FLEXIBILITY. AND SO THE PRESSURE
THAT I THINK SOME OPERATORS
MIGHT FEEL TO KEEP RUNNING IF
THEY'RE IN, YOU KNOW, SORT OF A
BUSY TIME OR FOR FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES, WHAT WE THINK IS THE
OPTIMAL OUTCOME HERE IS THERE BE
A RESERVE THAT ALLOWS FOR
REFINERS AND LABOR AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS, ENGINEERS TO
DECIDE WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST FOR PUBLIC SAFETY,
PERIOD. FULL STOP. IF YOU HAVE
MORE IN RESERVE, THEN YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY SO MUCH ABOUT
THOSE PINCH POINTS THAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT AND PUT SAFETY AND
ENGINEERING FIRST AND FOREMOST,
RATHER THAN MARKET CONDITIONS.
AND FROM OUR POSITION, HAVING A
BUFFER THAT ALLOWS EACH
INDIVIDUAL REFINER TO MAKE THOSE
THOSE DECISIONS TO OPTIMIZE
SAFETY IS THE BEST OUTCOME.
OKAY. NOW, IN REGARDS TO THE
TANK, THE TANK STORAGE AND THE
GOAL OF HAVING THEM VERY FULL.
IN THE REFINERY PROCESS, YOU
KNOW, ONCE THEY TURN THE
REFINERIES AND THEY'RE WORKING
THE SUPPLY, THE DEMAND SIDE OF
THIS FLUCTUATES WITH CONSUMER
DEMAND. WE EITHER DRIVE MORE OR
WE DON'T, OR WHATEVER IT IS.
WELL, THERE'S GOT TO BE A
FLUCTUATION IN THE AMOUNT OF
STORAGE THEY NEED IN THE TANK TO
BE ABLE TO, TO CONTINUE TO
ABSORB WHAT IS COMING THROUGH
THE REFINERIES FROM THE
INDUSTRY. WHAT HAPPENS DOES CAN
YOU JUST SHUT DOWN OR IS THERE A
SWITCH? YOU JUST SHUT IT OFF THE
REFINERY AND YOU DON'T WORK FOR
A FEW DAYS OR NO, HOW DOES THAT
WORK? NO. VERY COMPLEX TO SHUT
DOWN A REFINERY. OBVIOUSLY, A
LOT OF PRESSURE BUILD UP IN THE
REFINERY AS YOU SHUT DOWN, I
THINK, BUT THAT THAT'S WHAT BEGS
THE QUESTION IS IF YOUR TANKS
ARE NOW FULL OR CAN YOU RUN AT
THAT MAXIMUM CAPACITY TO MEET
DEMAND IF YOUR STORAGE TANKS
CAN'T TAKE THE PRODUCT COMING
OFF OF THE REFINERY, RIGHT. SO
THAT BECOMES ANOTHER ISSUE IS IF
OUR TANKS ARE SO FULL THAT WE
CAN'T ABSORB. SO APPARENTLY
YOU'RE AN EXPERT ON THAT. GO
AHEAD AND GIVE US THE YOU'RE
SHAKING YOUR HEAD AND ROLLING
YOUR EYES. I'M SORRY, SENATOR, I
EXCUSED. I COME FROM AN
EXPRESSIVE FAMILY AND I
APOLOGIZE. I DIDN'T MEAN TO BE
CHIRLA WAS NOT ROLLING MY EYES.
I THINK I THINK THIS IDEA THAT
THE TANKS ARE FULL IS, I THINK,
THE WRONG STARTING POINT. THE
AVERAGE IN THE INDUSTRY IS ABOUT
55% UTILIZATION. AND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOW FULL THE
TANKS GET IN THE IN THE WINTER
OR THE EARLY SUMMER AND HOW LOW
THEY GET IN THE FALL, IS 3 TO 4
MILLION BARRELS. IF YOU WERE AT
THAT EARLY SUMMER OR WINTER
LEVEL, THE TANKS STILL AREN'T
FULL AND THERE ARE THESE.
THERE'S A LOT OF, I THINK I
THINK TO THE CREDIT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM WISPA, THERE,
THERE IS SOME DISTINCTION
BETWEEN BLENDING TANKS AND
FINISHED PRODUCT TANKS. WE HOLD
IT AND THEN YOU LOAD IT INTO THE
SYSTEM. BUT BUT THEY'RE NOT
CLOSE TO FULL AND EVEN AT A
REGULATION THAT SAYS YOU NEED TO
HAVE A BETTER RESERVE, THEY
WOULDN'T BE CLOSE TO FULL.
THERE'S A PHRASE CALLED I'M
GOING TO MISPRONOUNCE IT ULLAGE
IN IT. NO ULLAGE ULLAGE, WHICH
IS THE AMOUNT OF TANK SPACE
THAT'S NOT USED THAT CURRENTLY
IS ABOUT HALF AND SO THERE JUST
IS MORE THAN ENOUGH OPERATIONAL
CAPACITY IN THE SYSTEM. AND I
THINK IT'S USING A FEW SORT OF
TECHNICAL PIECES OF JARGON TO
SAY THERE MIGHT BE PINCH POINTS,
I THINK IN THE, IN THE
RULEMAKING PROCESS, I THINK
CONFIDENT THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
EXISTING STORAGE SPACE THAT
COULD BE USED AND IT KIND OF
WE'VE BEEN NOTED LIKE DURING THE
ASSEMBLY HEARING AS WELL, WE
HEARD THE SHELL CAPACITY VERSUS
ACTUAL OPERATIONAL CAPACITY, AND
THE NUMBERS THAT WE PROVIDED ARE
ACTUAL OPERATING CAPACITY,
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE MINIMUM
THEY HAVE TO MAINTAIN AND THE
MAXIMUM LIMITS THEY HAVE EVEN IF
YOU LOOK AT THAT, WE HAVE ABOUT
19.1 DAYS WORTH OF SUPPLY. YOU
COULD HAVE IN THE STATE WITHIN
THE REFINERIES AND THE STORAGE
TANKS, AGAIN, TO THE POINT THAT
THAT WAS MADE. THESE JUST I
WOULD IMAGINE, WHISPER WOULD NOT
HAVE THE INDEPENDENT REFINERY BY
REFINERY, STORAGE TANK CAPACITY
BECAUSE IT WOULDN'T BE LEGAL FOR
AN INDUSTRY TRADE ASSOCIATION TO
HAVE THAT. BUT THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE, WE GET TO SEE THAT,
WE GET TO SEE THAT REGULARLY,
AND WE GET TO SEE AND WHAT
DIRECTOR MILLER MENTIONED, THOSE
OPERATING LIMITS AND AGAIN, KIND
OF GOING BACK TO THE SPIRIT OF
THE LAW, WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT 15 DAYS WORTH OF NEW
SUPPLY. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
DAY OR TWO OF AVAILABLE CAPACITY
THAT COULD BE USED
INCREMENTALLY. AND AGAIN, TAKING
INTO ALL THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
SEE, TAKING INTO ACCOUNT ALL THE
CONSTRAINTS, THE QUESTION WE
WOULD ASK EACH REFINERY IN
COLLABORATIVE SPIRIT IS WHAT
MORE CAN BE DONE TO STORE THAT
EXCESS AMOUNT? AND WHATEVER
COMES OUT OF THAT AS A AS A PART
OF THE PROCESS, THAT'S WHERE THE
RULEMAKING WILL SET THOSE
TARGETS. YEAH. THAT SEEMS OUR
PRICE SPIKES LASTED LONGER THAN
A DAY OR TWO WHEN WE HAVE THEM.
DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON WHAT.
YEAH, JUST AS WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT TANKAGE CAPACITY, I THINK
WHAT WAS REVEALED DURING THE
ASSEMBLY HEARINGS WAS NOT EVERY
REFINERY IS THE SAME. NOT
EVERYONE IS THE SAME SIZE, AND
NOT EVERYONE HAS CAPACITY TO
STORE. AND SO I THINK THAT'S WHY
YOU NOW SEE THIS REFINING
REGION, WHICH BRINGS UP
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS FOR US ALONG
WITH THE TRADING MECHANISM. BUT
I THINK EACH REFINERY IS
DIFFERENT AND A MANDATE LIKE
THIS, WE THINK COULD PUT FOLKS
AT COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGES OR
DISADVANTAGES. ALL RIGHT. MY
LAST QUESTION BEFORE I LET MY
COLLEAGUES JUMP IN AGAIN. I HOPE,
AND I'LL TAKE A BREAK FROM
ASKING SOME. AND THEN HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL COVER SOME OF THE OTHER
ONES THAT I HAVE. IS ON THE
TANKS THEMSELVES. NOW, I FORGOT
WHAT I WAS GOING TO ASK ABOUT
THE DOGGONE TANKS. SO. AND
ANYWAY, WELL, I'LL COME BACK TO
IT LATER IF IT COMES BACK TO ME.
BUT ANYWAY, I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS TO THE
BEST OF WHAT WE CAN. I THINK
WHAT MY THIS INITIAL LINE OF
QUESTIONING POINTS OUT IS THAT
THIS IS NOT A SIMPLE THING AND
THE REPERCUSSIONS IF WE'RE WRONG
TO THE PUBLIC, YES, IT SAYS, OH,
WE CAN. WE CAN NOT DO IT IF
WE'RE WRONG. BUT IT'S EVEN MORE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAN WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ON A PRICE
SPIKE. AND SO, YOU KNOW, I KIND
OF FEEL LIKE I DON'T BELIEVE
ANYTHING IN OCTOBER AND BEFORE
AN ELECTION. AND IT'S REALLY
HARD FOR ME TO SIT HERE AND
ABSORB THIS WITHOUT ACTUALLY
WHAT WE REALLY SHOULD HAVE HAD
IS AN EXTENSIVE HEARING,
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THIS.
AND WE DID HAVE THAT. WELL.
OKAY. WELL, ANYWAY. OKAY. WELL
GOOD. BECAUSE APPARENTLY I
MISSED THAT ONE. AND THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE I THINK AT
THE BEGINNING, THE INITIAL PART
OF THIS THAT WAS THERE WAS SOME,
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT, GOSH, I
CAN'T REMEMBER IT, BUT ANYWAY,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR BERKSHIRE, THANK YOU.
YES. MY QUESTION IS ACTUALLY FOR
THE AUTHOR AND ANYONE YOU'D LIKE
TO ENLIST. SO THE GOAL OF THIS
IS TO SAVE CONSUMERS MONEY. AND
SO MY QUESTION IS HOW WHAT IS
THE CRITERIA THAT WILL BE USED
BY THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO
ENSURE THAT WHATEVER MINIMUM
INVENTORY REQUIREMENTS ARE
PURSUED, WHETHER IT'S ONE DAY,
15 DAYS OR OR LONGER OR OR NOT
AT ALL, THAT THEY ACTUALLY DO
SAVE CONSUMERS MONEY. AND I ASK
THAT ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT THERE
ARE MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS AND
PLAYERS IN THIS CHAIN. SO FROM
THE REFINERS ALL THE WAY TO THE
RETAIL, THERE ARE MANY PLAYERS
IN THERE. SO JUST MAKING SURE
THAT THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS MET.
I'M WONDERING WHAT IS THE
CRITERIA THAT THE CEC WILL USE?
WELL, THE THIS BILL DOES NOT
CONTAIN THE ACTUAL REGULATIONS.
WE'RE GOING TO PROPOSE THE BILL
PROPOSES TO GO THROUGH A PUBLIC,
TRANSPARENT REGULATORY PROCESS
TO CREATE THOSE THAT RULEMAKING
WORKING WITH INDUSTRY. AND THE
REGULATIONS WILL ONLY BE
IMPLEMENTED IF IT PROVES TO
BENEFIT CONSUMERS BY NUMBER ONE,
REDUCING THE AVERAGE RETAIL COST
OF GASOLINE. NUMBER TWO,
INCREASING THE FUEL SUPPLY AND
THREE MINIMIZING THE SPOT MARKET
VOLATILITY. BUT DO WE HAVE
ANYTHING MORE THAN THAT OR IS
THERE ANY OTHER THOUGHTS ON
THAT. YES. GO AHEAD. BECAUSE I'D
LIKE TO I MEAN I UNDERSTAND THAT
WE'RE NOT PRESCRIBING THAT, BUT
WHAT DO WE ENVISION AS POSSIBLE.
RIGHT. ABSOLUTELY. WE'LL JUST
ADD TO THAT, SENATOR, I THINK
THE JUST USE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
JUST KIND OF CLARIFY A FEW
THINGS. SO WHAT WE HAVE, YOU
KNOW, THERE HAS BEEN A REFERENCE
TO THE TRANSPORTATION FUELS
ASSESSMENT THAT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS PUT OUT. SO THE
TRANSPORTATION FUELS ASSESSMENT
WAS A WHITEBOARDING EXERCISE, A
PUBLIC WHITEBOARDING EXERCISE
COLLABORATIVELY AND REALLY PUT
OUT ALL THE OPTIONS THAT THE
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE PUT IN,
INCLUDING THEIR PROS AND CONS.
AND THEN WHAT WHAT THE INITIAL
FOCUS HAS BEEN ON WAS 2 OR 3
IDEAS. WHAT CAN WE DO TO
IMMEDIATELY ADDRESS, YOU KNOW,
LIQUIDITY IN THE MARKET. SO OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS, AND WE
DID A SENATE HEARING IN MAY
TIMEFRAME WHERE WE PROVIDED
ANALYSIS, WHAT WE SHOW TODAY IS
WHEN THE MARKET LIQUIDITY DIPS
BELOW 15 DAYS. AND WHEN WE SAY
15 DAYS, ROUGHLY ABOUT 13 DAYS
OF THAT IS IN STORAGE TANKS AND
ABOUT TWO DAYS IS IMPORTS COMING
IN. AND REFINERIES RUNNING. SO
WHEN IT DIPS BELOW THAT, YOU
BEGIN TO SEE THIS REACTIVE
BEHAVIOR AT THE SPOT MARKET. SO
THE EXISTING HYPOTHESIS, BUT
ALSO KIND OF BASED ON THE DATA
WE HAVE ALONG WITH THOSE
INSIGHTS, IS THAT IF YOU COULD
MAINTAIN THE LIQUIDITY TO THAT
15 DAYS ROUGHLY, IT WOULD REMOVE
THE REACTIVE BEHAVIOR AT THE
SPOT MARKET. AND AGAIN, THIS IS
REFINERY BY REFINERY AND I WANT
TO JUST USE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND ON THAT, WHICH IS SOME
REFINERIES HAVE END CUSTOMER
OBLIGATIONS. SO A REFINERY MIGHT
HAVE ALL THE WAY TO THE RETAIL
STATION. THEY HAVE COMMITMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE TO HONOR, AND
SOME OF THEM JUST PRODUCE OIL
AND REFINED PRODUCT TO SELL. SO
WE WILL BE LOOKING AT EACH ONE
OF THEM SEPARATELY, LOOKING AT
THEIR TANKAGE SEPARATELY, AND
REALLY LOOKING AT THE SPIRIT OF
HOW CAN YOU MAXIMIZE WITHIN THE
EXISTING TANKAGE MORE VOLUME. SO
FOR CONTEXT, THE LOWEST WE HAVE
SEEN, THE DAYS OF SUPPLY DIP TO
WAS 12.5 DAYS IN 2022. SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT 12.5 DAYS TO 15
DAYS ABOUT TWO. AND A HALF DAYS
PER QUARTER. AND ACROSS ALL
INDUSTRY PLAYERS. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'LL BE WORKING ONE
BY ONE TO FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH OF
THE TWO AND TWO AND A HALF DAYS
COULD BE BROUGHT IN. OKAY. THANK
YOU. YEAH, YEAH, YEAH. I JUST
WANTED TO RESPOND TO THE NOTION
THAT THIS BILL APPLIES TO THE
ALL OF THE INDUSTRY. I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT SB ONE TWO
HAS REVEALED THROUGH THE PROCESS
IS THERE ARE A LOT OF PLAYERS IN
THE TRANSPORTATION FUEL MARKET.
THERE ARE WHOLESALERS,
DISTRIBUTORS, MARKETERS, ENERGY
TRADERS, REFINERS. BUT THIS BILL
SEEMS TO BE ONLY SUBJECT TO
REFINERS. AND I THINK IT SAYS
REFINER REGION, WHICH I DON'T
KNOW IS DEFINED. AND SO TO SAY
THAT THERE'S 13 DAYS IN THE
SYSTEM IS THAT ALL THE PLAYERS
OR JUST REFINERS. AND THAT'S
JUST A GENERAL QUESTION, BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK WE'VE I THINK THAT
WAS WITH TERMINAL OPERATIONS IN
THERE. WELL, SO COULD I JUST
FOLLOW UP ON THAT. SO WITH THIS
WHITEBOARDING EXERCISE IT WAS IT
WAS LOOKING AT UP TO 15 DAYS
AND, AND FIGURING OUT THAT THIS
DID SEEM TO BE THE TRIGGER, NOT
THESE OTHER PLAYERS IN THE
MARKET. IS THAT WHAT WHAT SO
WOULD YOUR RESPONSE BE THAT
THESE OTHER PLAYERS ARE NOT
ACTUALLY AFFECTING OVERALL COST?
RIGHT? I MEAN, SOME OF THEM
LIKE, YOU KNOW, THE RETAIL
MARGIN DOES INCREASE, BUT RETAIL
MARGIN INCREASE IS A REACTION TO
THE REFINERY MARGIN INCREASE. SO
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT WHAT'S AT THE TOP AND
WE CAN REDUCE THE SECONDARY
EFFECTS BY REDUCING THE FIRST
ONE OKAY OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CHAIR. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. A
COUPLE QUESTIONS TO OUR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE CEC AND
THE DIVISION. SO I NOTE AND THE
ANALYSIS DOES ALSO, THAT THE
BILL GIVES THE CEC AND THE
DIVISION CERTAIN AUTHORITIES,
AND IT REQUIRES REGULATIONS.
HOWEVER, IT ALSO INDICATES THAT
THE REGULATIONS, IF TO BE
ADOPTED, WILL SPECIFICALLY, IT
SAYS IT PROHIBITS YOU FROM
ADOPTING THE REGULATIONS UNLESS
YOU MAKE CERTAIN FINDINGS. SO MY
QUESTION IS, WHILE SO FAR YOUR
ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT THIS IS A
THAT REQUIRING SOME LEVEL OF
INVENTORY WOULD HELP US WITH
PRICE SPIKES, THE WAY THE BILL
IS CONSTRUCTED, YOU COULD OPT
NOT TO MAKE THAT REQUIREMENT.
AND I'D LIKE YOU TO SEE IF I'M
IF I AM THE ANALYSIS HAVE READ
THAT CORRECTLY AND SOME THOUGHTS
ON THAT. AND THEN I HAVE A
COUPLE OTHER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU, SENATOR, BASED ON THE
AMENDMENTS, THE AMENDMENTS ARE
COMING. WE'RE GOING TO BE
REVIEWING THEM AS THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. AND, YOU KNOW, AS AS
KIND OF ONE OF THE COMMISSIONERS
SERVING ON THAT, THIS WOULD BE
DONE THROUGH A COMMISSION VOTE.
BUT THE INTERPRETATION OF THE
BILL TODAY, IF WE CANNOT MEET
THE DIFFERENT GUARDRAILS, QUOTE,
UNQUOTE, PUT IN THE IN THE
LEGISLATION, YES, WE WILL NOT BE
MAKING A DETERMINATION TO SET
MINIMUM STANDARDS. RIGHT. I ASK
THAT BECAUSE SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION SEEMS TO IMPLY THAT
THIS THAT WE ARE AUTOMATIC, THAT
THIS BY VOTING IN THIS BILL, WE
ARE SETTING THOSE THOSE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS AND WE'RE NOT. AND
I JUST NOTE THAT BECAUSE IT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I LIKE
ABOUT THE BILL, BECAUSE IT GIVES
THE IF WE WERE TO SET
REQUIREMENTS AND OR SET THE
REGS, THEN SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED THAT COULD
BE REAL POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES COULD COME TRUE,
AND THEN IT WOULD BE THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD HAVE TO
COME BACK AND ACT TO FIX.
WHEREAS THIS HAS A PROCESS BUILT
IN PLUS A STAKEHOLDER GROUP PLUS
PUBLIC INPUT FOR YOU TO MAKE
THOSE DETERMINATIONS AND SET
REGS AND THEN TO ANALYZE THE
REGS, YOU KNOW, REPORTS TO US
AND SUCH. BUT ADDITIONALLY YOUR
OWN PROCESSES WHERE IF THE REGS
ARE NOT MEETING THE INTENTIONS,
THEN YOU CAN REVISE OR REVERSE
OR ELIMINATE. SO I JUST WANTED
TO SEE IF I UNDERSTOOD THAT
CORRECT. AND IT SEEMS LIKE YOUR
AFFIRMATION DOES THE OTHER THING
I WANTED TO THE OTHER ISSUE IS
ON THE IT PROHIBITS THE ENERGY
COMMISSION FROM APPLYING A
MINIMUM INVENTORY REQUIREMENT IF
IT CAN ONLY BE MET BY NEW
CONSTRUCTION OF STORAGE
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO IT I THINK
THAT THAT PROVISION DOES HELP US
IN TERMS OF SOME SOME POTENTIAL
COST PROBLEMS. AND I WANTED YOU
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THE STORAGE CAPACITY. THAT
YOU'VE ANALYZED SO FAR. I MEAN,
WE HAVE THE INDUSTRY HAS
INDICATED, YOU KNOW, THAT THEY
POTENTIALLY DON'T HAVE THAT
CAPACITY OR THAT CAPACITY COULD
BE SUCH THAT SINCE IT'S USED FOR
VARIOUS THINGS, COULD PUT THIS
PINCH PROBLEM. AND WHAT I FOUND
KIND OF INTERESTING ABOUT THAT
WAS I LISTENED TO THE ASSEMBLIES
HEARING THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING, AND I WAS STRUCK BY THE
OPERATOR OF ROTTEN ROBBIE
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE,
THE WAY THE, THE REFINED PRODUCT
IS PULLED FROM THE BOTTOM OF THE
TANK, SO THE NEWLY REFINED
PRODUCT IS PUT IN THE TOP, THE
REFINED PRODUCTS PULLED OUT FROM
THE BOTTOM, AND THAT FACT THAT.
SO THIS IS TO THE INDUSTRY'S
POINT THAT, YOU KNOW, THIS IS A
YOU KNOW, CONSTANTLY IN USE.
WELL, THAT'S PART OF WHAT GIVES
US THE ASSURANCE THAT OUR
CONCERN OF THE PRODUCT BEING,
YOU KNOW, THE SHELF LIFE OF A
REFINED PRODUCT, THAT. SO I
GUESS THE POINT I'M TRYING TO
MAKE, AND I WISH YOU WOULD
ELABORATE OR AFFIRM, IF I'M
CORRECT, IS THAT WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR A STATIC, REFINED
PRODUCT STORAGE BECAUSE THAT
COULD GET INTO SHELF LIFE
PROBLEMS. WE ARE ASKING TO USE,
AS THE REFINERY DOES, THE
CONSTANCY OF THE WAY IT IT MOVES
AND SUCH. SO IF YOU COULD SPEAK
TO THAT. FIRST THAT AND THEN
YEAH, SHE WANTS TO. AND IF YOU
WANT TO RESPOND THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR, IF I MAY JUST WANT TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE,
SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF A CONTEXT
BASED ON WHAT THE INFORMATION
THAT WAS SHARED. WE WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE. AND I WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE, YOU KNOW, AS A
REPRESENTATIVE, THESE ARE
COMPLEX OPERATIONS. THESE ARE
VERY COMPLEX OPERATIONS. WE ARE
NOT DEBATING THAT. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, WHAT DIRECTOR MILDER
MENTIONED, SOME OF THE OPTIONS
THAT NEEDS TO BE IMPLEMENTED ARE
STRAIGHTFORWARD. AND OUR HOPE IS
WE COULD WORK WITH THE INDUSTRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW BEST TO
OPERATIONALIZE THEM. SO TO YOUR
TO YOUR QUESTION, IF I, IF I GO
BACK WHEN WE TALK ABOUT TANKAGE,
TANKAGE ARE TYPICALLY ABOUT
BLENDING COMPONENTS. SO THERE
WILL BE ALKYLATE THERE WILL BE
SOMETHING ELSE, THERE'LL BE
SOMETHING ELSE. AND THEN FINALLY
YOU'LL HAVE THE PRODUCTION
TANKAGE QUOTE UNQUOTE, WHICH
WHERE YOU MIX ALL THESE BLENDING
COMPONENTS TOGETHER. ONE OF THE
INDUSTRY COLLEAGUES AND I SAID
THIS REALLY WELL IN ONE OF OUR
INTERNAL MEETINGS, IS IT'S LIKE
MAKING CAKES. YOU KNOW, I NEED
EGGS, I NEED MILK, I NEED SUGAR,
I NEED BAKING POWDER. I'M
BRINGING ALL OF THEM IN TANKS,
AND I'M GOING TO CONSTANTLY
MIXING THEM TO MAKE CAKES ON THE
OTHER END. THE PROBLEM IS
SPECIFIC BLENDING COMPONENTS
COULD RUN LOW. SO FOR EXAMPLE,
ONE OF THE CRITICAL COMPONENTS
OF A REFINERY IS THE FCC UNIT.
IF THE FCC UNIT GOES OUT YOU
CANNOT PRODUCE ALKALINE. SO IF
YOU HAVE ALKYLATE STORED AHEAD
OF TIME TO LEVELS THAT YOU COULD
STORE, YOU WOULD NOT HAVE TO
STOP PRODUCTION OF REFINED FUEL
JUST BECAUSE YOUR FCC UNIT GOES
OUT. AND THAT HAPPENS TODAY.
THAT HAPPENS TODAY. SO WHEN WE
HAVE MAINTENANCE EVENTS, YOU
KNOW, THE REFINERIES DON'T SHUT
DOWN. THEY TAKE THE EXISTING
BLENDING COMPONENTS AND KEEP
MIXING REFINED FUEL. THE PROBLEM
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO PRODUCE
FUEL COMES WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE
INDEPENDENT COMPONENTS. SO WHAT
WE SEE BASED ON THE DATA THAT
HAS BEEN SHARED WITH US,
OPPORTUNITY TO MAXIMIZE THOSE
INVENTORIES. AND SO WE'LL BE
WORKING WITH REFINERY BY
REFINERY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT CAN
BE STORED TO, TO KIND OF MAKE
THAT AVAILABLE DURING THESE
EXTREME TIMES. SO THE SECOND
POINT IN TERMS OF STORAGE, YOU
KNOW, THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
STORAGE, AS I MENTIONED, YOU
KNOW, IF WE COUNT THREE SEPARATE
COMPONENTS IN CALIFORNIA, ONE IS
JUST THE REFINERY GATE YOU HAVE
WITHIN THE REFINERY. THE
DIFFERENT TANKS, YOU HAVE
COMMERCIAL OPERATIONS. AND IF
YOU COUNT ALL OF THAT TOGETHER,
WE HAVE 24 DAYS OF NET OPERATING
CAPACITY IN CALIFORNIA,
TRANSLATING TO 19.1 MILLION
BARRELS. ALL OF THAT
COLLECTIVELY. SO WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HOW DO WE USE ALL THAT
CAPACITY NOT TO MAINTAIN 24
DAYS, NOT TO MAINTAIN 15 DAYS,
TO MAINTAIN INCREMENTALLY A DAY
OR TWO, DEPENDING ON WHAT'S
FEASIBLE? OKAY. THANK YOU. GOING
TO RESPOND TO THAT. YEAH. AND
JUST TO YOUR FIRST POINT,
SENATOR, AND APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME TODAY ON THE MINIMUM
INVENTORY. SO WORKING TANKS
GOING UP AND DOWN, UP AND DOWN
FOR THE COMPONENTS, I THINK ALSO
A COMPLEX MARKET BECAUSE THOSE
ARE ALL COMMODITIES, WHICH IF
YOU'RE NOW TALKING ABOUT MINIMUM
WHICH IS IN THE BILL POTENTIALLY
THE AUTHORITY FOR THE AUTHORITY
FOR IT, BUT NOT AN AMOUNT OR A
GUARANTEE THAT IT SETS A
MINIMUM, A MINIMUM, NO. BUT THE
I THINK OUR CONCERN IS WITH THE
MINIMUM, WHAT IS THAT NUMBER?
WE'VE HEARD 14 DAYS, 15 DAYS
HEARD ONE, TWO DAYS. IT'S
UNCLEAR IN THE BILL. AND THAT'S
PART OF OUR CONCERN AS AN
INDUSTRY IS WE DON'T KNOW THE
UNKNOWN. I THINK FOR THE WORKING
TANKS, WHICH IS WHAT THE
PROCESS, WHAT THE REGS WOULD
THAT PROCESS, WHICH I THINK,
YEAH, YES, THE PROCESS WOULD
DEVELOP WHAT THAT DAY
SPECIFICALLY IS AND I THINK THAT
WOULD POTENTIALLY DEFER REFINERY
BY REFINERY, I THINK FOR THE
WORKING TANK CAPACITY AND THE
COMPONENTS CAPACITY IS YOU ARE
CONSTANTLY BRINGING IN BATCHES
OF FUEL OF COMPONENTS FOR THE
FINISHED GASOLINE PROCESS.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY CERTIFYING THE
TANK TO ENSURE IT'S A PURE
PRODUCT. SO ONCE IT GETS TO THAT
FINISHED TANK, YOU HAVE TO
CERTIFY THAT IT IS, YOU KNOW,
THE GASOLINE YOU SAID IT IS AND
THEN YOU'RE AUDITED AT THE END
OF THE YEAR. YOU ARE THEN
SENDING OUT BATCHES OF FUEL. SO
YOU'RE CONSTANTLY DROPPING YOUR
FUEL SUPPLY AND PUTTING INTO A
PIPELINE SYSTEM LIKE KINDER
MORGAN, GASOLINE, DIESEL JET IS
USUALLY HOW IT GOES. AND THEN
YOU SEND ALONG THESE BATCHES OF
THOUSANDS, THOUSANDS OF BARRELS
OF GASOLINE. AND SO IT IS A
COMPLEX. SO IF YOU'RE REQUIRED
TO HAVE THAT MINIMUM INVENTORY,
I THINK PART OF OUR CONCERN IS
YOU ARE POTENTIALLY GOING IN AND
OUT OF COMPLIANCE AND THEN
POTENTIALLY SUBJECT TO THE
100,000 TO MILLION DOLLAR A DAY
PENALTY. IF I MAY, THROUGH THE
CHAIR, WE HAVE THE BOILERMAKERS
UNION HERE TODAY. THEY'RE THE
ONES WHO WOULD ACTUALLY BUILD
TANKS IF WE WERE STILL REQUIRING
THAT IN THE BILL. THE BILL DOES
NOT IS NOT, TO YOUR POINT,
REQUIRE THE BUILDING OF TANKS
ANYMORE. AND SO IT'S HARD FOR US
TO RECONCILE. THERE'S NOT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH CAPACITY. BUT
YOU CAN'T BUILD TANKS. BUT YOU
GOT TO USE THE CAPACITY YOU HAVE
ON HAND, BUT IT DIFFERS ABOUT
WHAT IS IN THOSE TANKS NOW AND
THE COMPONENTS AND HOW THE STUFF
IS REFINED. SO I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A BOILERMAKER
REPRESENTATIVE HERE WHO WOULD BE
PREPARED TO TALK ABOUT TANKS AND
HOW THEY'RE BUILT. IF YOU HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT. WELL,
NOT ACTUALLY. I THINK MY REAL
POINT WAS THAT IT IT DOESN'T
EXPLICITLY. WHAT IT PROHIBITS IS
IF THERE IS EXISTING STORAGE,
BUT IT DOESN'T I MEAN, I THINK
OBVIOUSLY IT'S CONSTRUCTED IN A
WAY WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID
INCREASING COSTS. RIGHT. AND
THERE OBVIOUSLY MAY BE SOME THE
ANALYSIS POINTS THAT OUT, AS
DOES THE CÁC ZONE FIGURES. BUT
THE AMENDMENTS AND THE WORK THAT
THE ASSEMBLY DID IS TRYING TO
MINIMIZE ANY OF THOSE COSTS. AND
SO THE BUILDING OF TANKS WOULD
OBVIOUSLY CREATE A COST.
HOWEVER, IT DOESN'T SAY
ABSOLUTELY CANNOT. SO IN OTHER
WORDS, THE PROCESSES THAT THE
DIVISION AND THE CEC WOULD HAVE
TO UNDERGO TO MAKE THESE
DETERMINATIONS. THIS IS PARTLY
WHY I LIKE THE CONSTRUCT OF THE
BILL, BECAUSE RATHER THAN WE,
THE LEGISLATURE, BEFORE WE KNOW
ALL OF THIS AND BEFORE WE ARE
GIVING THE AUTHORITY TO THE CEC
AND THE DIVISION TO, THROUGH A
STAKEHOLDER IN A PUBLIC PROCESS,
MAKE THESE DETERMINATIONS, AND
BOILERMAKERS MAY GET TO BUILD
SOME TANKS. WE'LL SEE ANYWAY.
BUT FINALLY, ON THE WORKER
SAFETY, YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE
THAT OUR OUR BUILDING TRADES
THAT WORK IN THE REFINERIES ARE
CONCERNED. I THINK THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE SENATE HAS
INTRODUCED THAT ARE REFLECTED IN
THIS. I UNDERSTAND YOU STILL ARE
NOT SATISFIED WITH THEM. I
APPRECIATE THAT TOO, BUT I THINK
THEY'VE GONE A LONG WAY TO
ADDRESSING SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS BY ALLOWING FOR THE
EMERGENCY MAINTENANCE AND
ACTIONS SO THAT WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY PUT WORKER SAFETY
FIRST. AND I WOULD JUST
REFERENCE IT'S NOT IN THE
ANALYSIS BECAUSE IT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT, BUT THE BILL BELIEVE
IT WAS SB 54. I CAN'T REMEMBER
THE EXACT NUMBER. I ALWAYS
FORGET THE BILL THAT SENATOR
HANCOCK AND I DID WITH THE
BOILERMAKERS AND WITH BUILDING
TRADES TO REALLY HELP ENSURE
THAT WORKER SAFETY WAS FIRST AND
FOREMOST IN ALL OF OUR TURNOVERS
AND REFINERY MAINTENANCE AND
NOTHING IN THE BILL IN ANY WAY
RESCINDS OR OR UNDERMINES ANY OF
THAT, WHICH I'M ALSO VERY
PLEASED ABOUT. SO. SO, SENATOR,
IF I CAN JUST ADD ONE, ONE KIND
OF NUMBER OR KIND OF CONTEXT FOR
YOU, JUST TO KIND OF KEEP THE
STORAGE THING TO BED THE LAST. I
MEAN, IF YOU LOOK AT 2022, WHEN
YOU HAD ADDITIONAL REFINERIES
OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA, AT THIS
POINT OF TIME, WE HAD LOWER,
LOWER INVENTORIES CAUSING THE
PRICE SPIKES. THIS YEAR, WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST INVENTORIES COMPARED
TO 22 AND 23, WITH LOWER NUMBER
OF REFINERIES AND NO PRICE
SPIKES OR LOWER PRICE SPIKES. SO
IT'S JUST IT DOESN'T ATTRACT
THAT. WE DON'T HAVE STORAGE
BECAUSE WE ARE RUNNING AT A
HIGHER INVENTORY LEVEL TODAY
COMPARED TO EVEN 2022, 23. AND I
WOULD ADD TO FOLLOW UP ON A
POINT THAT. REAL QUICK. ALL
RIGHT. YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THE GAS SPIKES IN 2022 AND 2023.
FOUR REFINERIES WENT DOWN.
THAT'S PART OF THE GAS SPIKE.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT. THIS WOULD NOT ALLEVIATE
THAT IN THE LEAST. THEY HAD
UNSCHEDULED REFINERY MAINTENANCE
I THINK ONE REFINERY CAUGHT ON
FIRE OR SOMETHING. AND THEN THAT
TAKES A WHILE. THEY HAD LOWER
THAN NORMAL INVENTORY DUE TO
HIGHER THAN NORMAL DEMAND. AND
THEN THEY HAD LOWER THAN NORMAL
FUEL IMPORTS BECAUSE OF THE
GLOBAL DISRUPTION, BECAUSE WE
WERE JUST STARTING A WAR OVER IN
THE MIDDLE EAST. AND ALSO IN
UKRAINE. WE HAD GLOBAL REFINERY
SHORTFALLS DUE TO WARS, LABOR
AND SUPPLY CHAIN SHORTAGES. IF
YOU REMEMBER, POST COVID, WE HAD
BOATS FLOATING OFF THE THING
WITH ALL OF THE THING. SO THERE
WERE NUMEROUS THINGS THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH STORAGE TANKS
THAT WERE CAUSING THIS. THESE
PRICE SPIKES THAT WE HAD, THE
EXTRAORDINARY PRICE SPIKES THAT
WE HAD IN THERE. AND YOU'VE
REFERRED TO IT SEVERAL TIMES,
BUT BUT THIS, YOU KNOW, IT ISN'T
JUST THAT. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
IT'S IMPORTANT WHEN YOU DO REFER
TO THOSE THAT YOU LABEL ALL OF
THE ISSUES THAT WERE GOING ON,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHY IT'S THAT'S
WHAT'S DIFFERENT TODAY THAN IT
WAS THEN. TODAY WE'VE STABILIZED
A LITTLE BIT OF THE GLOBAL THING,
ALTHOUGH THAT'S GOING TO BECOME
AN ISSUE PRETTY SOON. I THINK
AGAIN, YOU KNOW, AND THIS THIS
STORAGE SCHEME IS NOT GOING TO
OFFSET WHAT'S HAPPENING
GLOBALLY. AND SO TO, TO JUST LAY
IT ALL OFF ON WE DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH STORAGE. INVENTORY IS NOT
ACCURATE. AND I THINK IT'S
MISLEADING TO THE PEOPLE THAT
DON'T KNOW AS MUCH ABOUT THIS AS
YOU MIGHT. AND WE NEED ACCURATE
INFORMATION IF WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS TO OUR CONSTITUENTS. WE
NEED ACCURATE INFORMATION. THANK
YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT
REAL QUICK. YEAH. QUICKLY,
SENATOR, AGAIN, ALWAYS
APPRECIATE YOUR LINE OF
QUESTIONING. I'VE SAID THAT IN
THE IN THE PAST, YOU KNOW,
HAVING THOSE QUESTIONS HELP US
BE MORE ACCOUNTABLE. AND IT IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF CÁC HERE, TO
MAINTAIN PUBLIC TRUST AND
INTEGRITY TO DATA WITH YOU. SO
WITH THAT, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE LAST FEW YEARS, YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. THERE'S A LOT
OF FACTORS PLAYING IN, BUT AT
THE SAME TIME, THE FACTOR AROUND
INVENTORIES WAS ALSO PLAYING IN.
SO IF YOU REMOVE THE GLOBAL
CRUDE OIL ISSUES, IF YOU REMOVE
THOSE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES, YOU
STILL SEE THE SPIKE. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE BEEN PRESENTING. THE
SPIKE IS VERY PARTICULAR TO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY WAS ALSO HAVING
CRUDE OIL PRICES, SPIKES GOING
UP. AND WE'RE SPECIFICALLY
LOOKING AT ISOLATING THE PRICE
SPIKE TO CALIFORNIA AND ITS
RELATIONSHIP. AND CORRELATION TO
THE INVENTORIES IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR REGULATORY CLIMATE IN
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO VERY UNIQUE
TO THE OTHER PLACES, AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT DRIVES THOSE
PRICE. PRICE SPIKES. THANK YOU,
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR MAINTAINING THIS COMMITTEE
AS A AT LEAST THE POLICY
STANDING COMMITTEE, AS A
WATCHDOG HERE ON THESE BROADER
ENERGY AFFORDABILITY ISSUES. I
THINK WE ALL OWE YOU A DEBT OF
GRATITUDE FOR YOUR VIGILANCE ON
AFFORDABILITY AND KEEPING THINGS
AS SIMPLE AS THEY CAN, BUT NOT
SIMPLER. I WANTED TO FOLLOW UP,
I GUESS, ON THIS SAME LINE OF
QUESTIONING THAT WE'VE BEEN
PAWING AT TO THE VICE CHAIRS
POINT, AND SOMEWHAT FROM SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR AND SENATOR SKINNER
AS WELL. I'M UNDER NO ILLUSION
THAT SOMEHOW AB TWO ONE, AND NO
OFFENSE TO THE AUTHOR, IS GOING
TO SOLVE ALL OF OUR PROBLEMS AT
THE PUMP. AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A SORT OF A MAGIC
REALIGNMENT OF THE LEVERAGE THAT
THAT THE OIL INDUSTRY HAS OVER
DRIVERS IN THIS STATE WHERE
DRIVERS REALLY ARE STUCK AND
OFTEN HELD OVER A BARREL ABOUT
CHOICES THAT THEY MAY HAVE. I, I
DO THINK THAT THE ADDRESSING
THIS STORAGE PIECE, OR AT LEAST
GIVING AUTHORITY TO ADDRESS THIS
STORAGE PIECE AND GET INTO THE
INFORMATION GATHERING AND THE
SORT OF REGULATORY PROCESS WITH
AND WITH AN EYE KEENLY ON SAFETY
AS SORT OF THE, THE COMPASS HERE
TO GET THROUGH IT IS GOING TO BE
GOOD FOR ORGANIZED LABOR. I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE GOOD FOR
THE WORKERS THAT WE WORRIED
ABOUT WITH SB 54. I DID WANT TO
GET A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE. I KNOW
WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME FOR A WIENER
TESTIMONY, BUT FOR THE IF THE
STEELWORKERS ARE STILL HERE, IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU Þ YOU WANT
TO BRING THEM UP. OKAY. SO I'D
LOVE TO HEAR FROM THEM. JUST
SORT OF THE NOT THE TURNAROUND
JOB PERSPECTIVE, BUT SORT OF THE
EVERYDAY TO SEE IF SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE MADE
SINCE THE ASSEMBLY SORT OF
ADDRESSED SOME OF THOSE
WORKPLACE SAFETY ISSUES. I DO
THINK YOU'VE MADE SOME, SOME
MEANINGFUL IMPROVEMENTS HERE. I
AM CONCERNED THAT WE STILL
HAVEN'T STAFFED UP AT DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS, AND
THAT THERE ARE ONGOING BUDGET
PRESSURES ON BOTH DPMO AND ON
CSB ON THIS FRONT. SO MY FIRST
QUESTION WAS A IS REALLY
SOMEWHAT OF A FISCAL ONE, BUT
IT'S HOW ARE WE GOING TO FIND A
WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE GOT
THE PERSONNEL IN GOVERNMENT TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS WORK? I'VE
HEARD FROM A LOT OF OUR FRIENDS
IN THE TRADES THAT IT WOULD
ACTUALLY MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE
TO BE ABLE TO GO HIRE A FEW MORE
FOLKS AT DER. THE CHAIR HIMSELF
HAS MADE THIS POINT OVER THE
YEARS, BUT THE ONE POSITION
REQUESTED, I BELIEVE, IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. I THINK IT WAS
LIKE A $280,000 POSITION IS
STILL NOT FILLED. THAT'S JUST
DER. WE KNOW THAT DPMO AND CEC
ARE GOING TO HAVE REAL WORK TO
DO HERE, AND THAT YOU ACTUALLY
HAVEN'T LANDED ON AN ANSWER, AND
YOU'RE SORT OF WORKING BACKWARDS
FROM THERE, BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE
JUST TRYING TO BUILD UP THE
CAPACITY TO DIGEST VERY COMPLEX
MARKET INFORMATION FOR THE FIRST
TIME. THIS IS GROUNDBREAKING
STUFF. SO DO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT
THERE'S NO DIRECT PAY FOR HERE?
AND WE KNOW THAT THE OPERATING
ACCOUNT THAT FUNDS CDC AND DPMO
IS IN A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT HERE.
AND A LOT OF IT'S FUNDED BY
UTILITY RATEPAYERS. EPA IS
LARGELY ELECTRIC RATEPAYER
FUNDED. WE'RE NOT REALLY TALKING
ABOUT ELECTRICITY HERE. SO FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
HERE, DO YOU HAVE A PERSPECTIVE
ON WHETHER WE SHOULD BE
EXPECTING A SORT OF A SBX ONE
TWO AND TWO ONE SORT OF COMBO
FUNDING PROPOSAL, SAY, IN THE
COMING BUDGET CYCLE? I REALLY
WANT TO BE SURE THAT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THAT SORT OF
INDEPENDENT AGENCY JUDGMENT
BUILT UP AND THAT THE CAPACITY
IS GOING TO BE THERE. SO I JUST
WANTED TO GET PERSPECTIVE AND
MAYBE TOO SOON. I WAS ENCOURAGED
BY THE AB TWO X1 OR X2 TWO NINE
REASONABLE COST RECOVERY
MECHANISM THAT WAS IN THE
PETRIE-NORRIS BILL. I THOUGHT
THAT ACTUALLY WAS THE GROUNDWORK
FOR SOMETHING SOLID, AND IT
SOUNDED LIKE INDUSTRY AND LABOR
WERE OPEN TO THAT. A $5 MILLION
CAP COST RECOVERY. RIGHT NOW, WE
KNOW IT'S A $6 MILLION REQUEST.
ON THE EPA FRONT, STILL
UNFULFILLED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
SO I'M WORRIED WE'RE WE'RE
ADDING A LOT OF IMPORTANT NEW
AUTHORITIES WITHOUT THE PEOPLE
TO HANDLE IT. CARE TO COMMENT ON
THAT? THANK YOU, SENATOR STERN,
ON THAT QUESTION. I ALWAYS WANT
TO JUST START BY SAYING THANK
YOU FOR THE RESOURCES WE DO
HAVE. AS OF NOW. AND THANKS FOR
THE POSITIONS THAT WERE GIVEN TO
US WITHIN THE SP ONE TWO
CONTEXT. I THINK THE AT KIND OF
THE TOP LINE, YOU KNOW, PRICE
TIME AND QUALITY AND I THINK
THE, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE TO
COMPROMISE ON ONE OR THE OTHER,
YOU KNOW, DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH
WORKLOAD THIS WILL BE, WE ARE
STILL KIND OF LOOKING AT WHAT
THE FINAL AMENDMENTS WILL LOOK
LIKE AND THAT WILL SET OUR WORK
PLAN FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS. I THINK WE WOULD, YOU
KNOW, LIKELY HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF A SUPPORT NEEDED, BUT I THINK
IT ALSO PLAYS INTO DEPENDING ON
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THE
BROADER BUDGET IN A
CONSOLIDATION WE'VE DONE, MANY
OF OUR AGENCIES WERE REQUESTED
TO, YOU KNOW, SWEEP. THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN FILLED YET. AND SO
I THINK WE ARE KIND OF LOOKING
AT THE IMPACT OF THAT. WHAT WE
ARE GIVING UP BASED ON WHAT WE
GIVE UP. AND, YOU KNOW, LOOKING
AT HOW THE AMENDMENTS WOULD COME
AND THERE MIGHT BE A MINOR
REQUEST THAT MIGHT COME UP, I
WOULD CERTAINLY WELCOME THAT
REQUEST AND IN FACT, BE OPEN TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL ON
DEVELOPING AND ESPECIALLY
FINDING A COORDINATED WAY TO
DEAL WITH THIS, THIS, THIS SORT
OF UNIQUE OIL AND GAS MARKET
OVERSIGHT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE VERSUS THE SORT OF
ELECTRIC OVERSIGHT, RIGHT. AND,
AND GETTING THIS OFF THE RATE
BASE AND SORT OF MORE SQUARELY
INTO A COST RECOVERY FRAMEWORK
THAT IS NOT A NEW TAX, BUT
INSTEAD SORT OF AN
IMPLEMENTATION FEE, IF YOU WILL.
SO I WANT TO SORT OF JUST PLANT
THAT SEED AND HOPEFULLY THAT
STARTS TO BEAR SOME FRUIT IN THE
COMING YEAR. THE ONE OTHER
QUESTION I, I WANTED TO TOUCH ON
IS THE ONGOING WORK GOING
OCCURRING AT DPMO, NOT JUST ON
THIS STORAGE AND RESERVES
QUESTION, BUT ON SOME OF THE
BROADER UNADDRESSED VOLATILITIES
WE'VE SEEN. WE HAVEN'T BEEN
TALKING A LOT ABOUT THE MYSTERY
SURCHARGE, AND I'M REALLY
CONCERNED THAT, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS TO ME A NECESSARY MEASURE,
BUT IT'S NOT SUFFICIENT. AND I,
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOMETHING
BACK FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AT
LEAST ROUNDING OUT OR ASSESSING
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES, BECAUSE
THE TWO THINGS THAT IN MY VIEW,
MAKE US VERY UNIQUE IN
CALIFORNIA AS A MARKET IS ONE
ARE THE PRODUCT WE REFINE AND
THE SORT OF NATURE OF THIS NINE
REFINERY ISLAND AND LIMITED
PIPES IN AND OUT. BUT TWO THE
LARGE ROLE THAT BRANDED GASOLINE
PLAYS AND THIS THIS UNIQUE
DYNAMIC OF DEALER TANK WAGONS
AND WHERE YOU HAVE BRANDED GAS
COMING FROM REFINERS AND, YOU
KNOW, PLAYING A VERY DOMINANT
SHARE IN THE MARKET. WHEREAS YOU
SEE ON THE EAST COAST A LOT MORE
RETAIL COMPETITION, MORE FOLKS
ARE BUYING FROM THE RACK LESS
THESE SORT OF OTHER CONTRACTUAL
ARRANGEMENTS. SO IS THERE A PLAN
IN THE ADMINISTRATION TO ADDRESS
IF WE GIVE YOU THIS AUTHORITY,
IS THIS ALL YOU'RE GOING TO BE
FOCUSED ON IS STORAGE AND
RESERVES AND REFINERIES, OR IS
THERE GOING TO BE MORE EFFORT
MADE ON ON THIS RETAIL FRONT?
AND CAN WE EXPECT, YOU KNOW,
SOME SOMETHING MORE TO CHEW ON
THERE GOING FORWARD. YEAH. WELL
I'LL START HERE AND THEN ASK THE
VICE CHAIR TO JOIN IN. THIS IS
URGENT. SO THE IDEA THAT THERE
ARE THESE PRICE SPIKES, WE DID A
CALCULATION 2023 PRICE SPIKE.
THERE WAS ONE OVER $2 BILLION
THAT CONSUMERS WERE PAYING
EXCESS EXCESS PROFITS. AND SO I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT A
LOT OF DPMO AND SEC COLLEAGUES
ARE HERE WORKING INCREDIBLY
HARD. WE CAN PRIORITIZE
DIFFERENT IMPORTANT THINGS. AND
I THINK SO RIGHT NOW, BEING ABLE
TO SORT OF STOP THESE CRAZY
PRICE SPIKES IS A GREAT FIRST
STEP IN PROTECTING CONSUMERS.
BUT, SENATOR, YOUR COMMENTS ARE
VERY WELL TAKEN. THERE ARE OTHER
STRUCTURAL THINGS IN THIS
MARKET, AND DPMO HAS THREE PHD
ECONOMISTS. NOW THAT WE'VE GOT
ON BOARD, WE'RE USING THE DATA
TRANSPARENCY FROM SBX 1 OR 2
DASH ONE. AND SO I THINK THAT
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A
POSITION TO SHED MORE LIGHT ON
THAT. SO I'M GOING TO PLEDGE TO
YOU THAT WE WILL BRING MORE
VISIBILITY TO WHY PRICES ARE
HIGHER IN CALIFORNIA. LOOKING AT
SOME OF THESE ISSUES BETWEEN
BRANDED AND UNBRANDED AND THE
SALES MECHANISMS, THE PT THAT
YOU MENTIONED, I ALSO WANT TO
TAKE ONE MORE OPPORTUNITY. THE
ASSEMBLY HEARINGS HAVE BEEN
REFERENCED HERE. A COUPLE OF
TIMES. THERE WERE HOURS AND
HOURS OF PRETTY TECHNICAL
DISCUSSIONS, FOR EXAMPLE, OF HOW
MUCH STORAGE CAPACITY DO WE
HAVE? AND CDC AND DPMO BOTH MADE
AFFIRMATIVE PRESENTATIONS OF THE
DATA. I THINK INDUSTRY ADDRESSED
IT MORE ON THIS HYPOTHETICAL
LEVEL. WAS NOT PRESENTING DATA.
I WOULD JUST POINT FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE'S
CONFIDENCE, I WOULD REFERENCE
JUNE 20TH, 22, APRIL 2023 AND
FEBRUARY 2024. AND I'M PICKING
THOSE DATES BECAUSE THEY'RE
DIFFERENT MONTHS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR WITH SEASONALITY. AND THOSE
ARE DATES WHERE REFINERS IN
CALIFORNIA HAD ABOUT 13 MILLION
BARRELS IN STORAGE. AND THEN
DURING THE PRICE SPIKES, WE SEE
MORE LIKE 10 OR 11 MILLION
BARRELS. SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TAKE OUR WORD FOR IT THAT
THERE'S EXCESS CAPACITY. LOOK AT
HOW THEY OPERATE CURRENTLY. YOU
CAN ALREADY SEE THAT SLACK
CAPACITY IN THE SYSTEM. THAT'S
NOT LIKE A MATTER OF DEBATE
REALLY. AND I THINK THAT DATA
CLEARLY CAME IN WITH THE
ASSEMBLY HEARINGS, AS DID THIS
PHENOMENON OF HOW PRICE SPIKES
HAPPEN DURING THESE LOW
INVENTORY PERIODS. AND THE SORT
OF HOCKEY STICK EFFECT OF
INVENTORIES. BUT TO YOUR POINT,
SENATOR, THERE ARE OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT STEPS AHEAD OF US AS
WELL. BUT PROTECTING CONSUMERS
FROM PRICE SPIKES IS AN URGENT
NEED. AND I'D LIKE TO RESPOND,
IF I MAY, IF I MAY, THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. THROUGH THE CHAIR TO
THE TO THE WORKFORCE QUESTIONS.
YOU AND SENATOR SKINNER TOUCHED
ON IT OCCURS TO ME NOW THAT
SENATOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SKINNER, THEN SENATOR HANCOCK,
AND I THINK SENATOR STERN, YOU
MIGHT HAVE BEEN STAFFING SENATOR
HANCOCK ON THAT BILL. IT JUST
SORT OF FULL CIRCLE MOMENT FOR
ME HERE. YOU KNOW, WE APPRECIATE
THE REQUIREMENT TO USE A SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE TO DO THE
WORK. AND THE SIZE OF THE
REFINERIES IS INCLUDED IN THE
BILL. B2 OF THE BILL IN SECTION
ONE REQUIRES THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR TO BE SATISFIED WITH
THE RESUPPLY PLANS BEFORE THE
REGULATORY PROCESS IS FINISHED
REGARDING THE MAINTENANCE AND
TURNAROUNDS. SO IF WE CAN'T EVEN
GET A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE IN THERE TO DO THE
WORK, THE WORK IS NOT GOING TO
GET DONE IN A CORRECT FASHION.
AND FOR THE FOLKS THAT I
REPRESENT WHO ARE IN THE
REFINERIES, THIS WORK NEEDS TO
BE DONE ON A SCHEDULE AT TIMES
WHEN IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN. AND,
YOU KNOW, IN SITUATIONS WHERE
THERE'S A CONCERN ABOUT ONGOING
PROCESSES AT THE REFINERIES,
THEIR VOICES NEED TO BE HEARD.
BUT UNDER B TWO OF THE BILL, AS
A CRITERIA, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR HAS TO BE HAS TO BE
HAPPY WITH THE RESUPPLY PLANS.
ESSENTIALLY, I'M PARAPHRASING,
HAPPY WITH THE RESUPPLY PLANS
BEFORE THE REGULATION CAN GO
FORWARD TO DO THE MAINTENANCE
TURNAROUND. BUT FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR MEMBERS, IF THE SOLE FOCUS
WASN'T SO MUCH JUST ON REFINING
STORAGE MARGINS, THESE ISSUES, I
MEAN, AND WE WERE LOOKING MORE
BROADLY AT THE GASOLINE
MARKETPLACE, FOR INSTANCE, SOME
OF THESE RETAIL ISSUES WE
BROUGHT UP IS THERE AN OPENNESS,
YOU THINK, FROM BUILDING TRADES
MEMBERS TO LOOKING DOWNSTREAM AT
SOME OF THE DISTRIBUTION ISSUES
AND SORT OF MAYBE DIVERSIFYING
HOW WE LOOK AT, YOU KNOW, THE
OUR GASOLINE MARKET? I THINK
THAT OUR MEMBERS, THE MEMBERS I
REPRESENT FUEL FEEL MAYBE MOST
ACUTELY OF ALL THE WORKERS IN
OUR ECONOMY, THE HIGH COST OF
GASOLINE. THEY HAVE THEIR TOOLS.
THEY HAVE TO DRIVE. OFTENTIMES
MANY MILES BACK AND FORTH TO
THEIR JOB SITES. THEY HAVE TO
FILL UP THEIR CARS AS OFTEN OR
MORE THAN ANYBODY ELSE IN OUR
ECONOMY. SO I THINK, YOU KNOW,
IN THIS CASE, OUR MEMBERS ARE
FEELING WHAT YOU'RE GETTING AT
WITH THIS BILL TODAY AS WELL.
THEY DON'T THEY JUST DON'T WANT
TO TRADE OFF THEIR SAFETY OR
THEIR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
SAFETY WHO ARE WORKING IN
REFINERIES FOR SAVING A FEW
PENNIES PER GALLON AT THE PUMP.
BUT IN OPENNESS ON LOOKING
CLOSER AT THE RETAIL SIDE, I
THINK IF IT'S GOING TO HELP
LOWER COSTS FOR OUR MEMBERS,
WE'RE ALWAYS WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR A PLACE TO DO THAT.
OKAY. THANKS. THANK YOU. SENATOR
GONZALES, THROUGH THE CHAIR. MAY
I RESPOND? WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND? SENATOR STERN, I THINK
YOU YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD. THIS MARKET IS COMPLEX. WE
ARE UNIQUE. YOU YOU MENTIONED
CARB. WE HAVE A UNIQUE FUEL THAT
SETS US APART FROM THE REST OF
THE NATION. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
GULF COAST IN THE EAST, THEY ARE
INTERCONNECTED VIA A PIPELINE
CONNECTED TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
REFINERIES THAT ARE VERY
EFFICIENT AT RUNNING CRUDE. AND
SO WHEN OPERATIONS GO DOWN, THEY
ARE ABLE TO MAKE UP WITH THE
REDUNDANCY IN THE SYSTEM. WE
JUST DON'T HAVE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T HAVE THAT
REDUNDANCY ANYMORE. ON YOUR
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
DOWNSTREAM FROM THE REFINERY,
YOU KNOW, I THINK WE HAVE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THIS MYSTERY
SURCHARGE FOR A WHILE. WE HAVE
LOOKED AT THE RETAIL SPACE. I
THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE ACCURATE. WE
HAVE LESS GAS STATIONS PER
CAPITA THAN THE REST OF THE
NATION. WE ALSO HAVE MORE
BRANDED STATIONS THAN UNBRANDED
PER CAPITA. AND I THINK, YOU
KNOW, DIFFICULT TO EXPLAIN
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF LAND
USE POLICY THAT GOES INTO THE
COMPETITION LEVEL AT THE STREET.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE
CONSUMER STILL HAS CHOICE TO
LOOK AT THE 12 FOOT BILLBOARD
AND GO TO THE LOWEST COST OPTION
THAT WORKS FOR THEM. AND, YOU
KNOW, A LOT OF THE TIMES THEY
PEOPLE CHOOSE TO DO THAT. LOOK
ON DIFFERENT APPS AND WHATNOT,
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST THE BIGGER
CONCERN IS THAT IF THERE'S SOME
UNKNOWN, UNKNOWN HERE,
STRUCTURALLY IN THE RETAIL
GASOLINE MARKET, THAT'S
UNIQUELY, YOU KNOW, WHERE YOU
HAVE A CHEVRON REFINERY GIVING
THROUGH A SUBSIDIARY TO A
CHEVRON TRUCK, THEN TO A CHEVRON
GAS STATION WITH CONTRACTUAL
INCENTIVES DEPENDING ON THE
TIMING OF THAT SALE, TO EITHER
PUSH, YOU KNOW, TO SELL MORE
PUSH PRICES DOWN OR TO SELL
LESS, LIKE THERE ARE ALL KINDS
OF TOOLS IN THESE CONTRACTS THAT
I JUST FEEL LIKE WE DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWERS TO THOSE QUESTIONS.
I THINK THEY DO AFFECT FROM A
FROM A TRADE WORKER TO AN SEIU
WORKER TO, TO ME ON THE WAY TO
DRIVING MY KIDS TO SCHOOL.
RIGHT? I MEAN, IT AFFECTS
EVERYBODY. AND I JUST I HOPE
THAT WE RESOLVE OUT OF MOVING
THIS LEGISLATION TO COMMIT
OURSELVES TO THAT SORT OF MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THINGS
GOING FORWARD, GETTING THESE
AGENCIES FULLY FUNDED. YES,
LOOKING UPSTREAM, BUT ALSO GOING
DOWNSTREAM, I THINK WE SHOULD BE
OPEN ON SOME OF THE AB, X2 NINE
ISSUES RAISED AROUND. WE SHOULD
LOOK AT THE ETHANOL QUESTION. I
THINK WE SHOULD LOOK AT
PRODUCTION ENHANCEMENT
STRATEGIES. I THOUGHT THAT THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT MAY MAKE YOU
KNOW, SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT I'M CLOSE TO UNCOMFORTABLE,
BUT I THINK ALL OF US SHOULD BE
WILLING TO STRETCH AND EXPLORE
SOME OF THESE OPTIONS GOING INTO
NEXT YEAR. SO MAYBE, YOU KNOW,
MY SUGGESTION WOULD JUST BE NOT
TO TREAT THIS AS THE END OF THE
STORY, BUT TO THAT, YOU KNOW, AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME, I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AND GET
THIS DONE. BUT REALLY COUNTING
ON OUR EXPERTS HERE AND ON
INDUSTRY TO DO THAT
COLLABORATION, LIKE LET'S GET
OUT OF THE COURTROOM AND STOP
SUING ON DATA SHARING AND JUST
GET INTO IT. SO ANYWAY, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, FOR THE
INDULGENCE. AND THROUGH THE
CHAIR, IF I MAY RESPOND, I THINK
ON THE RETAIL SIDE, LARGELY
THERE IS A THE REFINERS HAVE
REALLY GOTTEN OUT OF THAT
BUSINESS. MOST OF THE RETAIL GAS
STATIONS ARE FRANCHISEES, SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS THAT HAVE THE
THEIR CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIPS
WITH WHOEVER THEY BUY THEIR FUEL
FROM. I THINK ON THE
DIVERSIFICATION POINT YOU MADE,
SENATOR STERN, AS IT RELATES TO
OTHER FUELS, USING EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE, THERE WAS A BILL
THIS YEAR THAT THE BUILDING
TRADES SUPPORTED. WE SUPPORTED
AS WELL, SB 983 THAT WOULD HAVE
LOOKED AT EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOW TO
INCORPORATE POTENTIALLY HYDROGEN
OR ELECTRIFICATION.
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT WAS VETOED
AND DUE TO COST PRESSURES AT THE
CEC. ARE YOU SURE YOU WANT TO
RESPOND? YOU WANT TO RESPOND
JUST KIND OF TO ADD TO THE
QUESTION THAT SENATOR STERN
ASKED EARLIER, SENATOR, THE
FUELS ASSESSMENT HAS ABOUT 15 TO
18 DIFFERENT OPTIONS. AND
DEPENDING ON HOW YOU BUCKET AND
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO REVISE
THAT PER MANDATE EVERY FEW YEARS
AND BRING BETTER FLESHED OUT
OPTIONS TO THE TABLE FOR YOU TO
THINK ABOUT. THANK YOU. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. YES, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD, AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE HEALTHY
DEBATE. I KNOW IT'S NOT BEEN
EASY FOR ANY OF US TO COME BACK
IN THIS SPECIAL SESSION. SO
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO HIT ON
THE POINTS. I KNOW THIS IS PART
TWO FROM THE DISCUSSIONS WE'VE
HAD ABOUT A YEAR OR SO AGO ON
WORKER SAFETY, AND I KNOW IT HAD
BEEN TALKED ABOUT MANY
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE COME TOGETHER,
INCLUDING OUR SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM, BUT IT HAS TO BE A VERY
MUCH A TOP PRIORITY. AND WE KNOW
THAT CONSUMERS ARE FEELING THIS
SPIKE EVERY SINGLE DAY, AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED, AND COMING OUT
OF THE ASSEMBLY FROM YOUR GOOD
WORK. JUST HAVE COMMENTS HERE.
BUT I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY WHAT
THE WORKER SAFETY AMENDMENTS DO.
FIRST, THE CEC WILL NOW BE
MANDATED THAT ANY NEW
REGULATIONS REQUIRED TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
EMPLOYEES, LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
THE PUBLIC HAS BEEN MENTIONED.
BUT MORE, MORE SPECIFICALLY THAT
THE COMMISSION MUST PRIORITIZE
WORKER SAFETY IN THEIR
RULEMAKING PROCESS, WHICH IS
FANTASTIC. AND THEN SECOND, AS
BEEN MENTIONED BY SENATOR
SKINNER, THE AMENDMENTS MAKE
VERY CLEAR THAT THE REGULATIONS
CAN'T INTERFERE WITH THE
AUTHORITY OF EMPLOYEES TO
PERFORM AN EMERGENCY SHUTDOWN OF
THE REFINERY PROCESS, OF COURSE,
AND NECESSARY MAINTENANCE ON
SAFETY. AND THEN TO ADD TO THAT
CANNOT INTERFERE WITH EXISTING
LAW REGARDING CALIFORNIA
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS AND WORKER PROTECTIONS
IN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE.
AND LASTLY, THE INSURER, WHICH I
THINK IS REALLY GREAT, THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A LABOR
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE
INDEPENDENT CONSUMER FUELS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO BE FROM A
LABOR ORGANIZATION WITH
EXPERIENCE IN REFINERY
OPERATIONS, ENSURING THAT THE
VOICES OF MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
WORKING ON THE FRONT LINES IN
OUR REFINERIES ACTUALLY HAVE A
SAY AT THE TABLE. AGAIN, I KNOW
A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE HAD ON THESE
COMPONENT ON WORKER SAFETY, BUT
WE WOULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN HERE IF
WE DIDN'T DO THIS TOGETHER. AND
I THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD, BRINGING
THE STAKEHOLDERS FORWARD AS
WELL. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING THIS ALONGSIDE SENATOR
STERN. SO THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
BACK TO YOU. YES. IF I MAY
RESPOND TO THE CHAIR AND
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR'S
COMMENTS. I THINK FOR US LOOKING
AT THIS FROM A SAFETY ANGLE,
ALONG WITH THE BUILDING TRADES,
AND I THINK MR. SMITH TOUCHED ON
IT A BIT. I THINK THE LANGUAGE
REALLY MATTERS HERE. ON WHERE
THIS NEW AUTHORITY IS COMING
FROM. SO NOW EXISTING LAW IS THE
REFINERS DER THAT IS KIND OF THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS. SOUTH
COAST, BAY AREA AQMD HAVE SOME
SOME ROLE IN HOW YOU DO YOUR
MAINTENANCE BECAUSE YOU GOT TO
UPDATE YOUR FACILITIES AS IT
RELATES TO RULES THAT ARE NOW
BEING IMPLEMENTED AT THE SOUTH
COAST LEVEL. SO YOU GOT TO DO
THAT KIND OF KIND OF MAINTENANCE
AS IT RELATES TO THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL. I THINK WHERE YOU'RE
HEARING OUR CONCERN FROM AS IT
RELATES TO SAFETY IS IN PAGE
FOUR TWO. SO THIS IS WHERE THE
NEW INSERTED AUTHORITY IS COMING
FROM. THAT BEFORE A REFINERY CAN
COMMENCE A TURNAROUND, THEY HAVE
TO DEMONSTRATE TO THE
SATISFACTION OF THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMISSION
SUFFICIENT ARRANGEMENTS FOR LOSS
OF PRODUCTION DURING THE
TURNAROUND OR MAINTENANCE EVENT.
AND I KNOW JEREMY TOUCHED ON
THIS A BIT, BUT I THINK THAT
THAT LANGUAGE THERE IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WHAT IF THE COMMISSIONER
IS UNSATISFIED? DOES THAT MEAN
BEFORE WE CAN COMMENCE OUR
MAINTENANCE, HE HAS TO BE HE OR
SHE HAS TO BECOME SATISFIED? AND
THAT'S WHERE THE DECISION MAKING
AND THE IMPOSITION OF THE
AUTHORITY IS, LET'S SAY THEY SAY
NO. AND OUR REFINERY CAN'T DO
ITS MAINTENANCE, BUT IS
CONTINUING TO OPERATE AND SERVE
THE MARKET. IF SOMETHING GOES
WRONG, WHO'S LIABLE? I THINK IS
A PART OF OUR QUESTION, BECAUSE
WE'VE ASKED TO DO THE
MAINTENANCE. WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
SATISFY THE REQUIREMENT. AND
THAT'S WHERE THAT DECISION
MAKING PROCESS HAS US CONCERNED
ABOUT SAFETY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BECKER. SENATOR BECKER. THANK
YOU. WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION. I
APPRECIATE BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD. I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
TO ADDRESS PRICES. I WAS JUST
REWATCHING A NBC STORY ABOUT THE
STATION THAT'S ESSENTIALLY
ACROSS THE STREET FROM MY
DISTRICT OFFICE, WHICH WAS
CHARGING $7.09 IN APRIL. IT WAS
DOWN TO ABOUT 640 WHEN I DROVE
BY YESTERDAY FOR REGULAR. BY THE
WAY. YEAH, YEAH, DOWN TO ABOUT
$6.40 FOR REGULAR. SO I, YOU
KNOW, ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
OF SENATOR STERN, THE SENSE OF,
YOU KNOW, WANTING TO LOOK AT THE
BIG PICTURE. I KNOW WE HAVE HAD
A NUMBER OF HEARINGS ON SOME OF
THE BIGGER PICTURE ISSUES. AND I
KNOW HERE WE'RE FOCUSED
OBVIOUSLY, SPECIFICALLY ON THIS
SOLUTION, BUT I DO SIMILARLY
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING SOME
OF THE OTHER, YOU KNOW,
DIMENSIONS HERE. WE MENTIONED
RETAIL. WE MENTIONED A FEW OTHER
PIECES. AND ALSO THAT THE CC
REPORT, WHICH WHICH TALKED ABOUT
THIS ALSO TALKED ABOUT
CONSERVATION. RIGHT. AND I'M
KIND OF CURIOUS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES DO PLANS TO
LAST COUPLE YEARS. THERE'S BEEN
BILLS TO FOCUS ON SUPER USERS.
SO TO TRY TO REALLY TARGET OUR
INCENTIVES FOR CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL A LOT BETTER ON ON THOSE
SUPER USERS AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
DRIVING WHO WE KNOW ARE DRIVING,
YOU KNOW, 30 000 MILES A YEAR.
AND JUST HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
KIND OF GET THAT, GET THAT GOING
FOR SOME REASON. SO I WONDER IF
YOU COULD SORT OF COMMENT ON
THAT. AND, AND KIND OF OPENNESS
TO EFFORTS TO LOOK, LOOK AT THAT
SIDE OF THINGS AS WE AS WE GO
FORWARD. AND THEN JUST TO CIRCLE
BACK ON THE WORKER SAFETY PIECE,
I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE,
MAJORITY LEADER GONZALEZ,
ADDRESSING THAT. THIS HAS BEEN A
BIG THING. WE CERTAINLY BROUGHT
THAT UP IN SOME OF OUR INTERNAL
DISCUSSIONS AND HAPPY TO SEE THE
AMENDMENTS. ALTHOUGH I KNOW IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S STILL ISSUES
ON THAT ON THAT SCORE, BUT MAYBE
I'LL JUST ASK THE ADMINISTRATION
IF YOU COULD SORT OF COMMENT ON
THE SOME OF THOSE BIGGER PICTURE
ISSUES. YEAH. THANK YOU. SENATOR
BECKER. I THINK JUST TO KIND OF
REITERATE, ONE OF THE POINTS
AROUND THE FUEL ASSESSMENT, THE
OPPORTUNITY THERE WAS TO REALLY
THINK THROUGH AS A WHOLE STATE,
INCLUDING STAKEHOLDERS,
INDUSTRY, BUT ALSO CARB AND
OTHER AGENCIES TAKING THEIR
INPUT INTO WHAT THE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS COULD BE TO NAVIGATE.
AND I HAVE TO THANK CARB BECAUSE
MUCH OF THE IDEAS AND OPTIONS
AROUND DEMAND SIDE REDUCTION
ACTUALLY CAME FROM THE SCOPING
PLAN AND CARB'S INSISTENCE TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE OVERALL
ASSESSMENT. THE NEXT STEP OF THE
PROCESS FOR SB ONE TWO IS
DEVELOPING THE TRANSITION
PLANNING PROCESS. SO WITHIN THE
TRANSITION PLANNING PROCESS, WE
ARE REQUIRED TO WORK ON CARBON
SEES. WE ARE REQUIRED TO WORK
TOGETHER TO THINK THROUGH
OPERATIONALIZING AND FURTHER
STUDYING. MOST OF THOSE OPTIONS.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE ARE
UNDERTAKING RIGHT NOW. AND WE
ARE HOPING TO PUT THAT ANALYSIS
OUT SOON. AND I THINK THAT'S A
COMMITMENT TO FURTHER SOME OF
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES THAT YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT. YEAH. AND
CERTAINLY EQUITY IN THAT PROCESS
IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL COMMENT
AS WELL. I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS, SENATOR, ON THE BIGGER
PICTURE, I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. I THINK THE
BIGGER PICTURE THAT SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON AND THAT WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION IS TO KEEP
THE REMAINING REFINERIES. YOU
HAVE, I THINK, WHAT THE AND
KUDOS TO THE CTC, CTC ON THE
TRANSPORTATION FUEL ASSESSMENT.
I, I GAVE THE COMPLIMENTS IN THE
LAST HEARING, BUT THEY DID A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF LOOKING AT
THE MARKET SUPPLY AND DEMAND. I
THINK WE'RE ON THE RAZOR'S EDGE
AS THINGS HAVE BEEN NOTED, AND I
THINK THE BIGGER PICTURE LOSING
ANOTHER REFINERY, WE COULD SEE
CLIFFS WITH HARD LANDINGS AS
OPPOSED TO THE SMOOTH
TRANSITION. I THINK THAT THE
STATE WANTS TO SEE, AND THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AREN'T, I DON'T
THINK ARE GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL
WITHOUT INDUSTRY AT THE TABLE.
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS LABOR
AT THE TABLE, HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT OUR FUTURE
IN THIS STATE. AND I THINK WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE AND WE TALK
ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME, THE
POLICIES THAT ARE MAKING
CALIFORNIA UNIQUE FROM THE REST
OF THE UNITED STATES. AND IT'S
THAT UNIQUE. CONTINUED. YOU KNOW,
ADVANCEMENT OF A BILL TO DO X,
Y, OR Z THAT IS MAKING REFINERS,
OIL COMPANIES QUESTION WHETHER
THE STATE REALLY WANTS US HERE
DURING THAT TRANSITION. AND I
THINK I WOULD JUST HEED THAT
CAUTION AS AS WE THINK ABOUT THE
BIG PICTURE, BECAUSE WE DO SEE
OURSELVES HAVING A ROLE IN THE
LOW CARBON ENERGY FUTURE. WE DO
SEE OURSELVES AS PART OF THAT
TRANSITION. YOU YOU'VE SEEN TWO
OF OUR REFINERIES CONVERT TO
RENEWABLE DIESEL. 60% OF OUR
DIESEL MARKET IS NOW PRODUCED BY
RENEWABLE DIESEL. I THINK THAT'S
AN AMAZING ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR OF
THE PROGRAMS, AND WE WANT TO BE
HERE TO BE PART OF THAT. YEAH.
JUST TO WRAP UP, I THINK THAT
YEAH, THAT IS AN AMAZING
ACCOMPLISHMENT. AND WE HAVE TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE TRANSITION PLAN,
OBVIOUSLY, SPIKE, YOU KNOW,
PRICE SPIKES FOR INDIVIDUALS.
BUT ALSO WE DON'T WANT TO
INCREASE OUR IMPORTING OF YOU
KNOW, OIL FROM OTHER PLACES. YOU
KNOW, THAT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE WE
KNOW HAVE MANY ISSUES IN THE
EXPLOITATION. SO ANYWAY, I
APPRECIATE ALL THAT TODAY. THANK
YOU. BEFORE WE GO BACK TO OTHER
MEMBERS, I'M GOING TO AFFORD THE
UNITED STEELWORKERS OPPORTUNITY
TO STATE THEIR TWEENER POSITION.
IS THAT CORRECT? YES, THAT IS
CORRECT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. SO IT
ALL BOILS DOWN TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY, WHICH HAS BEEN MENTIONED.
AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO HEAR
THAT WE'RE VERY PLEASED ON THE
MOVEMENT THAT WAS MADE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT
CAME OUT OF THAT. BUT TO GET
BACK TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PIECE, THERE'S THREE PIECES TO
THAT. THERE IS SAFETY, THE
COMMUNITY SAFETY OF THE WORKERS,
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
REFINERY, WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WITH TURNAROUNDS.
IT'S THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THE EQUIPMENT. IT'S THAT'S THE
PIECE THAT WHEN IT GOES WRONG,
MAKES THE HEADLINES, THAT SHUTS
DOWN THE 405 FREEWAY THAT CAUSES
GAS SPIKES, AS IT DID WHEN THE
CHEVRON RICHMOND INCIDENT
HAPPENED IN 2012. SAME THING
THAT HAPPENED WHEN, PARDON ME,
WHEN EXXONMOBIL HAD THEIR
INCIDENT IN 2015. ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE BEING DISCUSSED
ARE BEING DISCUSSED ON
ASSUMPTIONS THAT THE REFINERY IS
UP AND RUNNING, AND THAT'S NOT
ALWAYS THE CASE. SO A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE TO THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE WORKER IS STOP
WORK AUTHORITY. WE STRUGGLED A
VERY, VERY LONG TIME TO GET THAT
AS AS A SAFETY PROVISION THAT WE
HAD IN THE REGULATIONS THAT IF
SOMETHING'S WRONG, WE CAN STOP
IT. AND WE MOVE FORWARD. THERE'S
NO SECOND GUESSING. YOU KNOW, WE
FIX WHAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED WITH
THAT. IF THE EMPLOYEE HAS DONE
THE RIGHT THING AND HAS SPOKEN
UP, AND IF THE COMPANY HAS DONE
THE RIGHT THING AND STOPPED IT,
THAT SHOULDN'T TRIGGER THE
COMPANY BEING FINED FOR NOT
NECESSARILY HAVING THE EXCESS
CAPACITY STORED. WE'VE DONE THE
RIGHT THING. THE COMPANY HAS
MADE THE RIGHT MOVES, AND AT THE
END OF THAT, THERE SHOULDN'T BE
A FEE, THERE SHOULDN'T BE A
PENALTY BECAUSE THEY DID THAT.
SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S OF
CONCERN. WE'RE HAPPY THAT
THERE'S BEING CONSIDERED THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LABOR
PERSON ON THE BOARD. THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. THOSE WERE THE BASICS.
AGAIN, PLEASED WITH THE MOVES
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE. WE'RE STILL
WAITING TO SEE THAT THAT VERY
KEY PIECE, AS FAR AS THE STOP
WORK AUTHORITY GETS ADDRESSED.
AND ONE OTHER ITEM I WOULD
MENTION AS FAR AS SAFETY
REGULATIONS GO, IS THAT THEY
CHANGE, THAT THEY CHANGE. IN
2017, WE GOT UPDATED REFINERY
SAFETY REGULATIONS. THIS TIME
LAST MONTH. THOSE REGULATIONS
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR SEVEN
YEARS NOW. A MONTH LATER, THOSE
REGULATIONS HAVE CHANGED BECAUSE
THERE WAS A LAWSUIT THAT UNDID A
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF THOSE
REGULATIONS. SO THAT'S SOMETHING
ELSE THAT NEEDS TO BE KEPT IN
MIND AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THAT
WHAT WE THINK AND HOPE IS THE
SITUATION AS FAR AS SAFETY
REGULATIONS GO IS THE SAME
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR
THE CHANCE TO SPEAK. THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL ARCH SENATOR
ASHBY? YES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, CHAIR BRADFORD I CAN I'LL
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF BECAUSE I
CAN ALIGN MYSELF WITH A FEW
PEOPLE WHO'VE ALREADY SPOKEN
BEFORE ME. BUT I WANT TO START
WITH THE REALLY CLEAR POSITIVE
IN THIS SPACE, WHICH IS EVERYONE
UNIVERSALLY AGREES. WE WANT TO
PROVIDE RELIEF TO CALIFORNIANS.
I THINK WE'RE JUST TALKING
AROUND WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO DO
THAT, AND HOW DO WE KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE WHILE WE'RE DOING THAT? AND
HOW DO WE MANAGE THE STORAGE
COMPONENT AND WHO'S IN CHARGE,
AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE PEOPLE
HAVE A VOICE IN THIS PROCESS? SO
FOR ME, IF I STEP BACK AND I'M
THINKING OF MYSELF AS A YOU
KNOW, A CALIFORNIAN, I'M
GRATEFUL. I'M GRATEFUL THAT THE
SENATORS ARE HERE. I'M GRATEFUL
THAT ALL OF THE EXPERTS ARE
HERE. GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HART AND THE MAJORITY
LEADER FROM THE ASSEMBLY FOR
HAVING THE CONVERSATION. BECAUSE
WE CERTAINLY ALL AGREE THAT
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE
AROUND THE PRICING. I THINK THAT
SEEMS TO BE UNIVERSALLY
ACCEPTED. AND SO I APPRECIATE
THAT WE'RE ALL WORKING FROM THAT
COMMON SPACE. AND THEN FOR ME,
THIS REALLY BREAKS DOWN INTO
THREE ISSUES. THEN THE STORAGE
COMPONENT, THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
COMPONENT. AND THEN THE RELIEF
FOR CONSUMER COMPONENT. FOR ME,
THOSE ARE THE THREE SORT OF TOP
LINES ON THE STORAGE ISSUE. I
GUESS I HAVE MORE OF A QUESTION
FOR YOU ALL. AND THAT IS I THINK
IT'S A I THINK IT'S A FAIR
QUESTION TO ASK ABOUT STORAGE,
ALTHOUGH I WOULD ARGUE, YOU
KNOW, BE CAREFUL THE QUESTION
YOU ASK, BECAUSE I THINK THE
LANGUAGE BENEFITS YOU. NOW. IT
SAYS THEY CAN'T FORCE YOU TO
BUILD SOMETHING NEW. AND SO
THEREFORE YOU WOULD LOGICALLY
BELIEVE THAT THE REQUIREMENT IS
GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT CAN
BE ACHIEVED WITHIN THAT
FRAMEWORK, WHICH I THINK WOULD
WOULD BENEFIT YOU IF, YOU KNOW,
WHEN I'M LOOKING AT IT. BUT I DO
THINK IT'S A FAIR QUESTION. SO I
WANTED TO PRESENT IT BACK TO
YOU. WHAT IS THE STRATEGY MOVING
FORWARD TO BE REASONABLE IN THE
EXPECTATION AROUND STORAGE,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT REFINERIES THAT HAVE
LEFT DOWN TO THE NUMBER THAT WE
HAVE AND OTHER STATES BEING
SOMEWHAT RELIANT ON US AND US
EXTENDING THE COMMENTS THAT WE
HAVE TO THEM TO SAY, WE'RE
TAKING YOU IN MIND TOO. CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT, PLEASE? YEAH.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ASHBY. I
THINK YOU'VE KIND OF LAID OUT
SOME OF THE CONTEXT REALLY WELL.
AND JUST KIND OF LOOKING AT, YOU
KNOW, HOW CEC WOULD GO ABOUT
THIS. I THINK THE THREE
THRESHOLD QUESTIONS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY CONTENDED WITH AND NOW
THE SENATE IS CONTENDING WITH IS
ONE. AND I THINK YOU LAID IT OUT
REALLY WELL, WHICH IS WE ALL
COMMONLY AGREE THAT DURING THE
PRICE SPIKES, THE CONSUMERS PAY.
AND WE WANT TO MITIGATE THAT. IF
POSSIBLE. I THINK THAT'S THE
THRESHOLD QUESTION. WE ALL AGREE
ON THE SECOND THRESHOLD QUESTION
IS, IS THE POINT THAT YOU'RE
MAKING RIGHT NOW, WHICH IS THERE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT THROUGH
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSAL IN FRONT
OF YOU, WHICH I WILL EXPAND ON
JUST IN A MINUTE. AND THEN THE
THIRD THRESHOLD IS IF YOU WERE
TO DELEGATE AUTHORITY TO A STATE
AGENCY TO WORK ON THAT ISSUE,
WHAT GUARDRAILS WOULD YOU PUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO IT RIGHT?
SO I THINK THE THIRD QUESTION
AND THE FIRST QUESTION HAS BEEN
A LOT OF DEBATE, BUT I THINK
THEY ARE COMING, COMING
TOGETHER. THE SECOND ONE JUST ON
STORAGE, I JUST WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR THAT BASED ON THE DATA
THAT SB ONE TWO REQUIRES TO BE
SUBMITTED TO CEC, WHICH NOT NONE
OF THE REFINERIES HAVE, THAT
BECAUSE THEY ALL ONLY HAVE IT
FOR THEIR OWN REFINERY, BUT NOT
IN TOTALITY OR THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE ABSOLUTE
FAITH THAT THAT THE NUMBERS THAT
WE SEE PROVIDES INSIGHT, THAT
THERE IS A THRESHOLD LEVEL
EFFICIENCY WE CAN GAIN HERE
WITHIN THAT EXISTING WITHIN THE
EXISTING THING. SO AGAIN, YOU
KNOW, TO JUST KIND OF TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CRYSTAL LAKE VERY
CLEARLY SPEAK WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE MARKET AS A WHOLE, WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE MARKET, WHAT
WE'VE OBSERVED OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS IS WHEN THE LIQUIDITY IN
THE MARKET GOES DOWN, WHAT
HAPPENS IS THE REFINERIES ARE
TRYING TO SCRAMBLE TO FIGURE
OUT, HOW DO I HONOR MY
COMMITMENTS WHEN THEY TRY TO
HONOR THEIR COMMITMENTS? THEY'RE
GOING TO THE SPOT MARKET TO BUY
IT. SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS BY
ADVANCE PLANNING, COULD WE COULD
WE REDUCE THAT IN A REACTIVE
BEHAVIOR IN THE SPOT MARKET. SO
THEN KIND OF WALKING BACKWARDS,
HOW DO YOU REDUCE THAT REACTIVE
BEHAVIOR IS BY PLANNING A LITTLE
BIT MORE. AND THEN THE QUESTION
BECOMES WHAT METRIC COULD WE
USE. INDUSTRY USES DIFFERENT
METRICS FOR EXAMPLE, INDUSTRY
LOOKS AT THE PADD FIVE INVENTORY
AND A NUMBER OF COLLEAGUES THAT
WE TALKED TO. AND I KEEP
REFERENCING THEM AS COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD EXCELLENT
CONVERSATIONS WITH INDEPENDENT
REFINERIES OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL, YOU KNOW, SEVERAL
MONTHS. I PERSONALLY HAVE
VISITED ALL THE REFINERIES WE
MEET WITH THEM ONCE, IF NOT
MULTIPLE TIMES A WEEK, EITHER
DIRECTLY, OUR OFFICE OR OTHER
STAFF, BUT BASICALLY WHAT WE
LOOK AT TODAY IS IF YOU ARE
LOOKING AT PADD FIVE AS THE
INVENTORY AND SAY, YOU KNOW, 30
MILLION GALLONS ON PADD FIVE,
WE'RE GOOD SO WE CAN QUICKLY GET
IT FROM WASHINGTON IF NEEDED.
BUT AS THE INVENTORIES GO DOWN,
EVERYBODY SCRAMBLES. SO THE
METRIC THAT CEC HAS WORKED WITH
INDUSTRY CONSULTANTS ON IS
CALLED THE DAYS OF SUPPLY. ALL
WE ARE TRYING TO SAY IS WHEN WE
LOOK TO TWO WEEKS AHEAD, LOOK AT
THE INVENTORIES WE HAVE, LOOK AT
THE INFORMATION THAT THAT WE
HAVE ON PLANNED AND UNPLANNED
OUTAGES, AND LOOK AT ALL THE
SHIPS THAT ARE COMING TO
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TOTALITY, ARE WE LOOKING PRETTY
LIQUID OR NOT? RIGHT. SO THAT'S
THE THAT'S THE QUESTION. AND SO
THAT 15 DAYS SO THAT YOU WOULD
FIND OUT TWO WEEKS IN ADVANCE
THAT SOMETHING WAS COMING. NOT
NECESSARILY THAT YOU ARE
PLANNING FOR THOSE FULL TWO
WEEKS, BUT THAT YOU WOULD KNOW
OR WE WOULD KNOW WITH SOME
NOTICE. OKAY. WE WOULD KNOW IF
IT'S A PLANNED OUTAGE. WE WOULD
KNOW 120 DAYS AHEAD BASED ON THE
STATUTE. RIGHT. SO WE HAVE THAT.
SO ALL WE ARE THEN SAYING IS IF
WE LOOK AT THE ENTIRETY OF DATA
AND IF 15 DAYS SEEMS LIKE A
REASONABLE NUMBER TO AIM
TOWARDS, HOW DO WE PLAN TO GET
AS CLOSE AS POSSIBLE TO THAT?
AND THEN THE QUESTION COMES WHAT
WHAT AMOUNT OF STORAGE CAPACITY
DO WE HAVE? AS I MENTIONED IN MY
TESTIMONY TODAY, BASED ON THE
INFORMATION WE HAVE, THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF STORAGE CAPACITY JUST
IN CALIFORNIA IS 24 DAYS WORTH
OF IT. OKAY. AND SO THE IDEA IS
IF THE MINIMUM THAT WE HAVE SEEN
IN 2022 IS ABOUT 12.5 DAYS,
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF DAYS WORTH OF INCREMENTAL
ROOM THAT WE WANT TO GAIN IN THE
SYSTEM. SO THAT'S WHAT WE WILL
BE LOOKING AT IN THE IN THE
RULEMAKING PROCESS. OKAY. FAIR
ENOUGH. I APPRECIATE THE
EXPLANATION BECAUSE I THINK
STORAGE IS KEY TO HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS. THE SECOND
ISSUE FOR ME IS HEALTH AND
SAFETY. AND I, I DON'T THINK I
NEED TO GO INTO THIS REALLY
DEEPLY BECAUSE OUR, OUR MAJORITY
LEADER, SENATOR GONZALES, LAID
OUT WHAT SORT OF IN THE BILL,
THE REQUIREMENTS. I JUST WANT TO
SAY IT OUT LOUD, BECAUSE
JEREMY'S EXISTENCE HERE, THE
BOILERMAKERS EXISTENCE HERE,
MAKES A FEW OF US NERVOUS. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE SAFE.
THAT'S A REALLY BIG PART OF WHAT
WE DO HERE. AND SO I JUST IN
CASE YOU NEED TO HEAR IT FROM
ONE MORE PERSON ON THIS SIDE OF
THE DAIS, AS YOU IMPLEMENT THIS,
YOU GOT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
SAFE. YOU GOT TO PUT THOSE CODES
IN PLACE. YOU GOT TO UPHOLD ALL
THE PIECES THAT HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN IN HERE. AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR OUR CHAIRPERSON,
SENATOR BRADFORD, WHO DOUBLED
DOWN ON SOME OF THAT AND, AND
CIRCLED BACK AROUND TO MAKE SURE
IN THE LAST WEEK OR SO THAT I'VE
SORT OF HEARD CONVERSATIONS.
THIS HAS BEEN A TOP TIER ISSUE
FOR SENATORS AT LEAST WANTING TO
KNOW THAT WE'RE DOING ALL THAT
WE CAN ON THIS FRONT END TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHATEVER DECISIONS GET
MADE ON THE BACK END, THAT WE
TAKE CARE OF OUR PEOPLE. OKAY.
SURE. YEAH. YOU WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING, CHAIRMAN? I JUST WANT
TO, THROUGH THE CHAIR TO ADD
PERSPECTIVE TO WHAT YOU JUST
SAID AND THAT SENATOR GONZALEZ
LAID OUT EARLIER. ALL THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY, LABOR LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL. THAT'S ALL GOING TO BE
ENFORCED BY CAL OSHA. CAL OSHA
WAS REINSTATED 40 YEARS AGO OR
SO BY THE VOTERS THEY ARE
CURRENTLY OPERATING WELL BELOW
OPTIMAL STAFFING LEVELS. AND
THIS IS A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
CONVERSATION TO HAVE IN THE
SPRING. BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT ALL THE STUFF IN
THE BILL THAT WAS ADDED, IT'S AN
UNDERSTAFFED CAL OSHA. IT'S AN
UNDERSTAFFED PROCESS SAFETY
MANAGEMENT DEPARTMENT AT CAL
OSHA THAT HANDLES THE
REFINERIES. AND THESE AND THESE
TYPES OF FACILITIES. SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY HAS
THAT PERSPECTIVE. THEY DO GREAT
WORK THERE. I KNOW A LOT OF THEM
THERE, BUT THEY'RE DOING
YEOMAN'S WORK MORE WITH LESS,
AND THEY NEED TO BE DOING MORE
WITH MORE. YEAH, THAT'S A REALLY
FAIR STATEMENT. AND IT KIND OF
GOES BACK TO SENATOR STERNS
COMMENTS ABOUT BEING ABLE TO DO
MORE THAN ONE PRIORITY AT A
TIME. SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
WE'LL WE KNOW YOU WILL KEEP US
HONEST ON IT. WE EXPECT YOU TO
KEEP US HONEST ON IT, TOO, AND
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S HAPPENING.
AT LEAST THAT'S THIS SENATOR'S
PERSPECTIVE. AND THEN LAST FOR
ME, IS JUST THE RELIEF TO
CONSUMERS. YOU KNOW, THE SENATE,
YOU KNOW, WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS HAD LEGS BEFORE WE
CAME BACK TO TALK ABOUT IT. AND
NOW VERY CLEARLY DOES. AND IT'S
BEEN VERY CLEARLY LAID OUT. BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY, FOR ALL
OF US, I THINK THIS IS ABOUT THE
CONSUMERS. AND I APPRECIATE
BEING A PART OF A BODY, BOTH THE
SENATE AND THE LEGISLATURE AS A
WHOLE AND STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP THAT WOULD REACH IN
AND DO THESE HAVE THESE TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS THE SAME WEEK
THAT, YOU KNOW, LOTS OF OTHER
THINGS ARE HAPPENING IN OUR
WORLDS, BUT IT'S THAT IMPORTANT
TO US. SO IF THERE'S A TAKEAWAY
HERE FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
OUT THERE JUST TRYING TO GET TO
SCHOOL AND WORK AND GET TO PICK
UP THEIR KIDS ON TIME AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PAY THE BILLS, IT'S
THIS WE'RE HERE. WE'RE GRAPPLING
THROUGH THESE TOUGH ISSUES
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING VERY HARD
TO GET TO SOLUTIONS THAT MAKE
GAS LESS EXPENSIVE FOR PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AT
LEAST I KNOW. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
ALL HERE. AND I KNOW WE PROBABLY
CAN'T ALL AGREE TODAY ON EXACTLY
HOW TO DO THAT. BUT I JUST WANT
YOU TO KNOW, I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH BEING A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION TO TRY TO GIVE IT
AN EFFORT, NOT GIVE UP AND KEEP
TRYING. SO AND I APPRECIATE ALL
OF YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENTS TO
AND THROUGH THE CHAIR. MAY I
RESPOND? I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS, SENATOR. I THINK YOUR
FIRST COMMENT WAS ON EXISTING
CAPACITY, AND I THINK A QUESTION
I THINK SHOULD BE RAISED. AND I
THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
SHOULD BE CLARIFIED, IS IN THE
BILL. IT SAYS A PROCESS FOR
MAXIMIZING THE USE OF EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO IT DOESN'T
EXPLICITLY PROHIBIT THE BUILDING
OF NEW. BUT I THINK THAT NEEDS
TO BE CLARIFIED. SO IS THERE
ROOM TO BUILD NEW STORAGE GOING
FORWARD IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
MAXIMIZE THE USE OF EXISTING
STORAGE? IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
CLEAR ON JUST ON THAT PIECE.
YEAH. WELL, IT IS WRITTEN INTO
THE BEGINNING PORTION OF THE
BILL WHERE IT SAYS THE BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION FROM APPLYING A
MINIMUM INVENTORY REQUIREMENT TO
A REFINER IN A MANNER THAT WOULD
BE MET ONLY BY THE CONSTRUCTION
OF ADDITIONAL STORAGE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AS DETERMINED BY
THE ORGANIZATION. SO IT'S
PRETTY, AND I THINK THE POINT IS
ONLY SO YOU HAVE EXISTING, BUT
DO YOU NEED NEW. RIGHT. AND SO
AND I THINK HE HE'S TRYING TO
LAY OUT OTHER MECHANISMS TOO,
LIKE HOW YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO
INCLUDE INVENTORY THAT'S ON ITS
WAY OVER. SO I'M CONFIDENT YOU
GUYS CAN WORK YOUR WAY THROUGH
THAT. BUT I, I AGREE THAT THE
STORAGE ISSUE IS A PIECE THAT
WILL NEED TO BE LAID OUT A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER. THANK YOU
FOR THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
THEN ON YOUR SECOND POINT,
SENATOR, OF RELIEF FOR
CALIFORNIANS, I THINK JUST FOR
CONTEXTUAL SAKE, THE
TRANSPORTATION FUEL ASSESSMENT
DID A GOOD JOB KIND OF WRESTLING
WITH THIS ISSUE OF DO WE WANT
LOW GAS PRICES OR HIGH GAS
PRICES? AND I THINK THE
CONCLUSION WAS, NO, WE DON'T
WANT LOW GAS PRICES, BECAUSE
THAT WILL RESULT IN MORE DRIVING
AND MORE POLLUTION. AND, YOU
KNOW, THE POLICIES OF THE STATE
ARE SENDING CARBON PRICING
SIGNALS. WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
REGULATIONS THAT ARE GOING TO
AFFECT IN 2025 THAT ARE GOING TO
IMPACT CONSUMER COSTS. AND I
THINK THAT JUST NEEDS TO BE A
REALITY FOR RELIEF TO CONSUMERS
IS AS WE TRANSITION FROM A
FOSSIL BASED GASOLINE TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES, THERE IS GOING TO
BE THIS GROWING CARBON MARKET
THAT IS PUTTING MORE COSTS ON
CONSUMER GOODS. SO I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE THAT CLEAR. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT RELIEF FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU. SENATOR LAMONT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR THE
INFORMATION. THE ROBUST DIALOG,
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT'S COME UP
PRETTY CONSISTENTLY IN THIS
CONVERSATION, BOTH IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND HERE, HAS TO DO
WITH CAPACITY FOR STORAGE.
COMMISSIONER, YOU SAID THAT YOU
HAVE INFORMATION THROUGH
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION. YOU KNOW,
SENATOR SKINNER'S LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR THAT GIVES YOU FULL
CONFIDENCE THAT THERE IS
EXISTING CAPACITY FOR STORAGE
WITHIN EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND REFINERIES. AND I WANT TO
NOTE THAT BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THAT'S BOTH REALLY IMPORTANT. WE
HAVE GIVEN THE ENERGY COMMISSION
THAT AUTHORITY TO HAVE THAT, YOU
KNOW, INFORMATION. NO OTHER
REFINERY HAS IT. CERTAINLY, YOU
KNOW, NO AGENCY. BUT YOURSELF
HAVE IT. AND THAT WAS DONE BY
DESIGN TO PROTECT THE MARKET.
THE CHALLENGE IS YOU'RE THE ONLY
ONE THAT HAS IT. SO WE'RE TRYING
TO FIND THAT SAME LEVEL OF TRUST
IN TRYING TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THE CAPACITY EXISTS. SO
MY QUESTION IS HOW DOES THAT GET
RESOLVED? HOW DOES THE DISPUTE
GET RESOLVED? IF THERE REALLY
ARE DIFFERENT PERCEPTIONS,
RIGHT. LIKE WHAT I'M HEARING
RIGHT NOW ARE ENTITIES SAYING WE
DO NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR TEN
TO 14 OR 15 DAYS OF STORAGE. AND
THERE ARE FOLKS WHO, YOU KNOW
YOURSELF, HAVE INFORMATION THAT
WE JUST DON'T HAVE, AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE, AND THAT'S ON
PURPOSE, AND I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
BUT HELP ME UNDERSTAND HOW A
DISPUTE IS RESOLVED. YEAH. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, I THINK I WANT TO
JUST OBSERVE A COUPLE OF PIECES
IN YOUR QUESTION. AND I'M SURE,
LIKE IN A DIFFERENT INDUSTRY,
YOU KNOW, GROUPS ARE KIND OF
MEETING, MEETING WITH YOU TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION. I
THINK THE QUESTION AGAIN, I
WOULD ASK IS, OR AT LEAST I
WOULD SET UP IS DO EVERY
REFINERY UNDER THEIR CURRENT
OPERATIONAL STRUCTURE HAVE ROOM?
AND I WILL SAY RIGHT NOW, THE
ANSWER IS NO. SOME YOU KNOW, A
VERY SMALL REFINERY OR A
PARTICULAR REFINERY THAT'S
OPERATIONALLY MAXIMIZING THEIR
STORAGE MIGHT NOT HAVE ROOM FOR
IT, BUT OVERALL, WHEN WE LOOK AT
INDEPENDENT REFINERY INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE, WE SEE THAT, WE
SEE THAT INFORMATION. SO AS A
RULEMAKING PROCESS, WHAT WE WILL
HAVE IS THE ABILITY TO UNDER,
YOU KNOW, WE'LL WE CAN BREAK
LAW. WE CAN LIE TO EACH OTHER.
AND SO WE'LL HAVE DPMO AS AN
OVERSIGHT ENTITY AS WELL. WE
WILL BE REQUIRING THAT
INFORMATION TO BE LIKE THE
BURDEN OF PROOF WILL BE ON THE
REFINERY TO SHOW US THAT THEY DO
NOT HAVE OPERATIONAL ROOM. SO I
MEAN, TO NOT GET TOO TECHNICAL
ON THIS, BUT IF YOU IF YOU WOULD
PERMIT WHAT THE REFINERIES DO IN
TERMS OF OPERATIONAL KIND OF
EFFICIENCY EVERY DAY IS I MEAN,
WE'VE HEARD THIS AT THE ASSEMBLY
HEARING A LOT, WHICH IS CALLED
THE LINEAR PROGRAMING MODEL THAT
THEY DO. SO WHAT THEY DO IS
BASICALLY LOOKING AT EVERY TANK
CAPACITY THEY HAVE AVAILABLE,
AND THEN THEY OPTIMIZE HOW TO DO
THEIR OPERATIONS, WITH THE
OBJECTIVE FUNCTION BEING
MAXIMIZING THE REVENUE. AGAIN, I
WOULD NOT SAY MAXIMIZING REVENUE
IS A BAD THING, BUT THEY DO THAT
AND THEN AS IN ANY OPTIMIZATION
PROBLEM, YOU'RE YOU'RE
MAXIMIZING AND THINKING THROUGH
THE CONSTRAINTS IN THIS CASE,
WHAT WE WOULD ASK, YOU KNOW, OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM THE INDUSTRY IS
COULD YOU RUN A COUPLE OF
SCENARIOS FOR US. AND WE WILL WE
WILL PARTNER WITH THEM BECAUSE
THIS IS BEST DONE BY THEM TO
PROVIDE US A COUPLE OF SCENARIOS
ON, YOU KNOW, IF YOU WERE TO
MAINTAIN, YOU KNOW, A LITTLE BIT
MORE HERE OR ACCOUNT FOR A
CONTINGENCY, WHAT WOULD THAT
LOOK LIKE? AND THAT'S THE KIND
OF INFORMATION WE WILL BE
WORKING WITH THEM. AND, YOU
KNOW, HOPEFULLY WITH THE
OVERSIGHT AND OTHER, YOU KNOW,
YOU WILL HAVE OVERSIGHT AS WELL.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO RESOLVE THOSE
ISSUES. AND IF I COULD ADD ONE
POINT AS THE VICE CHAIR TALKING
ABOUT CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION,
THAT'S REFINERY BY REFINERY, BUT
YOU CAN AGGREGATE THAT DATA AND
REPORT IT OUT. AND SO THE DATA
POINTS THAT I SHARED ON JUNE
2022, APRIL 2023, FEBRUARY 2024
CC HAS SOMETHING CALLED THE
WEEKLY FUELS WATCH. THEY PUT ALL
THOSE NUMBERS TOGETHER ABOUT
BOTH FINISHED GASOLINE AND
BLENDING STOCKS, AND THAT'S
PUBLISHED WEEKLY. SO WHAT I WAS
JUST REFERENCING IS SOMETHING
THAT EACH SENATOR AND OR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CAN LOOK TO SEE
WHAT THOSE NUMBERS WERE
HISTORICALLY. AND SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO GO INTO THE SENSITIVE
PARTS TO HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
THESE NUMBERS ARE ACCURATE.
GREAT. THANK YOU. THE OTHER
PIECE AND I REALLY APPRECIATED,
YOU KNOW, THE, THE, THE
STEELWORKERS SAYING THAT SAFETY
IS THREE THINGS. IT'S WORKERS
COMMUNITY AND THE FACILITY AND
YOU HAVE HEARD, I THINK
RESOUNDING IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND FROM COLLEAGUES HERE. YOU
KNOW, HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS. AND
AS I THINK ABOUT THOSE THREE
THINGS, I THINK ABOUT A
SITUATION AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
THIS IS FOR, AND I'M HOPING
SOMEONE CAN JUST WALK ME THROUGH
WHAT THIS WOULD BE. IF THERE IS
AN EMERGENCY. AND I AM SOMEONE
WHO LIVES WITHIN A REFINERY, AND
THAT EMERGENCY NEEDS TO RESOLVE
WHAT CONFIDENCE CAN WE GIVE THE
WORKERS THE COMMUNITY AND THE
FACILITY ITSELF THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO BE OKAY IN THAT MOMENT
BECAUSE THERE ARE EMERGENCIES
THAT DON'T HAVE THAT HAPPEN AT
MIDNIGHT, RIGHT? THEIR OFFICES
AREN'T OPEN, BUT WHAT IS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT LOOK LIKE?
WALK ME THROUGH THAT SO THAT AS
WE'RE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS, IF I'M A MEMBER,
IF I'M A WORKER WHO WORKS THERE,
IF I'M A MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY, WHO LIVES NEARBY, I
HAVE THE CONFIDENCE THAT IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS, THERE ISN'T
GOING TO HAVE TO BE AN APPROVAL
PROCESS THAT WILL DELAY
IMMEDIATE ACTION. HOW DOES THAT
WORK? RIGHT. TWO POINTS, AND I
WOULD WELCOME DIRECTOR MUELLER
TO ALSO MENTION. SO THE FIRST
THING IS ANYTHING ANY BEST
PRACTICE THAT'S IN PLACE. AND
WE'VE HEARD FROM US ON HARD
FOUGHT RULES AND BEST PRACTICES
THAT ARE IMPLEMENTED TODAY.
THOSE WOULD BE TAKEN IN AS GIVEN
AND THOSE WOULD NOT BE
CHALLENGED. SO WE WOULD LOOK TO
LABOR REPRESENTATIVES BOTH ON
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE. BUT, YOU
KNOW, THE WE WOULD ALSO THINK WE
TALKED ABOUT IT IN ASSEMBLY. WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE MANY WORKING
GROUPS WITH LABOR
REPRESENTATIVES TO GET THEIR
INPUT DER, OSHA, THEIR WORD IS
THE START AND THE END. ENERGY
COMMISSION IS ONLY TAKING THAT
AS AN INPUT. AND IF THEIR INPUT
TO US IS UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES, THERE SHOULD BE
AN EXEMPTION. THAT'S WHAT THE
COMMISSION WILL WORK TOWARDS IN
THE RULE MAKING PROCESS. AND I
JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU THAT
CONFIDENCE THAT IT WAS RAISED
BEFORE THAT THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WILL HAVE DELEGATED
AUTHORITY, BUT THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WORKS AND OPERATES
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THE
COMMISSION'S VOTE. AND SO THE
DIRECTION WE WILL GIVE THEM WILL
BE DEPENDENT ON WHATEVER THE
RULEMAKING PROCESS YIELDS. I
ALSO WANTED TO SORT OF STRIKE A
HOPEFUL NOTE HERE. IT MAY BE NOT
READILY APPARENT WITH THE SORT
OF THE TRADE REPRESENTATIVES AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION, BUT THE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THE INDIVIDUAL
REFINERS IS VERY, VERY STRONG.
AND THAT THAT THAT BACK AND
FORTH, THAT COLLABORATION IS
ABSOLUTELY THERE. AND I WANT TO
CREDIT INDUSTRY NOT IN TERMS OF
MAYBE THE ARGUMENTS THEY MAKE IN
THIS SETTING, BUT PRIVATELY AND
OTHERWISE. THEY TAKE THIS
INCREDIBLY SERIOUSLY. AND I
THINK THEIR RECORD HAS IMPROVED
A LOT WITH LABORS PARTICIPATION
AND THE ABILITY FOR LABOR TO
STOP WORK IF SOMETHING IS
DANGEROUS. AND THAT INTERPLAY
THAT HAS DEVELOPED. I JUST WANT
TO SAY ON BEHALF OF DPMO SAID,
THIS BEFORE, IT REALLY IS ABOUT
CONTINUING TO HAVE THAT DECISION
IN THE HANDS OF THE PEOPLE ON
THE GROUND AND HAVING A BUFFER
OF MORE SUPPLY DOESN'T CHANGE
THAT. AND IN FACT, IT MAKES IT
IT EMPOWERS LABOR, IN MY VIEW,
TO BE ABLE TO SAY, NO, THIS IS
UNSAFE. LET'S STOP OPERATIONS.
AND SO THAT CONTINUES TO BE A
DECISION WITH DIR AND WITH THE
SKILLED LABOR WORKFORCE THAT'S
THERE ON THE GROUND. AND CEC
HERE IS FOCUSING ON PROTECTING
CONSUMERS WITH HAVING A BUFFER.
BUT THAT DOESN'T TAKE THE
DECISIONS OUT OF THOSE CRITICAL
HANDS. AND I JUST WANTED TO
RESPOND TO THE GOOD
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE HAPPENING
BETWEEN DPMO CEC AND THE
REFINERS. THOSE SAME PEOPLE
YOU'RE HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
ARE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT I
REPRESENT. AND I'M HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AS WELL.
AND THEY ARE SAYING, HEY, FOR
THIS, WE THINK A RULEMAKING
WOULD BE NOT THIS BILL, BUT IN
GENERAL, 1322 THE DATA THAT'S
BEING REPORTED, WE SAID, HEY,
THERE SHOULD PROBABLY BE A
RULEMAKING TO GET CLARIFICATION
ON ON THESE ISSUES. WE WERE
DENIED THAT RULEMAKING ON THE
FUELS FORECAST. WE WERE JUST
DENIED THIS PAST THURSDAY ON
THAT RULEMAKING. SO I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING. YOU KNOW, BEHIND THE
SCENES BETWEEN DPMO, THE CEC.
BUT WE'VE ASKED FOR THIS
COLLABORATION. WE'VE ASKED FOR
RULEMAKING SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND
WHAT EXACTLY THE CEC WANTS AND
NEEDS. AND WE'VE BEEN DENIED.
AND SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT CLARIFICATION, IF I MAY,
AGAIN, JUST KIND OF PROVIDING
THE FULL CONTEXT OF WHAT HAS
BEEN SHARED. THE FIRST TWO
RULEMAKINGS WERE DENIED BECAUSE
THE RULEMAKING PETITIONS
HAPPENED RIGHT WHEN THE SB ONE
TWO CONVERSATION WAS HAPPENING.
AND IN OUR DENIAL, WE NOTED THAT
SPECIFIC THING THAT WE WOULD
WANT TO WAIT UNTIL WHAT SB ONE
TWO, YOU KNOW, PROVIDES THAT'S
LAST YEAR. BEFORE WE GO ON TO
THAT RULEMAKING AND THE LATEST
RULEMAKING PROCESS THAT, YOU
KNOW, TALKED ABOUT THE DENIAL IS
WE SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE A
WORKSHOP AND A RULEMAKING IN
PROCESS THAT DUPLICATES THAT
WORK AND THAT WAS THE REASON FOR
DENIAL. AND I WOULD LOVE AND ASK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM WISPA TO
PROVIDE THAT FULL CONTEXT. WE'VE
THEN SHARED AND ALSO WANT TO
JUST SHARE LEGALLY. LEGALLY, WE
CANNOT START AN EMERGENCY
RULEMAKING PROCESS WITHOUT PRE
RULEMAKING PROCESS. SO ALL THREE
PETITIONS ASKED US TO DO A
RULEMAKING AND EMERGENCY
RULEMAKING WITHOUT ANY EMERGENCY
RULES PROVIDED TO US. AND WE
SAID AND NOTED IN OUR DECISION
THAT WE CANNOT DO THAT WITHOUT A
PUBLIC PROCESS. SO I JUST WANTED
TO SAY WE WERE OPERATING UNDER
THE CONSTRAINTS OF THE EXISTING
LAW AND THE CONTEXT, AND JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT. AND JUST
FOR CLARITY, THOUGH, THIS THIS
DOESN'T CHANGE THAT PIECE OF IT,
THOUGH, THAT WILL STILL BE THE
LAW. AND YOU WILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A PROCESS BEFORE YOU CAN
GO THROUGH THE EMERGENCY
PROCESS. YES. OKAY. AND YOU
KNOW, ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT'S
UNRESOLVED AS IT RELATES TO
WORKER SAFETY IS THE STOP WORK
AUTHORITY. CAN YOU TELL US HOW
THAT YOU THINK THAT THAT WILL BE
RESOLVED? IS IT THROUGH THE
RULEMAKING PROCESS? IS IT
SOMETHING, YOU KNOW, PRIOR AFTER?
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY RETAINED THE STOP
WORK AUTHORITY THAT IS, IN
EXISTING LAW AND IN FACT, THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE ADDED AT
THE THROUGH THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE SPECIFICALLY AIMED
AT CLARIFYING THAT THE EXISTING
LAW THAT PROTECTS WORKER SAFETY
HAS NOT BEEN CHANGED IN ANY WAY
BY THIS LEGISLATION. SO I THINK
WE THIS HAS BEEN A CONSISTENT
CONCERN BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY
HERE IN THE SENATE, WE'VE HEARD
VERY CLEARLY FROM LABOR
REPRESENTATIVES AND COMMUNITIES
NEAR REFINERIES THAT THIS IS
WORKER SAFETY IS A PARAMOUNT
CONCERN, AND NOTHING IN THIS
LEGISLATION DIMINISHES THAT AT
ALL. GREAT. THANK YOU. WELL, I
APPRECIATE IT. I'VE HAD THE
CHANCE TO TALK FOR, YOU KNOW,
WITH FOLKS OVER THE LAST WEEK
AND DAYS AND EVEN WEEKEND RIGHT,
ABOUT THIS, THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR. AND, YOU KNOW, I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT A LOT OF
THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN
THIS SPACE IS ONLY ONE BILL AT A
TIME, ONE ISSUE AT A TIME. SO
WHAT WE ARE SEEING TODAY IS
REALLY CONSISTENT WITH HOW YOU
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THIS
PARTICULAR SPACE. AND I THINK WE
SHARE GOALS OF WANTING TO ENSURE
THAT THE MARKET WORKS NOT JUST
FOR AN INDUSTRY OR FOR A STATE
AGENCY, BUT ULTIMATELY WORKS FOR
THE CONSUMER. AND I THINK THAT,
YOU KNOW, I'VE SEEN IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS THAT WE'VE TAKEN ON
THIS ISSUE IN A MORE CRITICAL
WAY, AND IT'S BEEN CHALLENGING.
BUT I DO SEE THAT WE'VE MADE A
LEVEL OF PROGRESS IN TERMS OF A
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVEN'T FOR A
VERY LONG TIME, AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT. AND
RECOGNIZING IT ALSO MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T ENGAGED IN THIS TYPE OF
CONVERSATION. SO I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION. I DO
KNOW THAT I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WILL BE REALLY
IMPORTANT IS TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD TRUST, AND THAT IS WE
CAN'T LEGISLATE THAT. CERTAINLY
LEGISLATION HELPS, BUT TO BUILD
TRUST, YOU KNOW, WITH OUR
WORKFORCE, WITH, YOU KNOW, ALL
SIDES AND ALL PARTIES INVOLVED
WITH REALLY STAKEHOLDERS THAT
THIS IS A PROCESS THAT WORKS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT AT THIS MOMENT,
THERE STILL FEELS LIKE THERE'S A
LOT OF, YOU KNOW, A LACK OF
TRUST BECAUSE IT'S NEW AND A LOT
OF THINGS THAT START OFF NEW
FEEL THAT WAY. BUT I DO THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW THIS ISSUE.
AND WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ACTIONS, ANY VOTES WE TAKE
ARE CONSISTENT WITH DOING THE
RIGHT THING FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
BUT UNDERSTANDING THAT IT IS
DIFFICULT, YOU KNOW, I MEAN,
MANY OF YOU KNOW, THE WORK THAT
I DO IN THE LEGISLATURE AND I
HAVE TO SAY THAT I SPENT I MEAN,
YOU SHOULD ALL SEE MY COLLEAGUES
CAN SEE THE NUMBER OF NOTES AND
PIECES OF PAPER AND
CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD, BECAUSE
EVEN FOR THOSE OF US WHO SPEND
TIME THINKING ABOUT THIS ON A
REGULAR BASIS, WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'VE GRASPED IT IN A WAY
THAT IS THE RIGHT DIRECTION. SO
I APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS. I
THINK YOU WANT TO ADD IN
SOMETHING. WELCOME TO ADD IN
SOMETHING. AND I APPRECIATE JUST
EVERYONE'S RESPONSE AND
WILLINGNESS TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. YEAH. AND THANK
YOU, SENATOR LEMON, AND ALWAYS
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOU.
MANY YEARS IN A ROW. I WANTED TO
MAKE RESPOND TO YOUR COMMENT
REGARDING THE KIND OF LAYERING
OF POLICIES, MULTIPLE POLICIES.
THIS BILL ISN'T THE ONLY ONE. I
THINK ONE OF OUR CONCERNS IS THE
CDC IS STILL CONSIDERING AND
IMPOSING A MARGIN CAP AND
PENALTY. THAT WAS A RESULT OF
LAST YEAR'S SPECIAL SESSION BILL,
WHICH WE WARNED WE THINK COULD
HAVE PRODUCTION AND SUPPLY ISSUE
IMPLICATIONS. I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE HAD THAT SAME
CONCERN AND COULD HAVE
IMPLICATIONS ON PRICES AT THE
PUMP, AND SO WANTED TO TAKE THAT
INTO NOTE AS YOU'RE GIVING THIS
NEW AUTHORITY, POTENTIALLY AND
AB X2-1, THAT THERE IS THIS
OTHER MECHANISM THAT I THINK
HASN'T BEEN EVALUATED TOGETHER,
THAT IF THESE TWO PIECES ARE
COMING TOGETHER, THEN THERE MAY
BE BIGGER DISRUPTIONS IN OUR
VIEW. YEAH, JUST JUST A QUICK
RESPONSE. I THINK, SENATOR,
FIRST OF ALL, I JUST WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR CALLING OUT TRUST
BUILDING. I THINK AS A AS AN
ENERGY COMMISSIONER AND I THINK
AS A STATE AGENCY, WE ARE BEST
SITUATED WHEN WE CAN HAVE THE
TRUST OF STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
PUBLIC, AND THAT IS WHETHER WE
DO THAT WELL OR NOT. IN A GIVEN
DAY. THAT'S OUR ABSOLUTE
COMMITMENT. JUST AS YOU WE ARE
IN A TOUGH SITUATION BETWEEN A
LOT OF DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
HAVING A LOT OF DIFFERENT
OPINIONS, AND NO MATTER WHERE WE
LAND ON ANY SPECIFIC DECISION AS
A COMMISSION, WE NEVER MAKE
EVERYBODY HAPPY. HAVING SAID
THAT, WE WOULD NEVER, YOU KNOW,
ANTAGONIZE ANY STAKEHOLDER. OUR
COMMITMENT IS TO WORK WITH THEM,
FIGURE OUT THE BEST PATH FORWARD
AS IT PERTAINS TO THE RULEMAKING
PROCESS. OUR HOPE WOULD BE TO
CREATE THE MOST FLEXIBLE
SOLUTION THAT ALLOWS FOR ALL THE
GUARDRAILS THAT YOU MENTIONED,
WITH THE GOAL AND SINGULAR GOAL
AS A STATE AGENCY TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMERS AT THE PUMP. SO WE'LL
WORK ON THAT CAREFULLY. AND AS
COLLEAGUE FROM VESPA MENTIONED,
YOU KNOW, DEPENDING ON WHO WE
TALK TO STAKEHOLDERS, SOME
STAKEHOLDERS ARE VERY UPSET WITH
US THAT WE HAVEN'T DONE THE
PENALTY YET. BUT THE SAME REASON
IT'S DELAYED IS THE DELIBERATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE NOT TAKING THAT
LOOSELY. WE ARE TRYING TO DO THE
ANALYSIS NECESSARY TO REALLY
ESTABLISH THAT THE BENEFITS
OUTWEIGH THE COSTS, AND WE CAN
MITIGATE THOSE RISKS, AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WOULD DO WITH THIS AS
WELL. GREAT. THANK YOU. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I WILL SAY
THAT ONE OTHER PIECE THAT HAS
BEEN BROUGHT UP THAT IS GOING TO
BE NEEDED FOR TRUST IS TO REALLY
FIGURE OUT HOW TO WORK AND
STRENGTHEN CAL OSHA AND THEIR
ABILITY TO ENFORCE THAT IS NOT
LOST ON ME. IT HAS BEEN PART OF
A CONVERSATION IN MANY SPACES,
AND I IT'S NOT PART OF THIS
BILL, BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT THAT
IS GOING TO BE VERY CRITICAL
PIECE AS WE THINK ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF STRENGTHENING THE LAWS
THAT MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. QUICK QUESTION BY
SENATOR COR. THANK YOU. ON THE
POINT THAT HE HAD POINTED OUT ON
THAT LAST HEARING THAT WE HAD WE
HAD ESTABLISHED THE BENCHMARKS
THAT YOU HAD TO YOU HAD TO FIND
THE FINDINGS THAT YOU NEEDED TO
GET TO BEFORE YOU COULD GO ON TO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THIS
FINE WAS GOING TO BE. I ASKED
YOU DIRECTLY, THE THREE
QUESTIONS, AND I REMEMBER YOU
SAID, YOU KNOW, OH, THOSE ARE
GOOD QUESTIONS. BUT THEY WERE
YOUR QUESTIONS. THEY WERE THEY
WERE IN YOUR REPORT AND YOU DID
NOT ESTABLISH THAT YOU HAD MET
ANY OF THOSE. AND YET HERE WE GO
ON TO TALK ABOUT THE PENALTY.
AND THAT'S MY CONCERN ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE, IS
JUST BECAUSE WE SAY WE MAY DO IT
OR IT HAS THIS PROTECTION
MECHANISM, EVEN IF WE DON'T MAKE
THE BENCHMARKS, IT SEEMS WE GO
ON TO THE PENALTY PART. AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
WITH THIS BILL, TOO, IS WE'RE
SAYING WE HAVE PROTECTION
AGAINST GOING FORWARD OR MAKING
DECISIONS THAT DON'T, YOU KNOW,
THAT ARE THAT MIGHT NOT BE SAFE
IN THE LONG RUN, BUT WE REALLY
DON'T BECAUSE WE KIND OF IGNORE
THOSE AND JUST KEEP GOING ON AND
MARCHING ON INSTEAD OF JUST
CALLING IT A DAY AND SAYING, YOU
KNOW WHAT? WE COULDN'T PROVE
THERE WAS GOUGING. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, WE MOVE ON TO NOW A
PENALTY WHEN WE COULDN'T PROVE
WHAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO PROVE
BEFORE WE EVEN GOT TO THAT
PENALTY. THANK YOU. THAT WAS MY
POINT. VICE CHAIR DALLEY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. GOOD TO BE BACK
HERE WITH YOU. I THOUGHT WE WERE
DONE, BUT APPARENTLY NOT QUICK.
I GOT A QUICK. SO THERE'S. I
THINK NINE REFINERIES I KNOW. IS
THAT THE NUMBER NINE? SOME ARE
BIG, SOME ARE SMALL. THE SMALLER
REFINERIES, DO THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO STORE 15 DAYS WORTH
OF PRODUCT OR ARE THEY ALL THE
SAME OR. NO. A CURRENT WOULD BE
THE SMALLEST. IT WOULD BE UNDER
50 000 BARRELS IN A PROCESSING
CAPACITY, AND THE REST ARE
SLIGHTLY LARGER. WE HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH THE REFINING CAPACITY
FOR EACH ONE OF THEM, BUT BASED
ON CURRENT KIND OF GEOGRAPHICAL
LOCATION, IT WE IT'S UNLIKELY
THAT THEY HAVE A LOT OF
CAPACITY, BUT WE HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH THAT AND ESTABLISH THAT
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND STORAGE
AS WELL. YES. OKAY. AND THEN I
HAD A FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON THE
BLENDS DURING THESE PRICE
CHANGES. WE'VE WE'VE THE
GOVERNOR DID CHANGE THE NUMBER
FOR THE BLEND SO MANY TIMES I
CAN'T EVEN KEEP TRACK. I MEAN,
WHEN THE PRICE GOES UP THEY GO
TO WINTER BLEND OR SUMMER BLEND,
WHICHEVER ONE IS CHEAPER. IS
THAT TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
FOR THESE CHANGES IN THE PRICES
THAT YOU'VE SEEN? BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUE, THAT WE
HAVE SPECIAL BLENDS THAT OTHER
STATES DON'T HAVE. CORRECT.
RIGHT. SO YOU'RE RIGHT, VICE
CHAIR, THE LAST TWO YEARS, BOTH
IN 22 AND 23, I'M RIGHT ABOUT
THIS TIME IN OCTOBER, START OF
OCTOBER AND WE MOVED TOWARDS A
WINTER BLEND WHERE YOU ADD IN A
BUNCH OF BUTANE AND INCREASE THE
OVERALL LIQUIDITY IN THE MARKET.
AND SO THAT HAS BEEN DONE TWICE
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. THE
PRICE SPIKES THAT WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED THROUGH OUR ANALYSIS
DO NOT INCLUDE THOSE THINGS.
THOSE TIMES, WHAT WE LOOK AT IS
THE OVERALL PRICE AT THE PUMP,
AND WE REMOVE THE CONTRIBUTION
OF OUR PARTICULAR TAX AND FEES.
WE REMOVE THAT. WE REMOVE THE
CONTRIBUTION OF CRUDE OIL. AND
WE ESTABLISHED JUST THE REFINERY
AND THE RETAIL MARGINS. SO
THAT'S KIND OF HOW WE TRY TO
ESTABLISH THE PRICE SPIKE AS WE
COMPARE TO THE REST OF THE US.
SO YOU'RE TRYING TO EXCLUDE OUT
ALL THE THINGS THAT THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO DO TO FIGURE OUT IF
THEY'RE ACTUALLY MANIPULATING
THE MARKET IN SOME WAY. YES, WE
ACCOUNT FOR ALL THE VARIABLES
THAT WOULD BE SIMILAR TO US AND
THE REST OF THE US. RIGHT? SO
YOU TAKE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
BLEND. YOU TAKE. YEAH. THEY'RE
CONVERTING OVER. YOU'RE TAKING
THAT WHEN THEY I MEAN, I THOUGHT
IT WAS INTERESTING WHEN WE DID
THE LAST SPECIAL SESSION THAT,
YOU KNOW, TALKING ABOUT PROFITS.
WELL, IT WASN'T ALL CALIFORNIA
PROFITS. IT WAS PROFITS FOR
CRUDE WAS GOING UP AND SOME BIG
PLAYERS AND CRUDE PLAY IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. SO YOU WANT
TO COMPARE APPLES TO APPLES TO
CALIFORNIA. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CALIFORNIA MARKET EXCLUSIVELY,
NOT THE GLOBAL MARKET FOR THESE
COMPANIES. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT. WE TRY TO ISOLATE ALL OF
THAT OKAY. THANK YOU I WANTED TO
GET THOSE THINGS OUT. SO YOU'RE
GOING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO WORK
WITH THOSE SMALLER ONES. SO
BASICALLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT'S THE NUMBER HOW MANY HOW
MANY SMALL ONES DO WE HAVE THAT
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY VERSUS
LARGE ENOUGH ONES THAT HAVE THE
CAPACITY. SO AGAIN NOT TO BE IN
A CIRCULAR ABOUT THIS, WE
HAVEN'T ESTABLISHED THROUGH THE
COMMISSION VOTE WHO HAS AND NOT.
BUT I WOULD I WOULD KIND OF
COMMIT TO SAYING THAT THE SMALL
ONE, ESPECIALLY KERN, WHICH IS
VERY SMALL, I WOULD IMAGINE, I
WOULD IMAGINE IT'S HIGHLY
UNLIKELY THAT HAVE THE ABILITY
TO, TO STORE PRODUCT. AND SO
THAT'S THE ONLY ONE THAT'S
REALLY SMALL THAT'S UNDER
50,000. SO EVERYBODY ELSE IS
GOING TO HAS STORAGE AND HAS THE
ABILITY FOR LARGER THAN 15 DAYS.
SO MOST OF THEM WILL HAVE
STORAGE. WE HAVE TO GO REFINERY
BY REFINERY TO ESTABLISH THEIR
PAST PRACTICES. SOME OF THEM DO
MAXIMIZE THEIR STORAGE BECAUSE
IT FITS THEIR BUSINESS MODEL. SO
WE'LL HAVE TO WORK WITH THEM
REFINERY BY REFINERY. OKAY, SO
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO ASK IS
ABOUT STORAGE AND OTHER OTHER
STATES. SO I DON'T AND I DON'T
KNOW THIS. YOU HAVE TO EDUCATE
ME, BUT I KNOW WE PUMP FUEL TO
RENO, NEVADA FROM OUR REFINERIES
AND WE PUMP IT TO CHICO AND
PLACES WHERE I KNOW OUR COMPANY
GETS FUEL. SO IS THAT IS THAT
COUNT? IS THOSE IS THAT COUNTED
AS REFINERY FUEL OR IS THAT
COUNTED AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS THAT
PIPELINE? SO WE ARE CURRENTLY
NOT CONSIDERING, YOU KNOW,
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
CONVERSATION, THINGS OUTSIDE,
LIKE KINDER MORGAN AND THINGS
WHICH, FOR EXAMPLE, KINDER
MORGAN PIPELINE WOULD BE MORE OF
A BUFFER. THINGS COME IN AND
FLOW OUT. THEY WON'T REALLY HAVE
CAPACITY TO STORE THINGS AS IT
MAY. SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REFINERY GATE. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT COMMERCIAL STORAGE SPACE
THAT THEY COULD USE, BUT WE'RE
SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
NINE REFINERS AND THEIR ABILITY
TO USE EXISTING STORAGE WITHIN
CALIFORNIA TO COMPLY WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS. IF I MAY
RESPOND TO THE CHAIR, I THINK ON
AS IT RELATES TO KINDER MORGAN
AND OTHER PLAYERS IN THE MARKET,
THERE IS OTHER CAPACITY IN THE
SYSTEM THAT IS OUTSIDE OF THE
REFINERY GATE, BUT THEY ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THIS TYPE OF BILL.
AND SO YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE
FULL PICTURE WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT A SYSTEM WIDE DATA TO JUSTIFY
REFINERY SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS.
IT'S A BIT COMPARING APPLES TO
ORANGES. AND I THINK WE JUST
HEARD THAT, NO, NOT EVERY
REFINERY HAS CAPACITY. KERN
DOESN'T. THERE ARE OTHER SMALLER
REFINERIES THAT MIGHT NOT. AND I
THINK THAT'S A BIG UNKNOWN FOR
MOVING A POLICY FORWARD WITH THE
AUTHORITY IN IT, WITH NOT HAVING
THOSE QUESTIONS ANSWERED. IF I
COULD JUST RESPOND AND I THINK,
AGAIN, I WANT TO JUST
RESPECTFULLY OFFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM WHISPER, THIS IS
THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
RULEMAKING PROCESS, RIGHT? I
MEAN, WE HAVE CONFIDENTIAL DATA
TODAY. AS I MENTIONED, WE HAVE A
THRESHOLD LEVEL INFORMATION
THAT'S ALREADY SUBMITTED TO CEC
THAT SHOWS AVAILABLE CAPACITY.
SO THE NEXT QUESTION THAT WE
HAVE TO ASK IN, IN COLLABORATION
AND PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
INDUSTRY IS COULD YOU USE THAT
EXISTING SPACE THAT WE SEE BASED
ON THE INFORMATION THAT YOU
PROVIDED US, THAT YOU HAVE
OPERATIONAL FLEXIBILITY TO
INCREASE STORAGE? THAT'S THE
NEXT QUESTION, AND THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING
THROUGH IN THIS RULEMAKING
PROCESS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS I HAVE.
I JUST HAVE SOME COMMENTS
THOUGH. MR. CHAIR, I'D LIKE TO
MAKE SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
DOGGING THE WHOLE YEAR IS THAT
RATEPAYERS FOR ELECTRICITY ARE
PAYING FOR THE CEC. AND THIS
THIS BILL IS GOING TO UP THAT
PRICE. AND THE RATEPAYERS FOR
ELECTRICITY ARE GOING TO PAY.
SENATOR STERN TOUCHED ON IT A
LITTLE BIT. SOMETHING THAT I'VE
BEEN FRUSTRATED ABOUT IS THAT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT FUNDING HERE,
SOMEBODY THAT DOESN'T OWN A CAR
OR USE GASOLINE IS PAYING FOR
PEOPLE WHO USE GASOLINE, AND
THAT'S WHERE THE RATES GO. SO I
JUST WANT TO BE ON THE RECORD
AGAIN, TO SAY THAT THAT'S WHAT'S
DRIVING SOME, SOME OF THE COST
IS DRIVING UP OUR INTEREST OR
OUR ELECTRICITY RATES. THE OTHER
THING I WANTED TO SAY IS THAT
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER ASKED THE
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR ABOUT THE
ADVISORY. SO YOU TALKED ABOUT
AND THEN ALSO, SENATOR SKINNER
TALKED ABOUT THIS AREA, ABOUT
THE BILL AND ABOUT THE
RULEMAKING AND THE AND THE
REGULATORY PART OF IT. AND SO
ALSO, YOU TALKED ABOUT
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION OR
STUFF, YOU KNOW, SO YOU'RE
ASKING THE LEGISLATORS TO
BASICALLY THIS BILL IS SAYING,
HEY, WE HAVE INFORMATION THAT WE
CAN'T TALK TO YOU ABOUT, RIGHT?
YOU JUST SAID, I CAN'T SAY I
CAN'T SHARE THAT INFORMATION,
AND WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON IT,
AND WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
POWER BACK. NOW, IF YOU GO TO
25, THREE, 5.4 OF THIS BILL AND
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT, YOU'RE
GOING TO DEVELOP THE, THE, THE
REGULATIONS AND DEVELOP IMPOSE
REQUIREMENTS FOR REFINERS AND
OPERATING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MINIMAL LEVELS.
SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY DOING HERE
IS WE'RE GIVING ALL THE POWER,
JUST LIKE WE DID TO THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD,
TO THE CEC, TO COME UP WITH
THESE REGULATIONS ON BUSINESSES.
AND SO FOR ME, I THINK THAT'S A
PROBLEM. AT THE SAME TIME,
ALLOWING THEM TO BE ABLE TO FIND
A $100,000 A DAY AND UP TO $1
MILLION A DAY. SO I DON'T SEE
HOW THAT'S GOING TO HELP DRIVE
DOWN THE COST OF FUEL IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I WAS STRUCK BY
THE FACT THAT, YOU KNOW, WE NEED
IF YOU'RE GOING TO ASK US TO
VOTE FOR A BILL AND YOU CAN'T
SHARE ALL THE INFORMATION WITH
US, I THINK THAT PUTS THE
LEGISLATORS AT A DISADVANTAGE.
AND I THINK THAT WE DESERVE THE
RIGHT TO IF WE'RE GOING TO PASS
A LAW WHICH THIS IS, AND GIVE
YOU THE AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO
REGULATE, BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS DOING. THIS IS GIVING
YOU THE AUTHORITY TO SAY, YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE TO COME BACK
TO THIS BOARD OR THIS
LEGISLATURE, AND YOU'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO REGULATE. I THINK
THAT'S VERY ROCKY, SCARY GROUND
FOR CALIFORNIANS, UNFORTUNATELY,
FORTUNATELY, AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD, WE'VE SEEN THAT
WITH MANY AGENCIES. DTSC WE TRY
TO REIN THOSE GUYS IN AND DO ALL
THESE THINGS. AND I THINK IT'S
NOT GOOD POLICY, QUITE FRANKLY,
TO JUST CARTE BLANCHE, GIVE THIS
TO UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS. SO NO
OFFENSE TO YOU, BUT I'M JUST
GOING TO SAY IT BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S NOT RIGHT. AND I DON'T WANT
TO TALK ABOUT PRICE GOUGING A
LITTLE BIT, BECAUSE I THINK THE
BIGGEST PRICE GOUGING IN THIS
STATE IS THE STATE. WHAT DO I
MEAN BY THAT? ACCORDING TO THE
CEC, YOU SAY THERE'S $1.42 IN
TAXES. THAT'S COLLECTED ON EVERY
GALLON OF GASOLINE THAT'S PAID.
YOU'RE THE BIGGEST PRODUCT OF
WINNING IN CALIFORNIA. YOU MAKE
MORE MONEY THAN ANY OF THESE
COMPANIES THAN ANYBODY THAT
PASSES FUEL ALONG THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYER. OR YOU'RE RECEIVING.
AND I CAN GO DOWN THIS FEDERAL
EXCISE TAX $0.18. THE TAXES ARE
THE BIGGEST ONE THAT'S CAUSING
THE RATE TO GO UP. IT'S $1.42 A
GALLON, ACCORDING TO THE CEC. SO
I THINK IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT $0.15 A
GALLON, WE'RE GOING TO SAVE HERE
AND THERE AND SOME OF THESE
PRICE GOUGING AND ALL THESE
THINGS THAT THE BIGGEST PERSON,
THAT THE BIGGEST PEOPLE, THAT
PRICE GOUGING CALIFORNIA IS THE
TAX SYSTEM. IT'S THINK ABOUT
THAT $0.15 I THINK YOU SAID
ADDED UP TO $2 BILLION. THINK
ABOUT WHAT $1.42 DOES EVERY
SINGLE DAY IN PERPETUITY. IT'S
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE PAYING. AND
GETTING. YOU KNOW, I KNOW, YEAH,
WE GOT A TRAIN SYSTEM THAT'S
GETTING BUILT AND WE GOT ALL
THESE THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING
SUPPOSEDLY SAVING THE CLIMATE.
BUT IN MY MIND, I DON'T THINK
WE'RE DOING A VERY GOOD JOB.
WE'RE BURNING OUR FORESTS DOWN.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT THOSE
THINGS. BUT ANYWAY, AT THE END
OF THE DAY, I JUST WANT TO SAY,
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
GIVING THE POWER TO UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS TO BE ABLE TO FIND
COMPANIES, TO BE ABLE TO PUT THE
REGULATIONS TOGETHER LATER. I
MEAN, HERE WE ARE IN A SPECIAL
SESSION FOR THAT. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, I'LL BE VOTING. NOT NO,
BUT JUST HELL NO. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT. WELL, I THINK WE'VE HAD A
THOROUGH DISCUSSION, AND I DO
HAVE SOME COMMENTS TO MAKE. AND
AS I MENTIONED, I HAVE FOUR
REFINERIES IN MY DISTRICT, AND I
THINK WE'VE ALL AGREED THAT
REFINERIES ARE COMPLEX
FACILITIES THAT REQUIRE REGULAR
MAINTENANCE TO ENSURE SAFETY NOT
ONLY TO EMPLOYEES, BUT TO
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
AND THIS MAINTENANCE IS OFTEN
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS TURNAROUND
OR PERFORMED ROUGHLY EVERY TWO
YEARS. AND WHEN TIME BETWEEN
THESE TURNAROUNDS IS EXTENDED,
OR THE SCOPE OF THE WORK
PERFORMED IS LIMITED, WORKERS
AND THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
ARE PUT AT RISK, AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO LOOK FAR BACK TO 2015.
IN TORRANCE, IN MY DISTRICT,
THOSE CONSTITUENTS STILL
REMEMBER THAT EXPLOSION THAT
HAPPENED AND THAT'S STILL ON
THEIR MINDS. SB X1 TWO, WHICH
WAS WAS LAST YEAR'S SPECIAL
SESSION BILL, GRANTED THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE AUTHORITY TO
CONSIDER WAYS TO MANAGE
NECESSARY REFINERY TURNAROUNDS
AND MAINTENANCE THAT WOULD
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT OF
MAINTENANCE RELATED PRODUCTION
LOSSES ON FUEL PRICES. WHILE
THIS MEASURE REQUIRED
CONSULTATION WITH THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AND
LABOR AND INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS,
IT DID NOT REQUIRE THE
CONSULTATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. THAT'S
WHY LAST YEAR I AUTHORED SB 842
TO ADDRESS SERIOUS CONCERNS.
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO
REFINERY SAFETY THAT COULD BE
LEFT UP TO BUREAUCRATS WITH NO
REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE ON HOW TO
OPERATE A REFINERY, AND MANY
HAVE NEVER EVEN VISITED A
REFINERY. AND THAT'S REAL TALK.
SB 842 WOULD HAVE REQUIRED THE
ENERGY COMMISSION TO ADD THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO THE LIST OF
COMMISSIONS THAT WOULD BE
CONSULTED IF THEY DEVELOP
REGULATIONS RELATED TO
SCHEDULING OR RESCHEDULING OF
MAINTENANCE OF REFINERIES. THIS
WOULD HAVE ENSURED THAT THERE
WAS COORDINATION ACROSS
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES THAT HAVE A
ROLE IN REGULATING REFINERIES
AND ENSURE SAFETY IS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE COMMISSION'S
EFFORTS. 842 WAS VETOED. AS WE
ALL KNOW, LAST YEAR, AND WOULD
HAVE REQUIRED THE COMMISSION TO
CONSULT WITH THE LABOR AND
INDUSTRIAL STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER
TO AVOID ADVERSE IMPACTS TO THE
SAFETY OF EMPLOYEES AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. I
CONTINUE TO RAISE THOSE SAME
CONCERNS THAT THE DECISIONS
REGARDING SCHEDULING A REFINERY
AND MAINTENANCE SHOULD NOT BE
LEFT UP TO BUREAUCRATS, BUT
SHOULD BE IN THE HANDS OF THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO THIS WORK
ON A DAILY BASIS OF OPERATING
THESE COMPLEX FACILITIES. THEY
ARE THE ONES WHO NOT ONLY WORK
THERE, BUT THEY LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND IN THE LINE. AND
I'M SORRY, LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES AND SHOULD
MAINTENANCE SHOULD NOT BE
NEGLECTED OR COMPROMISED. THEY
LIVE IN THE COMMUNITIES AND
UNDERSTAND THE RISKS THAT NOT
ONLY THEIR FAMILIES, BUT TO
THEIR NEIGHBORS AS WELL. I'M
ENCOURAGED BY AB X12, WHICH
INCLUDES A PROVISION THAT
REQUIRES AN INDEPENDENT CONSUMER
FUELS ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO MEET
ANNUALLY AND ENSURE LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE. AND THAT'S CRITICAL.
HOWEVER, SINCE THE PASSAGE OF,
AGAIN SB ONE TWO LAST YEAR, THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE, WHOSE JOB IS
TO ADVISE THE ENERGY COMMISSION
AND THE DIVISION OF PETROLEUM
MARKET OVERSIGHT ON THE MERIT OF
GASOLINE POLICIES, INCLUDING
SAFETY, HAS YET TO MEET BECAUSE
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS YET TO
APPOINT THE SIX INDIVIDUALS TO
SERVE ON THAT COMMITTEE. SO HOW
CAN WE SAY SAFETY IS A PRIORITY
HERE WHEN WE HAVE YET TO CONVENE
THIS COMMITTEE? AB TWO ONE
PROPOSES LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES
REFINERIES TO PREPARE RESUPPLY
PLANS OR OTHER ARRANGEMENTS TO
ENSURE THE LOSS OF PRODUCTION
DURING TURNAROUND OR MAINTENANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON THE FUEL MARKET. BUT
REFINERIES ARE ALREADY OBLIGATED
TO MEET THESE GASOLINE SUPPLY
AGREEMENTS DURING TURNAROUNDS.
AS NOTED BY LABOR GROUPS,
NOTHING SHOULD DELAY OR PREVENT
NECESSARY TURNAROUND WORK.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SEEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THE CONSEQUENCES OF
LEGISLATIVE OVERREACH, AND I
THINK MY VICE CHAIR KIND OF
SPOKE TO THAT. THE AMENDMENTS
HERE TODAY MOVE THIS BILL IN A
BETTER DIRECTION. BUT I STILL
HAVE STRONG RESERVATIONS
REGARDING THIS LEGISLATION. Ã
PROPONENTS ARGUE THAT REFINERIES
CONTROL AN EXTREME PORTION OF
THE MARKET AND CREATE CONDITIONS
FOR PRICE SPIKES. BUT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ADOPTED A
POLICY TO PHASE OUT OIL
PRODUCTION OR TO MOVE AWAY FROM
PETROLEUM, WHICH SENDS A MARKET
SIGNAL THAT HAS A DIRECT IMPACT
ON COSTS AND REDUCES PRODUCTION
AS WELL. AND AS HE STATED, WE
ALSO HAVE LWCF, WE HAVE GAS TAX,
WE HAVE CAP AND TRADE. ALL OF
THOSE HAVE TO BE FACTORED IN.
THAT IMPACT PRICES THAT DON'T
EXIST IN ANY OTHER STATE. SO I
FEAR MANY TIMES THAT WE'RE
PUTTING INVENTORY QUOTAS BEFORE
SAFETY AND BEFORE REAL PRICING.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS. AND I JUST HAD A
QUESTION AS IT RELATES TO THE
COMMISSION IS NOW THREE MONTHS
BEHIND IN RELEASING THE REPORT
ON THE GROSS GASOLINE REFINING
MARGIN DATA. WHAT'S CAUSING THAT
DELAY AND HOW CAN WE JUSTIFY
MORE REQUIREMENTS ON REFINERIES,
OR HOW CAN WE JUSTIFY MORE
REQUIREMENTS ON REFINERIES WHEN
OUR OWN AGENCIES HAVE FAILED TO
RESPOND IN A TIMELY MANNER?
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AS WELL AS
ALWAYS. WE HAVE AS OF APRIL,
STOPPED PUTTING THE INFORMATION
OUT SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE WHILE
WE'RE GATHERING THE INFORMATION,
NONE OF THE INFORMATION IS
INDEPENDENTLY VETTED BY CÁC. WE
REPORT FAITHFULLY THE
INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED
TO THE CÁC. AND AS DIRECTOR
MILLER MENTIONED EARLIER, SOME
OF THE INFORMATION THAT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED TO US DID NOT COMPORT
WITH WHAT OTHER DATA POINTS ARE
SHOWING. SO WE HAVE REQUESTED
THE INDUSTRY TO COME BACK TO US
AGAIN. I WILL I WILL NOTE FIRST
AND DISCLAIM THAT THE INDUSTRY
HAS BEEN REALLY GOOD PARTNERS ON
PROVIDING THE INFORMATION. BUT
IN THIS ONE CASE, SPECIFICALLY
AROUND THIS DATA, IT HAS TAKEN
US MULTIPLE MONTHS OF REQUESTS
TO COLLECT THAT DATA. WE'RE JUST
GETTING THAT INFORMATION NOW,
THE CORRECTED INFORMATION. AND
SO ONCE WE HAVE IT AND WE
PROCESS IT, WE'LL POST IT AGAIN.
BUT IT'S NOT FOR LACK OF DATA
COLLECTION. IT'S JUST WE JUST
DON'T WANT TO INADVERTENTLY PUT
OUT PUBLICLY INACCURATE DATA.
OKAY. AND SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ALREADY ASKED THE QUESTION
OF HOW DO WE STOCKPILE THIS FUEL
IF YOU'RE ALREADY AT CAPACITY AT
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE YEAR
ALREADY, HOW HOW WILL THESE
REFINERIES ADDRESS THAT OR BE
ABLE TO MEET THAT REQUIREMENT?
YEAH. AND FAIR QUESTION, CHAIR,
I THINK WE'RE NOT TALKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE WHOLE
YEAR. WE'RE LOOKING AT SPECIFIC
MONTHS AROUND JULY, AUGUST,
SEPTEMBER, OCTOBER. THAT'S THE
TIME WHEN WE REALLY DEPLOY IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK BACK ON THOSE AVERAGE
INVENTORIES. WE'RE GOING TO LOOK
AT THE SPACE THAT'S AVAILABLE
BASED AGAIN ON THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE INDUSTRY, TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT ALL THE GUARDRAILS
YOU'RE PUTTING IN AND LOOK FOR
ANY EFFICIENCIES THAT COULD BE
GAINED, THRESHOLD LEVEL, YOU
KNOW, INFORMATION WHICH WE CAN
PROVIDE TO YOU TODAY THAT'S
AGGREGATED. WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED BY LAW TO
PROVIDE YOU INDIVIDUAL REFINERY
DATA, BUT AGGREGATE, WE CAN SHOW
YOU THAT THERE IS PLENTY OF
CAPACITY THAT WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
COULD INCREASE THE EFFICIENCY OF
STORAGE. AGAIN, IT DEPENDS
REFINERY BY REFINERY, AND WE'RE
GOING TO WORK WITH THEM CLOSELY.
AND AS WE STATED, OUR DEPENDENCY
ON THESE PETROLEUM PRODUCTS ARE
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY ANYTIME
SOON. BUT UNDERSTANDING THE
REDUCTION IN PRODUCTION AND
EXTRACTION HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
DO YOU THINK IT LEADS US TO BE
MORE DEPENDENT ON FOREIGN
RESOURCES? THAT TAKES AS MUCH AS
30 DAYS TO IMPORT. SO AGAIN,
THAT'S KIND OF YOU KNOW, I
CANNOT COMMENT ON THE BROADER
STATE POLICY, BUT I WOULD NOTE
THAT, YOU KNOW, AS VICE CHAIR,
DALLI MENTIONED IN MANY OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS OF THE PAST
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMERS IN OTHER WAYS. AND I
THINK FOUNDATIONALLY, YOU KNOW,
YOU KNOW, DEFER TO THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY, BUT ALSO, YOU
KNOW, THE ADMINISTRATION ON HOW
BEST TO STRUCTURE THE HOLISTIC
PLAN, BUT WITHIN THE CONFINES OF
WHAT YOU'VE ASKED US TO DO
WITHIN THE TRANSITION PLAN, WE
ARE GOING TO PUT THAT OUT
CAREFULLY, LOOKING AT ALL THE
OPTIONS ON THE TABLE. YOU HAD A
YEAH, I WANTED TO JUST RESPOND
TO THE SYSTEM WIDE KIND OF
BROADER ENERGY POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA AS IT RELATES TO
PETROLEUM PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA. WE DID PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE CDC AND
SHARED WITH YOUR OFFICES THAT
THERE IS AN IMPACT TO IMPORTED
CRUDE, AND WE PROVIDED THIRD
PARTY DATA TO SHOW THAT. I THINK
THE CDC DATA IS ALSO SHOWING
THAT THAT IF YOU'RE IMPORTING
CRUDE, THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
COST ASSOCIATED WITH THAT FROM
THE MIDDLE EAST. IT'S 5 TO $6
FROM THE SILICON VALLEY OR THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY PIPELINE.
IT'S ABOUT A DOLLAR A BARREL. SO
THERE'S AN IMPACT TO IMPORTING
VERSUS HAVING IT PRODUCE HERE IN
THE STATE. AS IT RELATES TO
IMPORTS. I THINK WHAT THE CDC
DATA IS SHOWING IS THAT PORT
TRAFFIC IS PROBABLY GOING TO
PICK UP. WE ARE PROBABLY GOING
TO RELY MORE ON FINISHED
GASOLINE PRODUCT COMING INTO THE
STATE, WHICH IS GOING TO CROWD
UP TO THE PORTS. WHAT WE HAVE
GOING INTO EFFECT JANUARY 1ST,
2025. AND WE'VE RAISED THIS
CONCERN WITH THE CDC, IS THE AT
BERTH RULE. AND THAT IS A NEW
REQUIREMENT TO EITHER PLUG IN OR
HAVE CAPTURE TECHNOLOGY TO
CAPTURE THE EMISSIONS COMING OFF
OF THE SHIP. WE DON'T SEE A
PATHWAY FOR COMPLIANCE FOR THAT
RULE, AND WE HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SUPPLY
IMPLICATIONS THAT WILL HAVE COME
JANUARY 1ST. I WANT TO BE
REDUNDANT BECAUSE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY ASKED
QUESTIONS AS IT RELATES TO JUST
STORAGE, STORAGE THAT WE'VE
ALREADY ADDRESSED. AND I'M JUST
HOPING THIS DOESN'T HAVE A
NEGATIVE EFFECT OF DRIVING UP
PRICES. I MEAN, THIS IS ALL
ABOUT THE URGENCY OF NOW, BUT
NOTHING HERE IS WILL HAVE AN
IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON FUEL PRICES
STARTING TOMORROW OR NEXT 30
DAYS OR THE NEXT SIX MONTHS. SO
I JUST WANT TO BE MINDFUL THAT
WE ARE DOING IT IN A SAFE AND
METHODICAL WAY. THAT REALLY
TAKES IN ALL THOSE FACTORS, NOT
ONLY SACK SAFETY, BUT THE
CONSUMER AS WELL, BECAUSE I
SUPPORT THE MEASURE AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE, AND IT'S IMPORTANT. BUT
I THINK WE JUST NEED TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR HART,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART IS READY.
THANK YOU. TO THE CHAIR AND TO
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR THE ROBUST CONVERSATION AND
FOR THE HARD WORK OF COMMITTEE
STAFF. I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER RIVAS AND
SENATE PRO TEM MCGUIRE FOR
CONVENING A SECOND EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION TO ADDRESS SURGING GAS
PRICES IN OUR STATE. WE DO NOT
HAVE TO TRADE OFF WORKER SAFETY
FOR CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. THIS
BILL CAN BE IMPLEMENTED WHILE
SAFEGUARDING EXISTING STATE AND
FEDERAL LABOR REGULATIONS. THE
DATA SHOWS THAT CRUDE OIL SUPPLY
IS NOT A CAUSE OF REFINED FUEL
SUPPLY CONSTRAINTS, AND HAS NOT
LED TO GASOLINE PRICE SPIKES,
CURRENT STORAGE INFRASTRUCTURE
AT THE REFINERIES AND TERMINALS
ARE SUFFICIENT TO MAINTAIN
POTENTIAL MINIMUM INVENTORY
REQUIREMENTS. THIS BILL WILL
HOLD OIL COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR RESUPPLY PLANS WHEN
REFINERIES, SHUTDOWNS AND SUPPLY
CHAIN DISRUPTIONS OCCUR,
ULTIMATELY SAVING CALIFORNIANS
MONEY ON GASOLINE SALES. AB TWO
ONE IS SUPPORTED BY SEIU, UFCW,
W LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEADERS
ACROSS THE STATE, ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND CEJA, AND
CONSUMER RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
COLLEAGUES, I URGE YOU TO VOTE
AYE ON AB TWO ONE. LET'S TAKE
LET'S TAKE ACTION NOW TO PROVIDE
RELIEF FOR CALIFORNIANS FROM
GASOLINE PRICE SPIKING THE
STATUS QUO IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
BECAUSE IT IS COSTING CONSUMERS
BILLIONS AT THE GAS PUMP. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON AB
TWO ONE CHEN? IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR STERN, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLE ON AB TWO ONE. AND
IT'S A MOTION TO ADOPT AND SEND
TO SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. DO PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR BRADFORD Ã BRADFORD, A
DALLY NO DILLY DALLY NO. ASHBY.
ASHBY I BECKER I BECKER I
LARKSPUR I LARKSPUR I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I LAIRD I LAIRD I LEMON
LIMON I CIERTO CIERTO NO.
SKINNER I SKINNER I STERN STERN
I 9 TO 2. THAT MEASURE HAS NINE
YESES. TWO. NO VOTES. IT'S OUT
THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR HEARING.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN HART FOR HIS WORK
HERE TODAY AND ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES, OUR VICE CHAIR, FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. AND THIS WILL
CONCLUDE OUR COMMITTEE ON FUEL
SUPPLY AND PRICE SPIKES. WE'RE
NOW STAND ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.